la séance est reprise j'ai donné tout de
suite la parole à madame Colette mélo
pour une mise au point sujet d'un vote
et puis merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs nous
souhaitons effectuer une rectification
de vote sur le scrutin numéro 233
les sénateurs chassins de colle et what
Blade souhaitent s'abstenir en vous
remerciant
je vous remercie de prendre en compte
cette demande merci je vais donner la
parole à Monsieur Hitman
merci madame la Présidente je souhaite
faire la mise au point suivantes sur le
scrutin public numéro 233 ma collègue
Sylviane Noël souhaitait voter contre et
mon collègue Didier mandeli souhaitait
s'abstenir merci merci à tes données de
vos mises au point elle figureront dans
l'analyse politique du scrutin concerné
alors nous reprenons la discussion du
projet de loi de financement
rectificatif de la sécurité sociale pour
2023 dans la discussion des articles
nous sommes parvenus à la présentation
de la vie du rapporteur sur les sous
amendements à son amendement numéro 2127
à l'article 8 et je vais demander un
tout petit peu moins de bruit et je vais
passer la parole donc à monsieur le
rapporteur
oui merci donc nous revoilà à cet
amendement particulièrement important
qui prend en compte les maires de
famille
et je voulais simplement par rapport à
la présentation qui avait été faite
d'une part par Monsieur le Ministre tout
à l'heure et ensuite par moi-même pour
montrer le principe qui nous ont animés
au niveau de la commission des affaires
sociales pour prendre en compte de façon
la plus précise possible ces difficultés
rencontrées par les maires de famille
qui ont une carrière arraché vous
rappelez simplement quelques éléments il
suffit d'une majoration de trimestres
liés soit à l'éducation des enfants soit
à la maternité ce qui veut dire que ça
touche les mères quelque soit le nombre
d'enfants mais également ça peut toucher
les pères de famille puisque il y a
redistribution des des trimestres de
majoration qu'une telle mesure nous
l'avons préféré à un départ anticipé
d'âge ouverture des droits ce que vous
proposez pourquoi parce que je voulais
déjà dit tout à l'heure il y avait une
différence de traitement liée au genre
des personnes et ceux qui rentrer à
l'encontre du droit européen mais
également parce que ce n'est pas tout à
fait le même coup et c'est je crois
madame Raymond c'est mange qui avait
soulevé cela une surcote de 5% sur le
plan du montant est effectivement
équivalent à une année de retraite
puisque la surcote porte sur un
une disposition actuelle qui fait qu'on
estime qu'une durée moyenne de retraite
est en de 20 ans quand vous avez 5% de
façon complémentaire vous avez les 100%
autour de 20 ans ça correspond à une
année de départ anticipé sauf sauf que
il y a d'un côté ces 5% qui sont viagés
répartis sur 20 ans ce qui est déjà
signifiécatif que de l'autre côté vous
perdriez directement ça veut dire que
vous en prenant de façon anticiper la
carrière vous avez un coût qui tombe
directement sur le sur le système de
retraite que cette mesure qu'on leur dit
insuff vous présenter oui je partage
c'est jamais suffisant peut-être que on
peut éventuellement l'élargir et ça a
été proposé à travers un amendement
l'élargir jusque 30 62 ans non à 62 ans
dans le régime actuel vous n'avez pas de
surcote puisque pour aller la surcote il
faut aller non seulement avoir son taux
plein mais allez au-delà de l'âge légal
donc on peut avoir une surcote dans le
régime actuel à partir de 62 ans et un
trimestre qui correspond à 1,25 % de
surcote que vous avez tout au long de
votre carrière et là jusque 3 4
trimestres nous avons contingenté la
mesure à quatre trimestres de façon à ce
que le coût soit raisonnable mais si
monsieur le ministre vous souhaitez
qu'on aille un peu plus loin pour rester
dans le droit actuel et gagner encore
donc trois trimestres ne vous gênez pas
pour donner un avis favorable parce que
à ce moment-là on dépassera le droit
actuel donc il me faut votre
autorisation et franchement je
préférerais qu'on fasse un effort pour
les maires de famille plutôt que par des
mesures d'âge qui ratent leur cible mais
on aura l'occasion
discuter tout à l'heure c'est un avis
strictement personnel que je me permets
de vous dire en tout cas notre mesure
pas suffisante touchera néanmoins 30%
des femmes d'une génération 30% des
femmes d'une génération qui liquide une
génération par rapport au nombre de
femmes qui liquide leur retraite sur une
génération ça me paraît significative ça
coule touche quand même 130 000
personnes donc c'est un dispositif qui
mérite toute votre attention et qui
compte tenu des explications que je
voudrais donner que j'espère le plus
clair possible nous permet de vous
proposer de prendre cette mesure et pas
les autres que ils sont traduites à
travers vos sous amendements parce que
c'est celle qui correspond le plus aux
préoccupations de nos maires de famille
et qui conduisent je le répète une fois
encore mais des fois on peut être
répétitif dans ce débat à une diminution
des niveaux de pension entre les hommes
et les femmes je vous remercie merci la
vie du gouvernement monsieur le ministre
merci beaucoup madame la Présidente je
me suis exprimé longuement à la fin de
la discussion générale sur l'article
donc comme je l'avais promis je vais
être bref le gouvernement soutient
l'amendement adopté par la commission
des affaires sociales parce qu'il a ce
double mérite à la fin de permettre le
maintien d'un avantage de temps sous
forme de majoration durée de
d'affiliation régime pour les femmes et
plus largement les assurés bénéficiant
de trimestres dit familiaux qui n'ont
pas une carrière complète au moment de
l'âge d'ouverture des droits et parce
qu'il permet une surcote pour celles qui
au contraire ont atteint la durée
d'affiliation requise à 63 ans et alors
qu'il restera quatre trimestres à
travailler donc c'est un avis favorable
c'est un avis défavorable pour les mêmes
raisons que c'est l'évoquée par monsieur
le rapporteur y compris les questions de
l'équilibre budgétaires pour l'ensemble
des sous amendements je fais juste une
parenthèse pour dire que un certain
nombre d'intervention ont souligné la
difficulté qui subsiste quand elle est à
la différence de niveau de pension entre
les hommes et les femmes c'est
évidemment à la fois un constat et un
regret qui sont partagés mais la réalité
de la solution
pour que les pensions des hommes et les
pensions des femmes sont identiques ne
tient pas au système de retraite mais
bien l'égalité professionnelle et à la
résorption des inégalités tout au long
de la vie c'est un sacré chantier ça me
permettez cette familiarité et qui
dépasse très largement le cadre de ce
projet de loi donc défavorable sur tous
les amendements et favorable au 21 27 de
Monsieur Savary
merci alors pour explication de vote à
mes précédentes rossignol
d'accord mais
oui Vivi on va faire on va faire
globalement voilà merci madame la
Présidente merci beaucoup alors je vais
faire un explication de votre sur
l'amendement ça varie avant j'inverse un
peu d'abord pour dire une chose c'est
que c'est amendement c'est l'ambulance
qui suit l'offensif terrestre contre la
retraite à 62 ans et que bien entendu
comme on est respectueux des conventions
on ne va pas tirer sur l'ambulance c'est
pour ça que nous voterons cet amendement
ce qui me concerne je voterai pour
autant j'ai quelques remarques à faire
sur cet amendement la première concerne
un peu les sous amendements monsieur
rapporteur on pourrait faire et les
majorations de durée d'assurance et
l'augmentation de et la surcote l'un
n'est pas contradictoire de l'autre
quand on a 35% des cas de rémunération
entre les femmes et les hommes on
pourrait aussi augmenter spécifiquement
les pensions des femmes
première remarque deuxième remarque
ça concerne la nature des écarts de
salaire entre les écarts de pension
entre les hommes et les femmes il y a
deux facteurs premiers facteurs c'est
effectivement les carrières trouées
deuxième facteur c'est la faiblesse des
rémunérations des femmes pendant toute
leur durée d'activité qui impactent
aussi leur montant de pension et de ce
point de vue là votre amendement qui est
spécifiquement réservé aux maires de
famille
fait l'impasse sur les inégalités
salariales sur le fait que il n'y a pas
que les maires de famille
malheureusement qui souffrent de
rémunération insuffisante et
inégalitaire les femmes qui n'ont pas
d'enfants sont dans la même situation
l'écart résiduel de rémunération entre
les femmes et les hommes et de 9%
indépendamment des carrières celui qui
reste à post égal travailler égal
diplôme égal donc en excluant toutes les
femmes qui ne sont pas mère de famille
de cet amendement vous ne répondez pas à
l'écart de rémunération spécifique entre
les femmes et les hommes qui impactent
également la carrière des femmes qui ne
sont pas mère de famille enfin je ne
crois pas je pense cette mesure est
utile mais je j'ai un doute sur sa
dimension nataliste pour tout vous dire
je connais peu de jeunes femmes qui a
28,30 ans se demande si au moment où
elle veut le mettre un bébé en route
elles auront ou non une surcote ce
qu'elles veulent savoir c'est c'est pour
travailler élever leurs enfants avoir un
logement
avoir une crèche et ne pas souffrir dans
leur carrière du fait d'être mère de
famille merci la parole est à Madame A
poursu poli
ah d'accord ok merci
merci madame la Présidente mes chers
collègues j'ai eu à au moins à deux
reprises l'occasion de m'exprimer par
rapport à cet amendement en réalité et à
la logique politique qu'il suit à la
fois quand j'ai présenté pour mon groupe
la motion référendaire et encore et
encore hier en fait ce qui n'est pas
juste et nous l'avons dit à plusieurs
reprises c'est le fait d'allonger l'âge
de départ à la retraite à 64 ans qui
pénalise plus particulièrement les
femmes toutes les femmes qu'elle soit
mère de famille ou pas mère de famille
les explications vous les a donné par
rapport aux carrières hachées par
rapport aux inégalités salariales mais
vous n'avez pas voulu les entendre que
ce soit aux banc du gouvernement ou au
niveau de nos de notre rapporteur nous
avons eu également nous nous avions fait
un amendement global pour réécrire
cette cette amendement finalement il a
été il a été rejeté donc vous ne en rien
la problématique des femmes qui ont des
petites des carrières hachées des petits
des petits salaires et qui vont être
pénalisés par cette elles sont les
grandes perdantes je les dis encore hier
lors de la question d'actualité même si
le ministre essaye de démontrer le
contraire alors en réalité évidemment
comme nos collègues socialistes comme
c'est un petit plus c'est un petit mieux
pour quelques femmes cet amendement on
va le voter mais c'est vraiment
totalement insuffisant et ça ne répond
pas à la demande des femmes et puis moi
je voudrais vous donner la proposition
des communistes qui régleraient cette
cette question de surcote nous vous le
montant du congé parental d'éducation en
fait on est pour qu'il soit équivalent à
100% du salaire ce qui éviterait
justement la question de la surcotte il
ne me dites pas que vous n'avez pas
l'argent on a plein de solutions pour
financer ces mesures mais vous les
refusez alors en attendant que vous
réfléchissiez et bien on va voter ce
petit pas très petit mais c'est faut
commencer par quelque chose merci
beaucoup madame ponce
oui merci madame la Présidente
je voudrais dire monsieur le ministre
que tout à l'heure il a dit quelque
chose il a raison il a dit
l'effacement enfin la neutralisation des
trimestres enfants n'est pas que du
l'allongement d'âge il est dû aussi au
fait que les femmes travaillent plus
c'est l'effet générationnels les faits
noria il a raison à deux tiers un tiers
parce que un tiers effectivement des
trimestres ont été effacés par la loi
2010 pour 2017 et là ça va être ça va
être encore plus important je pense nous
vous l'avons dit 120
000 femmes par génération aujourd'hui
partent à 62 ans et de toute façon font
ce choix elles ont donc les deux
conditions elles le et appart à taux
plein donc cette trimestre des
trimestres enfants vont tous là devenir
des trimestres travaillés monsieur le
rapporteur la surcote effectivement vous
l'avez dit c'est une neutralité
actuariale mais l'esprit de la surcote
c'est le volontariat
aujourd'hui pour ces femmes si vous
voulez à 62 ans elle pouvait travailler
encore deux ans et on l'a dit elles
auraient eu 10% 10% de surcotte 10% de
surcotes c'est parce que effectivement
leur patrimoine retraite c'était neutre
sur leur patrimoine retraite c'est à
dire que les deux ans qu'elle n'avaient
pas elles ne gagnerait par la surcotte
aujourd'hui vous leur en donner la
moitié je parle des 120 000 femmes en
leur en donnant la moitié vous faites
baisser le patrimoine retraite de ces
femmes de ces femmes qui utilisaient
majoritairement leur trimestre d'enfant
nous vous l'avons dit les mesures d'âge
sont anti redistributives elles
accroisse les inégalités
toutefois et vous préférez ça
effectivement au départ parce que
effectivement vous voulez qu'on produise
plus et vous voulez surtout respecter le
pack de stabilité à court terme et vous
l'avez dit monsieur le rapporteur c'est
pas pareil en termes de termes de court
terme donc c'est pour ça que vous
préférez la surcote donc tout comme mes
collègues comme ça limite c'est une
mesure une des mesures de dénation de la
brutalité de la réforme bien entendu
nous la voterons avec tout toutes ces
considérations
merci madame la Présidente oui
effectivement cette amendement c'est une
petite mesure de compensation que vous
avez négocié mais qui ne va pas annuler
la brutalité de cette loi vous avez au
moins le mérite de la cohérence avec cet
article 8 parce que dans la casse de
notre service de dans notre système de
solidarité avec cette volonté que vous
avez de faire travailler plus deux ans
de plus nos concitoyens quel que soit
leur difficulté et la durée de leur
carrière il y aura peut-être d'autres
mesures de compensation votées mais
quand même
vouloir au départ faire travailler deux
ans de plus des parvailleurs qui sont
déclarés inapte au travail les
allocataires de la hache les
accolocataires de la location de
cessation anticipées d'activité des
travailleurs ayant une carrière longue
les travailleurs handicapés les
travailleurs qui ont une incapacité
permanente à la suite d'un accident de
travail ou une maladie professionnelle
les fonctionnaires handicapés les
fonctionnaires enfin n'arrivez pas en
rajouter on est vraiment là dans cette
volonté un moment donné dans le
brutalité de faire travailler plus les
personnes les plus fragiles et les plus
précaires bon bien évidemment les femmes
ont la tous dit ici sont les grandes
perdantes de cela et je le redis ce
n'est pas cette petite mesure qui va
améliorer leur retraite ce que je
voulais dire quand même en accord avec
mes collègues c'est que nous le voterons
quand même il vaut mieux tenir que
courir
merci Madame alors Monsieur Hainaut
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre alors nous voterons cette
amendement pour des motifs d'équilibre
des principes de d'équilibre de justice
et puis aussi de valeur
parce que évidemment il faut plus de
justice vis-à-vis des femmes il y a une
injustice ça a été dit au niveau de la
rémunération entre les femmes et les
hommes 10% à salaire à fonction égale ou
à diplôme égal et c'est insupportable
mais on peut pas tout attendre non plus
du du système de retraite je veux le
dire au collègue se soucier de cette
injustice à l'occasion d'une réforme de
du système de retraite c'est juste mais
on s'en est pas toujours soucier autant
et notamment à l'occasion de la réforme
Touraine sans ouvrir à nouveau la
polémique tout de même je veux le
signaler donc on peut pas tout attendre
de cette de cette réforme nous on aurait
même voulu peut-être aller plus loin
mais on prend effectivement
cette amendement et puis on a retiré nos
amendements pour que nous allions au
bout de cette discussion et nous y
tenons beaucoup et c'est pour nous
l'essentiel d'aller au bout de cette
discussion et puis pour des questions
d'équilibre aussi j'ai entendu madame
Vogel souvent je ne suis pas d'accord
avec elle mais je reconnais la
construction de de son argumentation
mais avec un système de retraite par
répartition il est tout à fait
indispensable légitime de s'occuper de
de démographie et de la dimension d'un
nataliste elle est intrinsèque au
système de répartition et enfin un
dernier mot sur la valeur pour nous la
famille ça n'est pas une j'ai entendu
tout ça tout à l'heure ça n'est ni une
idéologie ni doctrine c'est une valeur
mes chers collègues la famille ni une
doctrine ni des login inéditologie mais
une valeur et et pour nous
mère de famille ça n'est pas un gros mot
père de famille ça n'est pas un gros mot
et la valeur c'est même une valeur
essentielle une cellule de base de la
société comme disait Victor Hugo la
famille c'est la plus solide des
forteresses je vous remercie
monsieur mouillé
monsieur Cabanel
merci Madame madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Ministre et chers collègues
donc pour une fois on prend pas la
parole souvent parce que dans mon groupe
chacun est libre de son vote et pour une
fois nous avons donc tous voter c'est
amendement pour rendre la justice donc
aux femmes qui ont une carrière hachée
mais je vais profiter de la parole pour
expliquer donc ici quels sont notre
freelet notre frustration dans le groupe
de voir ce débat se dérouler comme il se
déroule on aimerait mieux qu'il y ait un
véritable débat ce qu'il me semble ne
pas y avoir alors certains reprochent à
la majorité sénatoriale d'avoir
déclenché des règlements
qui
mugellent un petit peu la parole des uns
et des autres je le regrette mais ils
n'ont été déclenchés qu'à partir de
l'article 7 et depuis le début il nous
semble que la gauche de cette hémicycle
veut ralentir le parce que moi depuis
que je suis dans cette maison c'est la
première fois que je vois des
amendements identiques portés
individuellement et qui donc cherche à
gagner du temps donc nous dans notre ADN
au sein du RDSE ce que nous voulons tous
ces débattre et nous voulons aller
jusqu'au bout donc il faudrait
clairement que chacun se prononce sur la
volonté d'aller au bout parce que il est
important il est de notre responsabilité
de débattre et de faire en sorte que les
Français comprennent un petit peu mieux
quelle est la volonté des débats que
nous avons et en tout cas c'est pas
l'image me semble-t-il que l'on nous
donne aujourd'hui nous dans notre
volonté c'est d'aller jusqu'au bout
merci
Monsieur chanterelle
[Applaudissements]
chanterelle
si madame la Présidente je voulais en
fait parler plus globalement de
l'article 8 en par parce que vous nous
en avez privé au tout début avec vos
artifices et votre volonté de nous
bâillonner au niveau des de nos prises
de parole au début monsieur chanterelle
vous vous parlez de des amendements
voilà et je vous remercie de laisser le
calme qui règne là dans l'hémicycle je
vous rassure c'est en lui
donc en tout cas c'est pas la présidence
qui parle c'est la présidence de la
droite on dirait mais bon
on voit en tout cas
vous pouvez demander une suspension de
séance je
reprends la parole monsieur chanterelle
monsieur chanterelle s'il vous plaît
je reprends la parole jamais vous
pourrez dire ça jamais tant mieux
pour tout le monde merci alors
maintenant je vous demande de faire
votre intervention et d'essayer de
garder le calme
alors
votre intimidation ne marchera pas merci
vous je sais que vous essayez je sais
que vous essayez de nous bâillonner de
nous intimider de plus plusieurs depuis
hier mais vous vous ne priverez pas les
français du débat
que ça soit à travers les coups de force
que vous faites depuis hier nous
continuerons nous continuerons à les
défendre même si ça vous plaît pas c'est
ça la démocratie il faut l'accepter donc
donc je par contre j'ai par contre j'ai
été coupé d'une minute mais bon
ce qu'il faut retenir justement de cet
article de du recul de l'âge de départ à
la retraite à 64 ans
je vais demander une suspension de
séance madame la Présidente
c'est c'est que le recul de là ce sont
les plus fragiles justement ce dont
parle l'amendement de Monsieur Savary et
les plus fragilisés qui seront punis par
cette réforme et au premier chef
celle et ceux qui bénéficient d'une
retraite anticipée comme le reste pas
beaucoup de temps je vais prendre le
temps par contre de les citer parce que
ce sont les personnes qui sont victimes
justement de votre de votre réforme ce
sont les titulaires d'une pension
d'invalidité les travailleurs déclarés
inapte au travail les allocataires de la
hache et de la location de cessation
anticipées d'activité les travailleurs
ayant eu une carrière longue les
travailleurs handicapés les travailleurs
qui ont une incapacité permanente à la
suite d'un accident du travail ou une
maladie professionnelle les
fonctionnaires handicapés les
fonctionnaires ayant eu
là c'est bon la parole est à Monsieur
karucci pour un rappel au règlement
madame la Présidente j'avais dit ce
matin que j'espérais je vous remercie
d'avoir suivi tout de suite
je me permets de dire à Monsieur
chanterelle et à l'ensemble de nos
collègues que si le climat restait
celui-là il faudrait appliquer la
totalité du règlement et dans la
totalité du règlement monsieur Chantrel
il y a un article 95 qui dit très
clairement que toute provocation toute
atteinte à la présidence de séance
entraîne la censure voir l'exclusion du
Sénat
Durand pour un rappel au règlement
madame la Présidente je sais que vous
avez la faculté de savoir ce qu'il y a
dans les amendements avant même de les
lire c'est ce qui est arrivé hier avec
la présidente de roche déclarant une
erreur validité sans même avoir lu nos
amendements et là vous avez eu vous la
faculté madame la Présidente de savoir
ce que notre collègue chanterelle allait
dire avant même de l'écouter parce qu'il
a juste dit qu'on voulait nous
bâillonner il a le droit de le dire et
la suite la suite
laissez parler monsieur Durin vous allez
jusqu'au bout mais je vous inviterai à
relire le compte rendu ensuite on
regardera la vidéo ensemble donc
la suite de la défense de l'amendement
la suite de la défense de la maman a
prouvé qu'on était bien sur le fond donc
je crois qu'il faut si vous voulez
effectivement éviter dans l'arrivée à
ces extrémités que nous promet monsieur
karucci on n'est pas obligé d'en arriver
là on n'est pas obligé d'en arriver là
donc je sais politiquement ça devient
compliqué sur ce texte parce qu'on voit
bien on a regardé les rectifications de
vote ça s'effrite et puis on voit bien
ce que dit la presse locale c'est pas
très populaire votre position on
comprend votre embarras on comprend
votre Amara donc laissez-nous travailler
vous connaissez notre attachement à
cette maison à l'ordre qui règne à la
qualité des débats qu'on sait produire
ensemble donc si vous contribuez au
calme et si tout se passe bien vous
pouvez compter sur nous
merci monsieur Durand mais il faut voir
les provocation de où elles viennent
quand même moi personnellement en tant
que Présidente je n'ai pas apprécié
voilà mes chers collègues je souhaite
sincèrement nos débats conservent la
sérénité qui fait la marque de fabrique
de notre assemblée et qui contribue à la
bonne image de notre travaux alors je
n'hésiterai pas afin de maintenir la
sérénité de nos débats à faire usage des
prérogatifs que le réglement confère à
la présidence de séance et se rappelle
ayant été fait nous reprenons le cours
normal de la discussion
et donc les explications de vote et
c'est Monsieur fier qui a la parole
merci madame la Présidente moi je
voterai l'amendement de notre apporteur
Savary et je ne le voterai pas parce que
j'ai l'article 7 honteux ou pour me
racheter ou pour me rattraper d'une
mauvaise action j'aurais commise au
contraire je le vote parce que il y a
une cohérence à demander certains
efforts et à corriger par ailleurs
certaines inégalités je moi je ne suis
pas économiste et je n'écoute pas les
économistes d'ailleurs parce que il y a
plutôt des raisons de s'en méfier moi je
me base sur ce que me disent les gens
que je rencontre qui travaillent aussi
dur que ceux que rencontre la partie
gauche de cette hémicycle qui travaille
durement et qui ont aussi un peu de bon
sens quand l'espérance de vie augmente
de 10 ans depuis 40 ans quand il y a
plus de départ en retraite que de gens
qui rentrent sur le marché du travail
quand la démographie baisse écoutez il y
a pas besoin d'avoir fait Polytechnique
pour se dire que les choses sont pas
équilibrées et qu'avec un peu de bon
sens et bien il faut que nous fassions
tous un effort supplémentaire et les
gens qui travaillent dur qui se lèvent
tôt le matin etc sont prêts aussi à le
faire quoi qu'on dise ils l'ont déjà
fait par exemple lorsqu'on a demandé de
travailler un jour de plus pour les
personnes âgées et la dépendance et je
crois que c'est aussi l'honneur nos
concitoyens c'est la marque de la
solidarité nationale quand on veut une
retraite par répartition que malgré les
difficultés la dureté du travail que
l'on que l'on a et bien on puisse faire
cet effort supplémentaire pour
équilibrer un régime des retraites et
éviter à nos enfants de payer à la fois
nos retraites et des dettes que nous
leur laisserons
[Applaudissements]
je vais faire un rappel aux règlements
par rapport à ce que ce qu'on a dit sur
le fait que Monsieur
[Musique]
chanterelle ne défendait pas
l'amendement lui a dit donc c'est un peu
pour et qui défendait pas l'amendement
et vous l'avez à juste titre pourquoi
pas couper en lui rappelant
effectivement que les propos doivent
elles sont propos vous semblaient hors
sujet mais
mais le collègue précédent a fait
exactement la même chose et
il a fait exactement la même chose il a
dit que le débat n'était pas intéressant
qu'on était dilatoire que c'était pas
qu'on me blague etc il a pas du tout
parlé de l'amendement absolument pas
pendant 2 minutes et alors et alors même
qu'on venait quand même de présenter des
arguments sérieux sur la surcote le
patrimoine retraite sur le fait qu'on
choisissait cette solution et pas une
autre à cause du rendement à court terme
ou à long terme tout de suite après il
prend la parole sur un amendement pour
nous tacler donc j'aimerais que toute
personne qui s'écarte de la défense de
l'amendement soit également sanctionné
merci Madame Lubin
merci madame la Présidente sur
l'amendement de du rapporteur ça varie
moi j'avoue que je suis très
circonspecte
bien évidemment bien évidemment par
rapport à la réforme qui nous est
protégé et par rapport oui par rapport à
ce qui nous est proposé l'article 5 là
pardon je suis en train de tout me
mélanger
les
5%, oui enfin c'est peut-être parce que
j'ai un boulot s'il vous plaît les 5%
les 5% de surcotte sont en mieux sont
une atténuation de ce que nous propose
le projet de loi on est bien d'accord
sauf que c'est moins
que ce que les femmes ont toujours dit
parce qu'aujourd'hui une femme captait
elle arrive à l'âge légal de la retraite
c'est-à-dire à 62 ans avec tous ces
trimestres si elle décide volontairement
de travailler jusqu'à 64 ans elle aura
10% de surcote
bah oui et donc là c'est certes mieux
que ce que nous propose le prochain le
projet de loi mais c'est bien moins que
ce que les femmes ont aujourd'hui et en
plus et en plus elles ont pas le choix
j'allais le dire Raymonde voilà elle non
pas le choix c'est-à-dire que
volontairement elles vont jusqu'à 64 ans
elles ont 10% là on les oblige à aller
jusqu'à 64 ans s'il y a 62 elles ont la
totalité de leur trimestre et on va
gentiment leur donner 5%. alors chers
collègues rapporteur je sais que c'est
sincère mais moi ça me plaît pas je sais
que beaucoup y compris voilà dans les
dans les rangs qui sont les miens trouve
que c'est plutôt pas mal moi à titre à
titre personnel à titre personnel
j'avoue que ça me c'est un amendement
qui ne qui ne me dérange pas bien
évidemment parce que parce que il est
construit tout ce qu'on veut mais c'est
un je ne le partage pas parce que
finalement c'est moins
que ce que elles ont aujourd'hui
merci Madame Vogel
merci madame la Présidente donc en effet
je crois que c'est important de le dire
et de le dire clairement l'amendement
sur lequel nous sommes amenés à voter va
consister à faire perdre des droits aux
femmes qui ont des enfants mais un peu
moins que ce qu'avait prévu le
gouvernement aujourd'hui les femmes qui
atteignent le taux plein à 62 ans avec
leur trimestre de majoration peuvent
choisir de s'arrêter de prendre leur
retraite à 62 ans ou bien de continuer à
travailler et dans ce cas là si elles
vont jusqu'à 64 ans elle bénéficie d'une
charcute de 10%
donc ce qui nous est proposé ici né en
aucun cas un progrès par rapport à
l'existant c'est un moindre recul pour
les seules personnes qui ont fait le
choix d'avoir des enfants ça n'aura
aucun effet sur les inégalités
structurelles entre les femmes et les
hommes dans la société que nous avons
proposé à de nombreuses reprises de
corriger par tout un tas de mesure que
vous avez systématiquement refusé je
voudrais juste finir en disant que pour
moi la famille n'est pas une valeur la
famille c'est une institution et comme
tous les institutions mais c'est pas un
gros mot institution excusez moi je sais
pas ce que c'est le problème que vous
avez avec le mot institution c'est une
institution comme toutes les
institutions ce sont des constructions
sociales et comme toutes les
constructions sociales elles ont
vocation à évoluer et nous avons le
projet de faire évoluer la famille pour
qu'elle soit moins concentrée sur l'idée
que la fille que la famille est une
affaire de femmes que les femmes sont là
pour faire des enfants et pour s'en
occuper
merci Monsieur Chaumier
merci
la Présidente je vais de expliquer
qu'elle va être mon vote puisque c'est
l'objet de cette intervention de cet
article auparavant je voulais dire que
les débats sont cette hémicycle même
s'ils sont entendus ne sont pas inutiles
et j'en veux pour preuve que depuis que
le vote a eu lieu sur le report à 64 ans
il y a une petite dizaine de collègues
qui ont abandonné le vote pour et l'ont
transformé en contre-abstention ce qui
veut dire que les arguments les
explications finissent par voilà un flux
sur notre position à chacun je voudrais
dire à mon collègue Bernard fialer
d'ailleurs que ce qui compte ça n'est
pas l'espérance de vie c'est l'espérance
de vie en bonne santé et quel stagne et
on ne sait pas ce qu'elle sera à
l'avenir d'ailleurs l'espérance de vie
globale va probablement régresser dans
les années à venir en tout cas comme aux
États-Unis l'espérance de vie en bonne
santé on n'en sait pas trop et je
conçois que cette définition est
d'ailleurs assez complexe mais toujours
est-il que quand on se fixe à cet
indicateur il n'y a pas vraiment de
motif d'arguments pour reporter l'âge
légal de la part de départ à retraite et
puis sur cette amendement du rapporteur
moi malgré les conditions dans lequel il
a été présenté et ce qui est une
manœuvre même si elle est réglementaire
qui a été menée pour aboutir à son
examen en priorité
évidemment c'est la question du verre à
moitié vide à moitié plein ou faut-il
atténuer accepter de voter l'atténuation
d'une d'un cadre général qui est très
négatif et c'était une atténuation qui
est partielle donc évidemment notre
groupe il réfléchit on est traversé on
est traversé sur cette question on n'a
pas une on n'est pas arrivé nous dans
cette hémicycle en ces temps mis
d'accord avec le gouvernement surtout et
en ayant une position de principe
surtout et donc je dis pas que tout le
monde on a vu que les votes changent je
l'ai dit donc je reconnais l'évolution
de chacun et donc peut-être que nos
votes seront différents sur cette
question moi je vais plutôt accepter la
proposition du rapporteur avec toutes
les réserves que j'ai expliqué merci
Monsieur longuet
oui merci Madame la présidence monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues le
groupe républicain soutient avec
conviction l'amendement 21-27 rectifiée
le soutien avec conviction parce que
c'est amendement à l'immense mérite
d'ouvrir enfin le débat sur une réalité
française c'est que le régime par
répartition ne peut durer que si nous
avons un équilibre des naissances au
regard de la durée de la vie en retraite
or vous évoquez avec nostalgie le CNR
qui en effet au printemps 1944 avant que
la France même soit libérée a fondé une
politique sociale
dont auquel auquel appartient évidemment
ce régime par répartition nous avions à
l'époque et les circonstances étaient
quand même tragiques pour notre pays une
natalité de 21 pour 1000
aujourd'hui nous sommes à 11 pour 1000
c'est-à-dire à peu près moitié moins
cette décrue a été particulièrement
forte au début du 21e siècle nous étions
encore à 14 pour 1000 en 2000 nous
sommes aujourd'hui à 11 pour 1000 il y a
une véritable interrogation
comme rapporteur de budget de
l'Éducation nationale je puis vous
rappeler qu'il y avait 820 000
naissances en France en 2012 il y a 10
ans il y en a cette année 720 000
environ c'est à dire une décrue de
100000 naissances en moins par an alors
que heureusement la vie s'allonge et que
le nombre de retraités ne peut
qu'augmenter et il faut s'en réjouir
votre amendement monsieur le rapporteur
rappelle c'est évidente qu'il évacue la
totalité du problème la réponse est non
mais si nous ne mettons pas le pied dans
la porte à cet instant nous serons
également en effet fondés à reconnaître
que nous avons manqué un rendez-vous
madame la Présidente je sais que vous
êtes très attentif on voudrait
simplement dire que la famille pour nous
est une valeur parce que c'est le
respect de la parole donnée de la parole
donnée à son conjoint
la parole est à Monsieur Breuillet non
non chers collègues
merci madame la Présidente pour ma part
je voterai cet amendement du rapporteur
Savary mais je le dis très honnêtement
je le vaut très par défaut
par défaut parce que
l'article 7 qui porte à 64 ans la mesure
d'âge plus l'amendement ça varie à cet
article 8 qui crée une surcote à 5%, ça
crée par rapport à la situation actuelle
c'est de articles additionnés ça crée un
recul un recul qui est plus limité que
le recul créé par le simple vote de
l'article 7 que vous avez voté hier
nuitamment mais un recul quand on
aggrave avec deux ans de plus puis qu'on
atténue avec une surcote cela reste une
aggravation c'est une aggravation
atténuée mais c'est une aggravation ma
deuxième remarque c'est que je le redis
j'ai entendu hier ou avant-hier une
proposition sur les groupes du centre
pour ne pas imposer le recul de la
mesure d'âge et je le dis c'est pareil
la surcote devrait rester un choix
personnel vous chers qui aident les
apôtres de la liberté très souvent
pourquoi ne pas laisser aux gens le
choix de la liberté parce qu'il y a des
personnes qui peuvent être cassées et
qui peuvent aspirer absolument à prendre
le retraites même avec une des cotes
vous le savez très bien d'ailleurs c'est
déjà le cas aujourd'hui donc laissons le
choix ne retardons pas la possibilité
pour chacune en l'occurrence de prendre
la retraite au moment où elle le décide
et laissons ce choix et puis enfin il me
reste que 14 secondes je veux dire que
je ne comprends pas ce débat sur le fait
que le travail ou la famille sont des
valeurs et j'aimerais qu'on prenne le
temps d'un débat évidemment un loi un
texte de loi de finance rectificative ne
se prête pas contraint dans le temps ne
se prête sans doute pas ce débat mais
c'est un débat très important et très
intéressant et la famille a beaucoup
changé vous le savez parfaitement donc
je ne sais pas ce que représente cette
valeur en tous les cas ce que je fais
c'est qu'il y a beaucoup de familles
très différentes merci merci Madame
meunier
et madame la Présidente je pense qu'on
assiste là un beau moment de débat
parlementaire moi j'ai eu l'occasion de
le dire avec la prise de parole sur
l'amendement et l'article 8 et donc
l'amendement présenté par notre
rapporteur Savary
par cet amendement les choses ne sont
pas réglées dans les inégalités entre
les femmes et les hommes les inégalités
de salaire les inégalités de pension les
accès à des métiers qui sont encore trop
réservés à des femmes dans des
catégories de domaine du médico-social
du soin des services à la personne bref
cet amendement ne règle pas c'est
amendement règles la question des femmes
qui ont trois enfants et qui vont
bénéficier d'une surcote moi j'ai pensé
au départ que c'était un peu meilleur
que s'il y avait rien enfin la situation
actuelle mais en vous entendant mes
chers collègues plutôt ici je sais pas
s'il faut voter c'est amendement en tout
cas le doute s'est installé en moi et je
pense que au final je m'abstiendrai
désolé monsieur ça va
si Monsieur mouillé
merci Madame le présidente j'aurai une
intervention en trois points tout
d'abord première intervention pour
soutenir l'amendement de rapporteurs et
la remercier d'avoir trouvé cette cette
plus-value notamment qui remet en valeur
notamment la natalité et donc les places
des femmes dans notre société on regarde
un effort collectif collectivement nous
nous mobilisons pour travailler plus
longtemps pour l'équilibre de nos
retraites et je crois que c'est un signe
important de pouvoir bien apporter cette
cette plus-value donc c'est pour moi la
première intervention deuxième
intervention on a beaucoup entendu des
des dans le débat des questionnements
sur l'égalité entre les femmes et les
hommes en matière de rémunération en
matière d'emploi c'est un vrai sujet
c'est un sujet que pour lequel de cela
doit s'emparer mais ce n'est pas du tout
l'objet du texte ce n'est pas du tout
l'objet du texte et donc aujourd'hui
nous devons nous concentrer sur les
enjeux concernant l'équilibre de nos
retraites et puis troisième point
concernant les personnes handicapées
j'ai entendu beaucoup d'interventions en
disant aujourd'hui la situation va être
beaucoup plus difficile
ils sont dans l'effort collectif mais si
vous regardez bien l'ensemble du texte
vous prenez le temps de lire le texte
aujourd'hui pour eux rien ne va changer
puisque de nouveau l'âge de 55 ans sera
un âge barrière pour pouvoir pas arrêter
en retraite anticipée simplement dans
les évolutions proposées par le
gouvernement ont simplifie des
procédures et donc on améliore leurs
conditions voilà donc je voulais le dire
parce que j'entends beaucoup de choses
autour de tout ça et si vous vous
souciez aujourd'hui de l'enjeu du
médico-social au cours de ces débats sur
les retraites moi j'ai un petit service
à vous demander collectivement demander
à ceux qui sont en train de couper
l'électricité en France des
établissements médico-sociaux d'arrêter
on aura un enjeu fondamental pour nous
merci Monsieur Retailleau sur le
président Retailleau
[Applaudissements]
c'est un moment du débat qui est
intéressant puisque je remercie le
rapporteur d'avoir porté cet amendement
dont nous avions fait auprès du
gouvernement je vous le rappelle chers
collègues une vraie ligne rouge
il est intéressant ce débat pour deux
raisons
il est intéressant d'abord parce que on
assiste à un rarement
d'une presque convergence entre nous ça
a été Rare il faut le souligner il est
aussi intéressant sur le plan politique
parce que vous voyez durant ces derniers
jours j'avais été accusé puisqu'à
l'origine aussi de cette amendement
j'avais été accusé de vouloir absolument
une politique nataliste et que la
politique nataliste c'était
l'abomination des abominations et je
vois qu'il y a une grande partie de la
gauche qui est restée fidèle à son
héritage l'héritage du Front populaire
qui a inventé
la location familiale universelle
enrichie ensuite avec le gaullisme le
CNR ils ont fondé les socles d'une
politique familiale nataliste pour ceux
qui aiment l'histoire bien sûr il y a
une petite partie de la gauche
rare ici dans notre hémicycle qui
considère que évidemment la famille ça
n'est pas une valeur et que il faut
déconstruire tout cela qu'il faut
tourner le dos à ses cadres collectifs
un destin commun au profit d'une
émancipation individuelle radicale mais
je suis heureux que au Sénat il yesset
de gauche social qui persiste et je me
suis toujours
j'ai regretté dans ma prof à vie
politique des dérives idéologiques pour
pouvoir le dire ici au sujet de la
gauche c'est un homme fondamental parce
que l'impensé de la réforme du
gouvernement c'est la démographie un
régime par répartition c'est un régime
justement de transition démographique et
intergénérationnel les femmes sont déjà
les grandes perdantes puisque vous
l'avez tous souligné les maires de
famille encore plus puisqu'on écrase les
trimestres de majoration avec les deux
années de recul c'est quelque chose de
fondamental on ne peut pas penser
l'avenir notre régime sans une politique
familiale qui soit une politique
familiale vraiment vigoureuse et
volontaire merci Monsieur le castor
sueur
je voulais remercier Monsieur
Retailleau pour sa contribution à
l'histoire du Front populaire
je voulais lui dire que cette
contribution est quelque peu orienté et
que c'est tout à fait contraire à la
réalité que de considérer que les hommes
et les femmes les ministres hommes et
femmes femmes et hommes qui étaient dans
le gouvernement du Front populaire était
contre ou aurait été contre une
politique de la famille ils ont au
contraire
fait beaucoup
fait beaucoup ils ont fait beaucoup à
cet égard ainsi et je vais dire aussi
que
nous nous instruisons chers collègues
dans le droit fil de cette politique du
Front populaire et quand vous essayez
quand vous essayez de nous présenter
comme étant en contradiction avec le
Front populaire franchement c'est une
imposture que nous ne pouvons accepter
merci chers collègues passer la parole à
Monsieur le Président Laurent
c'est ce que vient de dire le président
Retailleau qui m'incite à faire à mon
tour une explication de vote parce qu'il
faut être d'accord sur le sens de ce que
nous allons voter les uns et les autres
vous parlez de ligne rouge sur
Retailleau pour ce qui est de la réforme
des retraites c'est une ligne Maginot
parce que la régression sociale
va être massive avec les 64 ans et elle
va être massive pour tout le monde et
pour les maires de famille comme pour
les autres donc ça n'est en aucun cas
une ligne rouge qui empêche cette
régression sociale massive donc nous ne
sommes pas en train de créer une
conquête sociale puisque vous avez fait
référence aux Front populaire qui a été
une période de grande conquête sociale
nous sommes entrons dans le meilleur des
cas d'essayer de limiter un tout petit
peu les dégâts que va provoquer la
réforme que vous voulez absolument voter
et la deuxième chose que je veux dire
c'est qu'en matière de politique
familiale
le plus grave coût qui était porté à la
politique familiale française c'est le
jour où on a décidé que les entreprises
seraient totalement dégagées du
financement des allocations familiales
parce que vous avez décidé ce jour-là de
fiscaliser entièrement la politique
familiale et comme vous êtes les
premiers à expliquer tous les jours
qu'il faut baisser les dépenses
publiques c'est vous qui tarissez la
possibilité d'avoir une politique
familiale ambitieuse parce que vous avez
dégagé les entreprises
et la création de valeur ajoutée des
responsabilités en la matière et que
vous êtes les premiers à faire pression
sur le niveau des dépenses publiques et
des dépenses sociales donc ne nous
donnez pas des leçons en matière de
politique familiale merci
alors je vais donner la parole à
Monsieur le Rapporteur Savary et je vous
invite à rejoindre vos bancs pour le
scrutin public qui aura lieu ensuite
monsieur Kerrouche attendez monsieur le
rapporteur
on réagit tous
à aux prises de parole qui ont été dites
et juste pour corriger
il veut plus parler
je suis sûr que ça vous aurait manqué
donc je rallume
pourtant pourtant il va falloir
je vous remercie madame la Présidente
Bruno Retailleau ne veulent pas ne
veulent pas franchir la ligne rouge j'en
ai jamais douté
sur le sur le sur le fond on peut dire
que cet amendement fait que les choses
soient moins pires que pire mais
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
elle est avérée elle était verrée aussi
au moment de au moment de la retraite
il y a un écart de 28% sur les droits à
la retraite entre les hommes et les
femmes et quand on prend en compte
uniquement les droits directs et pas les
droits dérivés cet écart monte à 41%.
donc il y a une vraie difficulté et j'en
viens à toujours cette ce problème que
notre collègue fièrent à évoqué tout à
l'heure
vous avez dit mais cette réforme c'est
le bon sens parce que on vit plus
longtemps et donc d'une certaine façon
il n'y a pas besoin de sortir de
Polytechnique pour comprendre qu'il faut
faire plus rien n'est plus faux rien
n'est plus faux parce que encore une
fois je vous le répète vous raisonnez
sur des moyennes et en statistique ça
n'a pas de sens la moyenne est une
valeur générale ce qui compte c'est
l'écart à la moyenne et l'écart à la
moyenne il est complètement différent en
fonction du sexe et en fonction de la
catégorie sociale et en fonction du
revenu donc faire comme si la moyenne
concernait tout le monde c'est
complètement faux certains sont
directement touchés et impactés et faire
croire comme le gouvernement que cette
réforme est une réforme de bon sens
c'est justement un non-sens statistique
une erreur politique et une erreur
sociale
merci alors le scrutin public c'est sur
l'amendement avant je ferai sur
l'amendement
bah oui bien sûr
en fait j'ai donné la parole pour les
explications de vote surtout quoi mais
donc voilà il y a pas de souci merci de
votre générosité je voulais dire au
président Retailleau que je vais vous
prendre pendant deux minutes madame la
Présidente moi je suis disponible pour
un débat sur les questions
démographiques sur la question de la
natalité et sur les politiques
familiales mais je pense que d'abord il
faut passer par une analyse sérieuse de
ce qui aujourd'hui nous amène au chiffre
que vous avez donné d'un peu plus 700
000 naissances par an bon
non c'est le même chiffre que ce soit
l'un ou l'autre qu'il est donné c'est
voilà on observe qu'est-ce qui à mon
sens aujourd'hui est la principale cause
des hésitations des jeunes couples à
mettre des enfants au monde premièrement
les inégalités entre les femmes et les
hommes aujourd'hui des jeunes femmes
conçoivent leur vie les jeunes femmes se
posent laissez-moi finir président
laissez-moi finir quand vous demandez à
une jeune femme quelle est la carrière
qu'elle veut faire des femmes très
diplômées elles vous répondent celle qui
me permettra d'avoir une vie compatible
avec ma vie familiale vous posez la
question aux garçons de la même
promotion ils répondent pas ça donc les
jeunes gens projettent leur avenir en
fonction des charges de famille et pour
les jeunes femmes l'âge du premier
enfant qui est de vrai sujet c'est l'âge
de naissance du premier enfant il ne
peut arriver que quand tout est sécurisé
la carrière le logement
le couple tout ça et donc et donc nous
avons la premier sujet deuxième le sujet
qui on peut comprendre que des jeunes
gens entre 25 et 35 ans s'interroge pour
savoir à quoi ressemblera le monde
demain dans lequel vont vivre leurs
enfants on peut pas on peut pas
la meilleure des politiques familiales
c'est aujourd'hui de rassurer les jeunes
sur le fait que nous prendrons toutes
les mesures nécessaires pour garantir à
leurs enfants de l'eau de l'air et un
climat bien sûr que si des conséquette
est une donnée majeure comme l'égalité
professionnelle entre les femmes et les
hommes mais quand vous voulez on fait un
grand débat au Sénat moi je demande que
ça merci madame est présente donc je
vais donner la parole à Monsieur le
rapporteur
très bien merci effectivement et si on
veut donner envie aux jeunes il faut
aussi quelque part que dans notre
discours nous n'ayons pas toujours un
discours misérabilisme ou apocalyptique
quand on parle du travail me semble-t-il
[Applaudissements]
moi je voudrais amener quelques
précisions parce que ce débat était
intéressant mais il y a eu également
quelques imprécisions
pour permettre de les aborder je risque
de déporter quelques mais juste une
minute ou deux je vais être le plus
synthétique possible mais il me semble
que c'est tout à fait important de
rétablir effectivement il y a des
majorations trimestres qui sont perdus
comme on peut dire effacer en tout cas
elle rentre pas en compte ni dans la
durée ni effectivement bien sûr dans le
compte dans le montant de la pension
mais en tout cas dans la durée du fait
de quoi on nous sommes à 20% de
majoration qui soit actuellement perdu
quand on a là où je lâche on sera à 30%.
mais sauf que elles sont on a un taux de
20% parce qu'il y a déjà le commencement
de l'application de la loi Touraine et
vous perdez des majorations à la fois
quand vous n'avez pas vos 43 Triest
c'est sur la longueur et également par
le décalage de l'âge c'est pour ça que
c'est très forme fait que effectivement
il y aura un décalage de majoration et
ça nous a pas échappé c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous avons convenu que une
majoration méritait qu'elle soit pris en
compte et
cette mesure s'adresse
parfois aux hommes mais
principalement majoritairement aux
femmes
[Musique]
les 43 années excusez-moi merci les 43
années faut commencer à 19 ans quand
même donc on touche pas toutes les
femmes voyez il y a beaucoup de femmes
qui sont effectivement avec une durée
déjà plus importante un autre dispositif
vous dites avec la surcote de main il y
a pas la surcotte avoir moins de sous
ben non non parce qu'elles vont
travailler effectivement là le fait born
fait que et ça a été bien compris et
c'est pour ça qu'il y a un certain
nombre de personnes qui sont mécontent
l'effet borne force à travailler plus
longtemps moi je le reconnais bien
volontiers c'est le principe de la
réforme de force mais c'est la
philosophie même de la réforme sauf que
effectivement ils auraient peut-être une
surcote mais comme elle travaille plus
longtemps comme elle travaille plus
longtemps elles auront un salaire qui
fait qui il y aura effectivement une
rémunération plus importante et si c'est
quelqu'un dans la fonction publique
comment calcule la retraite sur les six
derniers mois qu'elle aura son indice
indiscert qui va augmenter donc elle
aura une meilleure retraite donc elle
rattrapera éventuellement la surcote
c'est la raison pour laquelle cette
mesure de 5% est tout à fait
significative dites-le autour de vous si
vous votez cela parce que vous pourrez
dire on a quand même essayé d'améliorer
votre pension même si ça vient nous ne
vous gênez pas pour le dire
un autre point que je voulais simplement
signaler c'est que vous avez largement
dénoncé et injuste titre que le système
était inégalitaire par rapport notamment
au maire de famille mais dans d'autres
dispositifs et on a assisté je ne sais
plus quel
diatrie là-dessus sur les différences de
traitement pour l'usure professionnelle
l'incapacité permanente qui faisait que
etc un certain nombre de dispositifs
inégalitaires et nous l'avons constaté
le principe de cette réforme c'est que
ce soit le moins inégalitaire possible
dans ces dispositifs en conséquence
c'est la raison pour laquelle je vous
invite dans le cas de cette réflexion
à suivre ce qui sera proposé dans
l'amendement de Monsieur Retailleau en
ce qui concerne les régimes spéciaux
parce que nous avons le même
raisonnement faut trouver une durée de
retraite qui soit fonction si elle est
plus longue que les autres de l'usure
professionnelle et il s'agit que tout le
monde soit traité à la même enseigne
c'est pour ça qu'il est permis sans
animosité de faire en sorte que l'on
puisse avoir cette égalité sans attendre
70 ans mais en essayant d'avoir un délai
un petit peu plus contraint voilà la
réflexion qu'à animer la Commission en
tout cas merci de soutenir cet
abonnement c'est tout à fait décisif
merci à Bruno Retailleau de l'avoir
proposé merci alors je vais mettre voir
non j'ai dit
rénal après on passe au vote
je vais être très court mais toujours
pour reprendre un peu notre rapporteur
quelquefois comment dire s'envole un
petit peu en disant si vous le votez
n'oubliez pas de rappeler qu'il vient de
nous
qu'ils viennent de nous je parle à sa
place c'est ce qu'il vient de dire et il
y a juste un petit problème que je
rappelle encore une fois c'est que
toutes les améliorations éventuelles
toutes les petites améliorations qui
peuvent subvenir ne peuvent venir que de
vous puisque il s'agit d'un accord
préalable avec le gouvernement vous
autorisant à déposer l'amendement parce
que si le gouvernement avait dit non
vous étiez article 40 et il y aurait pas
dans l'amélioration donc bien sûr que
nous ne le dirons pas
merci monsieur le Président alors je
mets aux voix donc les sous amendements
donc le premier c'est le 4876 le dernier
sous amendement j'ai dit amendement sous
amendement excusez-moi
sont identiques
défavorable de la commission et du
gouvernement qui est pour
qui est contre
qui s'abstient ne sont pas adoptés je
vais passer au vote donc de l'amendement
2127 de la commission avec un avis
favorable du Gouvernement donc qui se
fait sur la forme du scrutin public il
va être procédé donc au scrutin public
dans les conditions fixées par l'article
56 du règlement le scrutin est ouvert
plus personne ne demande à voter le
scrutin est clos
alors résultat du scrutin nombre de
votants 344 exprimés 280 pour 280 contre
0 le Sénat a adopté
[Applaudissements]
en conséquence tous les amendements de
suppression tombent
et j'ai aussi deux amendements qui
tombent le 4329 de madame la Présidente
assassin
et le 2863 de Madame Lubin
et donc nous avons 11 amendements
faisant l'objet d'une discussion commune
c'est même lui madame Lubin
pour le 2860
c'est bon alors
ah oui c'est un amendement qui vise à
supprimer le décalage à 62 ans de l'âge
de départ anticipé à la retraite pour
les titulaires d'une pension invalidité
les travailleurs déclarés inapte au
travail et les allocataires de la hache
je pense que ça peut être aussi un débat
intéressant je cherche des yeux notre
collègue
spécialisé voilà
nous pensons en effet que s'il vous
plaît
nous pensons en effet que
on pourrait peut-être saisir ce projet
de loi pour corriger ce qui nous semble
être une injustice et je pense qu'un
certain nombre de collègues auront des
choses à dire là-dessus tout comme
l'amendement du rapporteur que nous
venons de discuter maintenant il me
semble que c'est un sujet intéressant et
qui mérite débat
merci l'amendement 4332
la présidente assassin
il est défendu merci
monsieur le Président Laurent
oui donc l'amendement 4332 il s'agit de
supprimer les alinés à 8 et 9
et c'est amendement vise à supprimer la
limitation de deux ans maximum du départ
anticipé pour pénibilité non pas
évidemment que nous soyons opposés un
départ anticipé pour pénibilité mais
tout simplement parce que toutes ces
dispositions ont fait suivent le recul
de l'âge légal accompagne le recul de
l'âge légal à 64 ans et donc en limitant
à deux ans maximum la possibilité de ce
départ elle le recule en vérité de deux
ans donc voilà pourquoi pour exprimer
notre opposition en vérité au recul de
deux ans de cette possibilité nous
proposons cet amendement je vous
remercie merci de 3450 à impensé manger
oui merci Madame ma présidente alors un
rapport
IGAS
IGS de 2016 soulignait les spécificités
des besoins des travailleurs handicapés
en effet le rapport témoigne d'une
fatigabilité accrue d'un absentéisme
plus fréquent et de besoin
d'accompagnement supplémentaires aux
âges dont nous parlons de la retraite le
rapport quinté également une prévalence
accrue des maladies professionnelles
chez les travailleurs handicapés
entraînant une hausse des cotisations
ATMP des charges d'assurance prévoyance
par ailleurs un précédent rapport de la
même institution publié en 2013
indiquait que l'avancée en âge des
personnes handicapées se traduisaient
plus souvent par la survenue de
nouvelles déficiences liées à l'âge
surprévalence et provoque de nouveaux
handicaps comme la surdité la cécité la
réduction de la mobilité la dépression
ainsi que par un possible accroissement
des déficiences antérieures pour ces
différentes raisons la réforme doit
s'adapter aux besoins par particulier
des travailleurs handicapés quelle ne
fait pas car si elle maintient 55 ans
toutes les travailleurs en situation de
handicap ne peuvent pas bénéficier quand
ils n'ont pas les conditions de
l'handicap à 55 ans et donc
effectivement pour ceux qui ne peuvent
pas en bénéficier des dispositifs c'est
une aggravation
puisqu'ils ont deux ans de plus pour ces
nouveaux proposons donc par cet
amendement de garantir aux travailleurs
en situation de handicap qui puisse
bénéficier d'un départ anticipés à la
retraite ou départ progressifs à partir
de 55 ans mais dans des conditions
élargies beaucoup plus élargies comme
que de le faire actuellement par enfin
c'est actuellement par décret nous vous
proposons de l'inscrire dans la loi
c'est notre rôle par ailleurs pour
conclure présenter ces mesures de statu
quo de faible avancée comme de
véritables progrès sociaux est une
hypocrisie alors que l'économie générale
c'est-à-dire la tendance de fond conduit
à une aggravation
y compris pour les personnes invalides
ou en situation de n'a pas été modifié
je vous remercie
le 417 monsieur Ferny
oui merci madame la Présidente Monsieur
le Ministre collègues nous avons souvent
alerté le gouvernement et quand je dis
nous je parle de notre chambre haute sur
les dérives de ce gouvernement dans son
rapport au corps législatif procédure
accélérée devenue la norme non
ratification des ordonnances renvoie
constant au décret sous couvert
d'efficacité toutes ces décisions
éloignent la représentation nationale de
dispositions importantes les retire de
la discussion nous avons bien vu que
dans la construction de ce texte sur
l'avenir des retraites le gouvernement
ne s'était guère embarrassé d'écouter
les syndicats les partis politiques ou
même le Conseil d'État nous empêchant
même de pouvoir nous nous les écouter en
maintenant secrètes la note qui aurait
pu et dû éclairer nos échanges cet
article 8 est représentatif passez-moi
l'expression du bricolage du
gouvernement des annonces de progrès
social mais sans réel mesure de progrès
social notre amendement souhaite donc
rendre concrète les annonces non dites
par le gouvernement le présente article
prévoit plus particulièrement que
rentabilité et l'inaptitude où vous
ouvre droit un départ anticipé à un âge
fixé par décret en plus du bénéfice
d'une retraite au temps plein à cet âge
il est ainsi prévu que cet âge soit
maintenu à 62 ans par décret notre
groupe ne souhaite pas laisser de place
à des renvois en décret les discussions
de ces derniers jours ont montré comment
comme l'absence de décret a pu impacter
le calcul des retraites des enseignants
par exemple il nous paraît donc
nécessaire de fixer dès maintenant cet
âge anticipées de manière aussi fixe que
celui fixé dans l'article 7 de la loi je
vous remercie de votre attention merci
le 28 61 madame Lubin
c'est un amendement qui vise à garantir
que l'âge de départ anticipé à la
retraite pour les allocataires de
l'allocation de cessation anticipées
d'activités les travailleurs ayant pu
une carrière longue les travailleurs
handicapés les travailleurs qui ont une
incapacité permanente à la suite d'un
accident du travail ou une maladie
professionnelle sera toujours de 62 ans
et non prendre cette disposition par
décret comme cela est proposé
actuellement
merci le 4580 monsieur Fanny
alors que le gouvernement limite
fortement le débat Parlement pardon
excusez-moi
Madame le Ministre madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre je m'excuse chers
collègues
alors que le gouvernement limite
fortement le débat parlementaire est
réduit à peu de choses la concertation
avec les organisations syndicales nous
demandons par cette amendement de faire
des négociations avec les partenaires
sociaux organisation syndicales et
patronales représentative au niveau
national et interprofessionnel un point
de passage obligé préalable au décret
merci le 2126 de la commission monsieur
le rapporteur
un moment de coordination
merci avis du gouvernement
annonce est vraiment d'après excusez-moi
manque un peu de sommeil
alors troisièmement identique le 2846
madame Lubin même Poumirol
oui merci madame la Présidente c'est un
moment encore une fois viens marquer
notre
refus de décalage de l'âge de la
retraite de deux ans et donc c'est
amendement du groupe socialiste vise à
ne pas décaler de 2 ans pour les
salariés qui sont affectés par des
risques professionnels puisqu'on sait
que dans leur cas la situation est
encore plus pénible il y a encore plus
grave donc nous demandons à ce qu'il n'y
a pas de recul
qu'est-ce que je dois
pardon
374 non
donnez moi une seconde
3374 madame ponce
oui merci madame la Présidente alors je
voudrais revenir sur le C2P vous nous
dites que c'est les au titre de du C2P
vous maintenez deux ans avant mais les
départs anticipés au titre du C2P vous
êtes bien d'accord désormais ne pourront
intervenir qu'à 62 ans nous proposons
par cet amendement de maintenir la
possibilité d'un départ anticipé à 60
ans pour
pour le C2P pour les
départs anticipés pour pénibilité ces
disposions surviennent alors que le
travail s'intensifie depuis 30 ans je
reviendrai pas sur les chiffres de la
DARES selon les chercheurs Thomas Barney
et Eric Defebvre la retraite présente
des effets bénéfiques pour la santé et
le bien-être de façon générale mais
vraiment plus pour les catégories
populaires largement exposées à
l'accroissement de la pénibilité au
travail selon eux le rôle protecteur de
la prise de retraite reste très
prononcée parmi les personnes dont le
travail a été éprouvant pour les
personnes confrontées à des contraintes
physiques la retraite améliore
principalement la santé générale mais ne
répare pas toujours les corps autant
tandis que pour les personnes ayant subi
des contraintes psychosociales et bien
effectivement ça s'accompagne d'une
diminution
sensible de l'anxiété de la dépression
pour la population masculine la plus
exposée à des contraintes physiques ils
observent que la retraite permet une
diminution des maladies chroniques de 13
%, une baisse de l'anxiété de la
dépression de 8 % et une baisse qui est
importante pour l'espérance de vie sans
un sans incapacité une baisse de 16% de
la limitation d'activité aussi le
meilleur remède à la pénibilité du C2P
c'est donc la retraite arrêtez d'user
les cordes des travailleurs de ce pays
monsieur le ministre et monsieur le
ministre
des manifestants voulant appeler ils ne
veulent plus perdre leur vie à la gagner
si le 433 c'est qu'il défend
madame greaume
merci Madame ma Présidente c'est un
moment vise à ne pas décaler de deux ans
là je n'ai pas anticipé pour les
salariés affectés par des risques
professionnels
merci le 1938 monsieur mouillé
merci Madame présidente comme je
l'évoquais lors d'une dernière
intervention nous avons regardé très
près la situation des travailleurs
handicapés aujourd'hui il y a septembre
de mesure existe pour leur permettre de
partir en de façon anticipée à l'âge de
55 ans car je devrais pas sur le les
risques professionnels sur le le taux de
fatigue aussi des travailleurs
handicapés mais cette situation n'est
permise que par décret et ce que je
propose vers cet amendement c'est que ce
soit mis dans la loi en dur et donc nous
puissions le fixer directement à 55 ans
qui est une véritable avancée et comme
j'ai dit tout à l'heure je suis
également la volonté de simplification
du gouvernement pour la prise à
considération de cette période là voilà
l'objet de mon amendement merci quelle
est la vie de la Commission sur ses am
endements c'est la vie de la Commission
sur ses amendements
prenez votre temps
de
j'étais perturbé par madame la
Présidente simplement ces amendements
effectivement portent quelque chose de
d'important là aussi c'est la prise en
compte d'âge d'agents anticipés
la Commission a gardé toujours je le
répète parce que dans ce que l'on va
vous proposer c'est également important
ce principe que les âges anticipés
voulaient dire retraites plus longue
donc si c'est une retraite qui est plus
longue par rapport à la prise en compte
de l'usure ça veut dire qu'il y a eu des
facteurs d'usure ou des facteurs de vie
très particuliers on pense notamment à
l'invalidité la maladie qui font en
sorte que il est tout à fait légitime
que la société consacre un effort
supplémentaire tant sur le plan des des
mesures que sur le plan financier à ces
personnes qui ont un parcours un peu
compliqué du fait de certains facteurs
c'est la raison pour laquelle il y a un
certain nombre d'âge dé par rapport à
cette âge légal proposé à 64 ans mais
comme vous voyez ça fait beaucoup d'âge
on arrive à 55 ans et c'est d'ailleurs
l'âge actuel pour les personnes en
situation de handicap qui ont une durée
d'exposition dont on reparlera
éventuellement tout à l'heure dans ce
handicap par rapport maintenant un
critère nouveau qui sont les critères de
trimestre cotisés ou réputés cotisés
mais pas l'ensemble des trimestres
validés ce qui est un dispositif
d'ouverture par rapport à cet âge et
effectivement on peut comprendre que
certains amendements veuillent inscrire
cet âge de 55 ans moyennant des critères
qui sont définis et fixent dans la loi
il y a l'âge également par exemple de 60
ans en ce qui concerne ou 62 ans on va
parler de ces deux P ou actuellement le
C2P c'est vous pouvez bénéficier de deux
ans avec le nombre de points qui vous a
donné des trimestres qui vous permettent
de partir de façon anticipée trop de
personnes prennent ce dispositif par
rapport à d'autres dispositifs et en
conséquence nous avons pensé il était
plus judicieux non pas de les laisser à
62 à 60 ans comme aujourd'hui puisque
deux ans moins l'âge légal ce qui les
laisserait dans le dispositif
d'exposition à certains risques mais
plutôt d'essayer de favoriser le temps
partiel rémunéré de façon complète en
déplafonnant les points vous le verrez
en vous le présentera le moment venu en
développe plafonnant les points
consacrés à ce temps partiel pour qu'on
les réserve pour la fin de carrière ce
serait un peu plus ça nous paraît
maintenant c'est discutable bien entendu
si vous vers la discussion ça nous
paraît judicieux de faire une transition
comme ça à travers le C2P en fin de
carrière pour finir de façon progressive
il y a également l'âge de 60 ans en ce
qui concerne l'invalidité l'inaptitude
c'est le droit actuel le gouvernement
propose de le mettre en agent anticipé
par rapport à 64 ceux qui veut dire que
on reste dans le droit actuel et dessus
à nous apparu effectivement par rapport
à ceux qui ont des invalidités des in
études au travail pour aider raison
médicales mais pas pour des raisons
professionnelles de le laisser à 62 ans
ceux qui par contre et c'est là qu'on a
une différence avec le gouvernement qui
sont dans l'incapacité permanente à au
moins 20% ou bien pour ceux qui sont
entre 10 et 20% selon un nombre
d'expositions 17 années d'exposer à
certains risques nous avons une
divergence avec Monsieur le Ministre
parce que nous pensons qu'il ne faut pas
décaler pour eux ce passage de 60 à 62
ans et nous souhaitons que maintenir à
60 ans cette âge pour retraite anticipée
pour invalidité compte tenu des critères
exposés et puis il y aura on le verra
tout à l'heure mais ça fera partie de
notre lourd encore quatre h de bornes
proposées ou trois ou quatre mais on
verra le moment venu pour les carrières
longues et puis il y a toutes les bornes
qu'il y a concernant les actifs les
sédentaires c'est pour ça qu'on essaye
de faire en sorte que ces personnes là
puissent avoir un relativement
équivalent d'un métier à l'autre ou d'un
statut à l'autre qui sont les bornes qui
passent à 59 ans notamment pour les
actifs et 54 ans pour les super actifs
voilà un peu donc notre raisonnement a
été toujours le même et c'est la raison
pour laquelle je donne un avis
défavorable par rapport aux propositions
qui sont faites puisqu'elles vont à
l'encontre de ce que vous propose votre
commission des affaires sociales merci
en ce qui concerne j'ai dû oublier un
amendement ou de d'explication
ça c'est vu qu'est-ce que c'est que ça
c'est vu je l'ai expliqué donc c'est le
maintien pour les amendements de 1846 à
433 le maintien du C2P donc comme je
voulais exposé et puis il y a une petite
différence où j'anticipe par rapport à
la réaction de madame ponsémont je sais
ce qui est concerne
l'inscription à 55 ans on choisira
l'amendement de Philippe mouillé
je l'attendais je l'attendais non pas
par gentillesse ou pas mais c'est parce
que il faudrait rectifier le vôtre par
rapport à ce qu'elle s'est proposé c'est
pour ça que nous préférons l'amendement
1938 qui a inscrit bien le dispositif
parce qu'actuellement c'est un décret
donc on inscrit bien par contre il y a
effectivement une petite erreur et ce
qui fait que j'ai donné un avis
défavorable mais c'est le même esprit et
puis également en ce qui concerne le 417
pour Monsieur benaro J'ai un petit
commentaire particulier parce que je
pense que l'auteur de cet amendement n'a
pas bien considéré ce qu'il proposait et
je ne peux pas croire qu'il s'agisse de
son intention parce qu'effectivement
entre l'objet et la volonté il y a une
large différence donc avis défavorable
merci
monsieur le ministre
merci madame la Présidente peut-être un
avis en trois points sur le fond mais
sur le rapporteur a dit l'essentiel des
arguments que le Gouvernement partage
simplement préciser que le gouvernement
donne un avis de sagesse à la demande
21-26 de monsieur le rapporteur un avis
défavorable ou une demande de retrait
sur tous les autres amendements puisque
la plupart d'entre eux comme la
dimension le rapporteur sont en réalité
satisfaits puisque beaucoup des
situations évoquées sont des situations
qui n'évoluent pas avec le texte que
nous vous présentons je n'ai qu'une
différence d'appréciation avec monsieur
le rapporteur qui concerne l'amendement
1938 pardon je les ai mal de Monsieur
mouillé
l'idée là et nous la partageons puisque
nous souhaitons que le départ des
personnes en situation de handicap soit
fixées reste fixés à 55 ans l'article
351-3 que vous mentionnez dans votre
amendement précise que cet âge de départ
anticipé est fixé par des craies et
précise que
cette et il est actuellement fixé donc à
55 ans le gouvernement n'envisage
absolument pas de modifier le décret
puisque nous voulons laisser 55 ans ce
que nous ce que je crains ce que nous
craignons c'est que la rédaction que
vous proposez disons au maximum 9 ans
empêche finalement qui que ce soit
d'aller plus loin par décret ça peut
être un choix mais en l'état de la
rédaction du décret et la possibilité
ultérieure de la bouger nous
considérions c'était satisfait c'est la
raison pour laquelle c'était plutôt une
demande de retrait qu'un avis qu'un avis
favorable
merci sur ces amendements et des
explications de vote
madame Lubin
j'entends j'entends bien que le
gouvernement considère qu'il a fait un
effort puisque il ne bouge pas pour
certaines catégories donc
de personnes handicapées ou en
invalidité il ne bouge pas à 64 ans
je pense qu'il y a une inégalité pour
ces personnes là et qu'elle devrait être
tout à 60 ans
je pense que c'est quelque chose que
nous aurions dû veiller à faire les uns
et les autres voilà et donc je me dis
que ce projet de loi aurait peut-être pu
donner l'occasion de rectifier cette
inégalité j'imagine qu'elle a un coup
bien évidemment mais bon quel que soit
la qualification que l'on soit en H que
l'on soit en invalidité en incapacité je
ne suis pas spécialiste du dossier donc
je fais attention à ce que je dis
la réalité c'est que on est en fin de
carrière et qu'on ne peut plus
travailler et donc dans ces cas-là
pourquoi ne fixe-t-on pas 60 ans pour
toutes ces personnes qui relèvent de ces
catégories là il me semble où ça serait
une véritable mesure de justice
c'est Monsieur brouiller
merci madame la Présidente j'ai commencé
à propos de l'amendement de Monsieur
mouillé moi j'ai compris qu'il
suggérait de ne pas changer par décret
pour préserver cet âge de 55 ans et
c'est d'ailleurs la raison pour laquelle
je le vaut très ma deuxième remarque
c'est que le rapporteur a évoqué qui
avait beaucoup de d'âge de bornes et
beaucoup de mesures de bornes et je
voulais juste dire j'étais assez
d'accord à m'opposer aux mesures de
bornes notamment à cette loi
monsieur gay
oui merci Madame la présente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues dans la
même veine que ma collègue lui-même
conçoit en invalidité en incapacité en
situation de handicap entre 55 et 60 ans
peu importe vous ne retrouverez pas du
travail
et vous ne repartirez pas au travail
parce que la vie a fait que vous avez
contracté une maladie professionnelle
vous avez eu un accident de la vie et
donc quoi qu'il arrive
vous ne repartirez pas au travail et
même dans la start-up nation où on peut
se recycler à l'infini vous n'y
arriverez pas
et donc on a un choix de société à faire
il y a une question d'égalité mais aussi
un choix de société soit nous continuons
à les insécuriser à les laisser dans une
très grande précarité avec une
allocation ou avec le RSA jusqu'à l'âge
de 64 voire 65 voire plus il faut une
placard ici non pas eu une carrière
complète ou alors nous nous disons qu'à
un moment donné ça suffit à 60 ans c'est
la limite d'âge que l'on donne on les
passe à la retraite
et nous pensons que c'est le moment
parce que de toute façon quoi qu'il
arrive vous allez avoir un sens de
précarité vous voulez faire y compris
une question financière mais ça pèse sur
les comptes sociaux et donc nous pensons
qu'il vaut mieux qu'il soit plus
sécurisé dans l'âge de la retraite c'est
ça la question qui nous est posée alors
après on peut avoir tout un débat sur
est-ce que c'est l'incapacité le
vieillissement le handicap à quelle
hauteur mais on devrait au minimum sur
cet article sur la pénibilité au minimum
entre nous se mettent d'accord sur ça et
je ne comprends pas pourquoi Nîmes sur
le rapporteur ni monsieur le ministre
font un geste en ce sens voilà je vous
remercie madame la Présidente merci s'il
n'y a plus d'explication de vote je vais
soumettre on voit ses amendements le 28
60 qui a reçu un double avis défavorable
qui est pour
qui est contre qui s'abstient il n'est
pas adopté 43 32 double avis défavorable
qui est pour qui contre qui s'abstient
il n'est pas adopté le 34-50 double avis
défavorable qui est pour qui contre qui
s'abstient il n'est pas adopté
le 417
pareil toujours debbaye défavorable qui
pour
qui est contre qui s'abstient il n'est
pas adopté le 28 31 même vote
le 45 81 même vote
qui est pour
qui contre qui s'abstient il n'est pas
adopté le 21-26 maintenant de la
commission qui a reçu un avis de sagesse
du gouvernement qui est pour
qui est contre qui s'abstient il est
adopté le 28 46 au 33 74 43 33 qui ont
reçu un double avis défavorable qui est
pour
qui contre qui s'abstient et ne sont pas
adoptés et enfin le 19 38 qui a reçu un
avis favorable de la commission une
demande de retrait du gouvernement qui
est pour
qui est contre qui s'abstient il est
adopté
je sais pas si c'est 18 amendements
maintenant en discussion commune
commençons avec le 43 34 kit défend
madame Cohen
merci madame la Présidente le
Gouvernement présente la création d'un
dispositif carrière super longue et le
statu quo concernant le dispositif
carrière longue existant comme des
mesures de justice sociale or les
dispositifs carrière longue ne seront
pas renforcés en réalité l'âge de départ
pour les bénéficiaires de carrière
longue qui ont commencé à travailler à
18 ou 19 ans sera allongée de deux ans
soit un départ à 62 ans en 2030 et ce
ayant commencé avant 18 ans pourront
toujours partir à 60 ans mais il
connaîtront un durcissement de leur
situation puisqu'ils devront s'acquitter
de la durée de cotisation majorée d'un
an c'est un véritable en fait coup de
communication le gouvernement maintient
58 ans l'âge de départ pour celles et
ceux ayant commencé à travailler avant
16 ans soit moins mes chers collègues de
1% des générations qui sont touchées par
la réforme en effet pour la génération
1973 le dis motif de carrière super
longue ne concerne
pas plus que 300 personnes par an
environ et là j'ai moyen d'accès un
premier emploi stable et passer de 20
ans en 2060 en
1975 pardon à 27 ans aujourd'hui du coup
notre amendement vise à supprimer les
trois bornes d'âge de départ anticipé
pour les pour les carrières longues et
très longues merci Madame ponce pour le
36 68
merci madame la Présidente alors
vous renvoyez un décret la définition
des âges anticipés des départs anticipés
pour carrière longue et des conditions
de durée requises dans le texte proposé
la seule référence au dispositif
envisagé et dans le fait de remplacer je
cite les assurés qui ont commencé leur
activité avant un âge etc etc
par les assurés qui ont commencé leur
activité avant un des trois âges
sous-entendus 16 18 et 20 cette
modification n'apporte rien à l'état du
droit puisqu'ils avec la rédaction
actuelle il existe déjà quatre pages 16
17 18 et 20 ans pire la modification
envisagée vient figer elle vient figer
les possibilités du pouvoir
réglementaire en matière d'âge alors
qu'il s'agit au contraire d'un paramètre
sur lequel il faut trouver le plus de
souplesse possible au profit ici de la
durée d'assurance requise actuellement
le décret dispose que les assurés ayant
commencé à travailler avant 20 ans
doivent justifier d'une durée de
cotisation équivalente à celle requise
pour le taux plein les assurés ayant
commencé à travailler avant 16 ans
doivent justifier de cette durée mais
majorée de 8 trimestres le gouvernement
dans son dossier de presse prévoit
d'abaisser cette condition à quatre
trimestres
avant 16 ans de majorer cette durée de 4
trimestres pour ceux ayant commencé
avant 18 ans et ne prévoit pas de la
majorée comme c'est le cas aujourd'hui
pour les assurer ils ont commencé avant
20 ans c'est très compliqué hein nous
vous proposons donc de modifier les
dispositions envisagées c'est la
conséquence et de supprimer à chaque
fois la référence aux trois âges vous
voyez la complexité qu'on en parle et de
les remplacer par une disposition claire
précisant les conditions de durée
requises en précisant que la durée de
cotisation requise pour l'anticipation
au titre de la carrière longue est égal
à la durée d'assurance requise pour le
taux plein c'est bien plus simple vous
en conviendrez merci Madame madame Lubin
pour le 26 35
merci madame la Présidente je vais pas
relire le motif parce que l'objet parce
que c'est exactement le même que celui
de ma collègue Raymond de pensée mange
donc je vais poser le problème
[Musique]
ce projet de loi amène à avoir des âges
extrêmement différents en matière de fin
des durées différentes en matière de
carrière longue alors il y aura il y a
une dispositif pour ceux qui auront
commencé à travailler avant 16 ans
certes c'est bien il existait déjà un
certain nombre de choses bon ça
concernera très peu de gens au final
mais ça aura le mérite d'exister
aujourd'hui les gens qui ont commencé
qui ont cotisé 5 trimestres avant 20 ans
et qui ont le nombre de trimestres
requis à l'âge requis peuvent prétendre
à une carrière longue des 60 ans bon
cela qui vont constituer et qui
constitue déjà et qui constitueront
encore plus dans les 10 années qui
viennent le gros de la cohorte des
carrières longues cela vont devoir
continuer à travailler jusqu'à 62 ans
alors certes c'est un peu le débat qu'on
avait tout à l'heure pour eux 62 ans ça
sera mieux que 64 mais c'est pire que 60
on est bien d'accord et pour la plupart
ce sont des gens
qui travaillent déjà on l'a dit depuis
longtemps puis ce sont ceux-là que l'on
retrouve dans tous les métiers dont on
n'arrête pas de parler voilà donc moi
j'amène tout le monde à réfléchir quand
même pour un certain nombre de ces
personnes là
deux ans de plus lorsque la loi sera
totalement vigueur ou quelques mois à
partir de maintenant ça n'est pas rien
donc effectivement nous ce que nous
préconisons c'est 43 ans de cotisations
et on s'en va
merci nous allons maintenant trois
amendements identiques le 45 monsieur
Cabanel merci madame la Présidente le
dispositif de retraite anticipée pour
carrière longue a été mis en place en
2023 pardon dans un esprit de justice
sociale pour accompagner les réformes
d'un logement de la durée d'assurance
requise les assurés qui ont commencé à
travailler particulièrement tôt et qui
remplissent certaines conditions de
durée d'assurance peuvent ainsi
bénéficier d'un départ en retraite
anticipé pour carrière longue afin
d'amortir l'impact du relèvement de
l'âge légal sur les assurés qui ont
travaillé le plus tôt l'article 8
modifie les conditions applicables aux
carrières longues l'âge de départ à la
retraite pour longue carrière serait
ainsi anticipée selon trois bornes d'âge
c'est amendement propose de créer une
quatrième borne d'âge de début
d'activité permettant un départ anticipé
pour les assurer ayant travaillé avant
21 ans cette nouvelle borne d'âge
permettra aux assurer et en réuni quatre
cinq trimestre avant 21 ans et
justifiant de leur durée d'assurance
requise cotisée de partir à l'âge de 63
ans les âges de début d'activité et
l'âge de départ possible sont définies
par décret un décret précisera par
ailleurs que pour l'ensemble des niveaux
de dispositif carrière longue la
condition de durée cotisée sera fixée
conformément à la durée d'assurance
requise pour le droit commun ainsi
assurer pourra partir à la retraite à
taux plein si la cotisée au moins cette
durée dès lors qu'il aura atteint l'âge
anticipé de départ au titre des
carrières longues
c'est à vous merci Présidente c'est
amendement présenté par mon collègue
Xavier yakovelli et notre groupe est
exactement le même que celui qui a été
excellenté par notre collègue Cabanel
donc je n'en dirai pas plus très bien
nous avons maintenant le 3407
identique madame ponce
oui il est identique mais je tiens à
ressouler effectivement et ça va être
souvent le cas que nous cet amendement
les sénateurs du groupe écologiste
solidarité territoire souhaite atténuer
la brutalité de la réforme portée par le
gouvernement effectivement l'article 8
précise que l'âge de départ à la
retraite pour longue carrière peut être
anticipé selon trois bornes d'âge vous
avez vu quand même qu'on proposait
d'autres formulations donc je continue
l'amendement précédent ne sera pas
retenu qui sont définies par décret
l'accès au dispositif est en effet
conditionné un début d'activité 16 18 20
ans le président amendement a pour objet
malheureusement vu cette complexité de
créer une possibilité de départ anticipé
pour les assurer ayant travaillé avant
21 ans en créant une quatrième borne
d'âge de début d'activité
c'est conformément aux annonces de la
première ministre du 5 février 2023
conformément à cet engagement à décret
précisera également que pour l'ensemble
des niveaux de dispositifs carrière
longue et c'est ça qui est important la
condition de durée cotiser sera fixée
conformément à la durée d'assurance
requise pour le droit commun aujourd'hui
quoi qu'on en pense c'est 43 à nuités au
terme de l'accélération du calendrier
Touraine dès lors qu'il atteint la
anticipé de départ routine des carrières
longues l'assuré devra pouvoir partir à
la retraite à taux plein Steve a cotiser
au moins cette durée requise merci merci
pour le suivant le 208 monsieur mandoli
il est défendu le 43 36
qui le défend
ces messieurs ça veulent de
ça va être monsieur ça veut dire
merci
pour accéder à la retraite anticipée
pour handicap à 55 ans il faut remplir
deux conditions cumulatives à la fois
validé une certaine durée d'assurance
trimestre cotisée puis trimestre
assimilé dont un certain nombre de
trimestres cotisés et là la réforme
propose de ne plus retenir que la
cotisante la condition de curées cotisée
cela réduit certes la durée totale
d'assurance pour bénéficier du
dispositif mais à nos yeux cela n'aurait
en rien la programmatique la durée de
cotisation reste beaucoup trop longue
pire cela
risque de rendre encore plus compliqué
l'accès aux dispositif car les
trimestres assimilés mais non cotisés
notamment au titre du chômage d'un arrêt
de maladie d'un stage etc ne sont plus
plis en compte d'ailleurs ce retour en
arrière en totalement en contradiction
avec l'article qui prévoit de mieux
prendre en compte les périodes de stage
de formation professionnelle donc on
peut être favorable à la réduction de la
durée d'assurance totale exigée mais il
est inacceptable de supprimer la prise
en compte des trimestres validés il faut
maintenir donc cette possibilité de
prendre en compte les trimestres valides
assimilés et élargir les périodes
reconnues comme tel que ce soit les
pertes de chômage d'arrêt maladie
accident du travail période de stage de
formation professionnelle perte
d'apprentissage période de service
civique etc il faut également réduire la
durée exigée de cotisations situation
d'handicap d'au moins 20 trimestres car
une personne en situation de handicap
ayant passé plus de 5 années au chômage
ou en maladie ne pourra pas prétendre à
une retraite anticipée en remplissant
les autres conditions si vous dire que
cet amendement n'est pas le moment
seulement de notre groupe c'est nous
l'avons déposé avec l'esprit de ce que
nous a demandé de mettre ici en débat
qui a été réalisé par le collectif
handicap qui correspond et qui rassemble
52 organisations plan national sur cet
enjeu de la question du handicap donc il
faudrait faire bénéficier les personnes
dont le handicap survient à compter de
40 ans et qui ont un taux d'incapacité
supérieur à 50%. merci monsieur le
ministre le 46 51
l'article 8 prévoit la prise en compte
des trimestres à kiotiques de
l'assurance vieillesse par en foyer et
de l'assurance vieillesse des aidants
pour calculer le bénéfice de la retraite
anticipée pour carrière longue par
dérogation en principe qui fait que
celles les trimestres cotisés par
l'assuré sont prises en compte dans la
rédaction retenue à l'Assemblée
nationale seuls les trimestres prises en
compte
seul trimestre en compte pardon sont
ceux au cours desquelles les intérêts
ont été affiliés au régime général or
les périodes de cours desquelles les
assurés étant aidons étaient aidons et
aux parents ont failli peuvent être fait
au titre de la CNRACL ou au titre de la
cpcmr et donc nous proposons d'élargir
aux autres régimes la prise en compte
des trimestres d'assurance vieillesse
par employés et d'assurance vieillesse
des aidants pour la prise en compte des
trimestres dans le calcul de
l'éligibilité au départ anticipé pour
carrière longue
[Musique]
de la commission merci c'est une la
correction d'une erreur
pensez 80
validé cinq trimestres avant la fin de
ses 18 ans sera à terme conduit à
liquider un an plus tard quand l'absence
de réforme
soit un report c'est de cela dont vous
féliciter nettement inférieur à la
hausse de deux ans de l'âge d'ouverture
des droits seulement d'un an un an de
plus seulement pour les personnes qui
travaillent depuis leur 18 ans quelle
chance qu'elle progrès qu'elle geste
social conséquent et exceptionnelle
l'autre geste exceptionnel c'est de
permettre la validation de 4 à 5
trimestres avant 16 ans mais selon
l'adresse seul 04% des cotisants de la
génération né en 62 valide un premier
trimestre avant l'âge de 16 ans et cette
proportion sera de 0,1 soit 4 fois moins
dans les générations suivantes l'âge de
la première validation de trimestre se
situe autour de 21 ans pour la
génération 62 et autour de 22 ans pour
la génération 78 c'est à dire que pour
la Vasse majorité des futurs retraités
votre mesure servira guerre et ils vont
subir par contre ça ça c'est sûr la
brutalité de l'entièreté de cette
réforme c'est à dire deux ans de plus
voilà la réalité
merci le 21 29 c'est encore un
amendement rédactionnel
de la commission c'est encore voilà je
le passe je le passe le 43 41
qui est-ce que
est-ce qu'il est défendu le 43-41 de
Madame assassy et ses collègues comment
on va dire
il est défendu merci le 21 30 c'est
encore un amendement rédactionnel de la
commission le 31 03 de qui d'identique
au suivant monsieur Cabanel merci madame
la Présidente
les conditions de départ pour les
carrières longues ainsi à assurer qui
remplit les conditions de début
d'activité et qui atteignent l'âge de
départ anticipé auquel il a droit pourra
bénéficier d'une retraite à toplin si ça
durée de cotisation effective atteint la
durée d'assurance requise pour le droit
commun
si qui défend
[Musique]
qui défend l'identique 37 26
allez-y madame il est défendu merci
le 30 99 madame Lubin
en fait c'est une
c'est une manière d'insister un peu sur
le sujet
bien évidemment je sois consciente et
nous soyons conscients que la mesure
budgétaire pourra être importante nous
considérons que finalement pour tous ces
toutes ces personnes qui arrivent qui
auront 43 amités à nuité avant d'avoir
atteint leur 64 ans c'est à dire à 63 à
63 ou à 62 sans être pour autant
carrière longue c'est un peu compliqué
mais ce sont des ce sont des exemples
qui existeront qui ne seront pas qui ne
seront pas comment dire anodin nous
considérons qu'il faut leur donner la
retraite des 43 années de cotisations
merci le 33 92
pendu
et il est identique au 3408 de Madame
ponce mais madame pensément je vais le
défendre vous allez voir
oui tout à fait alors je répéterai pas
ce qui a déjà été dit par contre par
contre le gouvernement assure qu'un
salarié en carrière longue ne pourra pas
travailler au-delà de 43 à nuités encore
faudrait-il que cela soit garanti dans
son dispositif de super carrière longue
le gouvernement présentant son projet de
loi il est un peu plus d'un mois avait
oublié effectivement ceux qui commencent
à travailler à 18 ans puisqu'il est
contraignait à cotiser 44 ans je crois
que c'était aussi le cas pour les
saisons Elisabeth borne c'était en
précepte Elisabeth madame la Première
ministre c'était empressé de corriger le
tir devant cette injustice par trop
flagrante en annonçant que ceux-ci
serait corrigé sous la probation de
nombreux groupes à l'Assemblée et
notamment des LR il faut le souligner
pour corriger le tir le gouvernement
avait donc déposé un amendement à
l'article 8 qui n'a pas été discuté mais
n'a pas été discuté il aurait pu être
toutefois il me semble intégré dans le
texte du Sénat donc voilà devant ce flou
on laisse on laisse très certain
travailleur aux carrière longue
travailler 44 ans je ne pense pas et je
ne verrai pas le groupe LR et le
gouvernement voté contre un amendement
qui va dans le sens qui a été déposé par
lui et demandé par certains membres du
groupe républicains l'Assemblée
nationale je ne doute pas que vous
voterez ces amendements merci je vais
solliciter la vie du rapporteur
maintenant
merci effectivement là on aborde un
sujet bien particulier les carrières
longues alors
va falloir être attentif parce qu'il
faut s'accrocher quand même au
dispositif le dispositif me semble-t-il
dans sa philosophie au départ en temps
initialement c'était sa cible sa cible
c'est véritablement de prendre en compte
ceux qu'on peut ceux qui ont travaillé
très tôt qui ont eu des carrières
derrière difficiles non formés on pense
notamment aux métiers d'artisanat etc et
voilà ceux qui méritent effectivement
contenu d'un métier pénible avec une
usure professionnelle il faut pas les
faire travailler trop longtemps donc il
mérite une retraite plus longue que les
autres toujours dans le cadre général et
pas particulier on pense que ils auront
une espérance de vie moins importante et
là on se rejoint ayant une espérance de
vie moins importante il est tout à fait
légitime que la société répondent en
proposant de partir avant à la retraite
pour qu'il Béné aussi à peu près c'est
purement théorique à peu près de même
temps de retraite que quelqu'un qui a eu
une carrière plus facile alors pour
faire cela prendre en compte
il est un dispositif
la loi numéro
[Musique]
l351-1 qui dit que l'ensemble de ces
dispositifs les bornes d'achetes et la
durée sont prises par décret voilà
Quentin pris par décret donc si vous
voulez après on peut parler de 43 ans
d'annuité on peut parler de deux trois
quatre bornes de Tin je le dis la loi je
vais y arriver mille excuses dit bien
que c'est un âge fixé par décret et une
durée fixée par décret et quand vous
ramenez ça dans ces dispositifs vous
mettez des bornes et des durées et bien
effectivement effectivement il y a des
conséquences qui sont pas forcément la
même et vous ne pouvez pas dans le
dispositif actuel dire il y aura durée
pour tel pour ces personnes là parce que
selon l'âge selon les mois de naissance
vous avez une répercussion différente et
vous rentrez où vous rentrez pas dans le
dispositif et que les 43 ans puisque
c'est de ça qu'il s'agit aujourd'hui
c'est une durée de cotisation plancher
ce n'est pas une durée de cotisation
plafond les 64 ans âge légal c'est un
âge minimal de départ en retraite ce
n'est pas un plafond c'est la même
gymnastique d'esprit qu'il faut faire
pour comprendre le dispositif mais ce
serait tôt simple ni l'excuse là aussi
c'est pour ça que je suis vous l'avez
compris avec une position qui est pas
toujours en accord avec celle de
Monsieur le Ministre mais il partage les
principes de mes propositions je prends
5 minutes pour les exposer
oui mais c'est parce que c'est un
travail déjà de longue haleine là-dessus
de très longues haleine je me permets de
les exposer mais vous me ferez moi j'ai
pas réussi j'ai pas réussi à faire une
contre proposition c'est la raison pour
laquelle j'ai donné une commission à
donner un avis de sagesse j'ai pas
réussi à faire une contrepoolique
simplement vous prenez pour ces
carrières longues dans la loi c'est
marqué que ces quatre à cinq trimestres
avant votre année anniversaire la fin de
l'année celui qui a trois trimestres il
est pas dans le dispositif c'est la
borne suivante et 4 à Saint trimestre à
la fin c'est pas facile à expliquer
parce que pour les autres dispositifs
communs vous partez quand vous avez
telle durée quel que soit votre date de
naissance vous avez 43 ans de cotisation
et bien vous partez à la retraite c'est
pas avoir 4 à 5 trimestre avant le début
et puis ensuite
ce serait trop simple il y a le
dispositif de la durée quand vous
calculez la durée de ces dispositifs
car entre trois ans
qui sont affectés à une borne durée de
cotisation plus de c'est la réforme
naturelle sur la bosse de la borne de
ces ans c'est durée de cotisation plus
deux 43 + 2
= 45 ans quand vous appliquez cette
durée de cotisation et que vous comptez
les trimestres ce ne sont pas les mêmes
trimestres comptés que pour le régime
général d'un côté on se rend compte que
les trimestres cotisés c'est-à-dire
qu'il y avait véritablement les gens qui
ont travaillé concotisé ou réputés
cotisés parce qu'il y a une petite marge
de solidarité de l'autre côté on a un
système très solidaire qui permet de
prendre en compte certes les années
cotisées mais également quand vous avez
été malade des indemnités journalières
le chômage des réputés cositisées et des
assimilés et des majorations notamment
on en a parlé tout à l'heure qui fait
que dans les 43 ans il y a pas forcément
43 ans de travail il y a aussi 43 ans
qui sont compensés au titre de la
solidarité c'est un régime très
solidaire cette solidarité dans le
régime général ne s'applique pas au
régime des carrières longues ce qui fait
que quand on décline le dispositif vous
avez quelqu'un qui part à 20 ans puisque
c'est une nouvelle bonne vingt ans
voyez-vous quand il a ces quatre cent
trimestre avant la fin d'anniversaire de
sa 20e année quand il est dans un
dispositif où il a fait une grande école
par exemple
rémunérer et bien rentre dans le
dispositif et il va partir à 63 ans
c'est la proposition parce qu'il a
Polytechnique par exemple l'école des
impôts deuxième exemple donc il va
rentrer et le bien portant qu'à une part
guerrière sûrement difficile parce que
c'est sûrement difficile
partira 63 ans celui qui est dans les
mêmes conditions mais qui fait une autre
école qui est pas ou qui est rémuné ou
qui part dans sa carrière il est dans
les mêmes dispositions 4 à 5 ans avant
il arrive lui il a été malade il a
continué à travailler il a eu un entrain
de d'indemnité journalière il a repris
le boulot il a eu un amitié journalière
et ben celui-là comment compte pas les
trimestres de la même façon et ben il
part à 64 ans donc voyez-vous pour
partir avec un départ anticipé il faut
être bien portant avec un métier pas
trop difficile pour partir dans les
autres conditions celui qui a un métier
usant et qui peut être malade et ben il
bénéficie pas du dispositif il est clair
il est illisible parce que effectivement
c'est 4 à 5 ans etc et on peut toujours
mettre des bornes on peut toujours
mettre des amendements sur les durées de
cotisation le dispositif est-elle que
les dispositions se prennent par décret
donc moi j'ai tendance à donner
effectivement et la commission aussi un
avis de sagesse par rapport à cela parce
que vous avez la possibilité
effectivement de trouver le système le
moins inégaléatoire possible et quand on
dit 43 ans comme c'était proposé à
mettre sur chacune des bornes on peut
toujours le voter moi j'ai aucun
inconvénient là-dessus sauf que vous
dites pas la vérité aux gens parce que
selon l'âge selon le mois où vous êtes
né dans l'année et bien il y a des gens
qui feront de toute façon
systématiquement 44 ans et vous n'y
pouvez rien c'est les mathématiques qui
s'imposent voilà pourquoi ce système
illisible inégalitaire j'aurais souhaité
monsieur le ministre vous proposer
quelque chose de plus juste qui
n'entendent pas les finances non plus
parce qu'il faut faire attention que
chaque disposition quand vous dites à
passer facile on va faire que 43 ans
sauf que derrière il y a une addition à
payer et je préfère je préfère quand
même puisque nous avons une réforme
budgétaire où il faut combler des
déficitifs et non pas les creuser je
préfère qu'on consacre plutôt à des
mesures de solidarité les maires de
famille plutôt qu'à ses bornes d'âge
relativement inégalitaire il n'empêche
que certaines dispositions ont été
prises certaines proposition avancée par
madame la Première ministre donc il
incompte bien entendu au gouvernement de
les confirmer mais en attendant je pense
que on peut voter certaines dispositions
par forcément d'autres voilà où je
voulais en venir en sachant que j'avais
encore donc un avis toujours de sagesse
mais vous l'avez compris et je pense que
je donnerai plutôt un avis défavorable
donc sur la durée d'âge parce que
pardon oui la durée d'âge est 43 ans
systématiquement je pense qu'il faut pas
aller dans cette voie là parce qu'on ne
dit pas la vérité aux Français mais
c'est le ministre qui dira comment il
veut faire derrière bien entendu par
contre en ce qui concerne les bornes
d'âge bon qu'il y ait trois ou carbone
on voit bien qu'on peut les régler on
n'est pas obligé de mettre 16 18 20 21
parce que je pense qu'il aurait été plus
simple de mettre de 17 19 21 peu importe
je n'ai pas trouvé la solution vous
l'avez pas trouvé vous m'avez dit mais
sachons nous retrouver peut-être
là-dessus pour dire la vérité et
répondre au problème des personnes ne
ratons pas la cible la cible c'est ce
qu'on commençait tôt et que une carrière
pénible ne ratons pas la cible et puis
j'ai aussi à donner un avis favorable
bien sûr à l'amendement de Monsieur le
Ministre parce que il a l'argile la
solidarité à travers les trimestres en
compte par les avpf ou l'AVA et c'est
une mesure qu'on attendait parce qu'il
faut quand même un peu plus de
solidarité dans ce dispositif carrière
longue et j'ai également à vous dire que
l'amendement de la commission
2128 donc celui que je vous ai proposé
a été corrigé pour le rang compatible
avec les amendements 45 1918 et 3407
c'est bien cela merci pardonnez-moi
d'avoir été trop long mais il va falloir
il fallait un peu expliquer cela
monsieur le rapporteur si j'ai bien
suivi et sans être excessivement
formaliste c'est un avis de sagesse sur
le les trois identiques 45 19 18 et 34
07 et favorable du Gouvernement et
défavorable sur tous les autres merci
monsieur le ministre c'est à vous
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur
rapporteur a été très clair sur le
dispositif carrière longue qui est
extrêmement complexe tout le monde tout
le monde a pu le voir je voudrais
simplement commencer par une deux
précisions de méthode à l'attention de
madame pensemonge vous avez dit madame
la sénatrice que le gouvernement avait
déposé deux amendements sur les carrière
longue pour être tout à fait exact le
gouvernement a déposé le mardi soir de
la deuxième semaine de débat un
amendement identique aux amendements 45
1918 et 3407 visant à autoriser la
création d'une quatrième borne d'âge
ensuite à l'occasion du débat du
vendredi a été évoqué les pistes de
travail sur la question de la durée de
cotisation mais aucun amendement n'a été
déposé la deuxième précision que je veux
apporter concerne un propos que vous
avez eu toujours sur la méthode où vous
nous avez dit Madame
puisque c'était déposé dans le cadre du
47 Thirion le gouvernement aurait pu le
mettre dans le texte ce n'est pas le cas
ce n'est pas le cas puisque l'article
47-1 de la Constitution et la loi
organique qui le décline disent que le
gouvernement cadre de d'impossibilité
d'une des assemblée à aller au bout de
l'examen du texte transmet à l'autre
assemblée son projet de loi initiale
auquel il peut ajouter les amendements
de son choix mais à condition que ces
amendements étaient adoptés par
l'Assemblée saisie du texte dans la
mesure où l'amendement déposé le mardi
je parle de l'identique aux 45 1918 et
34 07 était déposé à l'article 8 que
l'Assemblée nationale n'a jamais
examinée n'a pas été adopté et donc le
47 terrain interdit au gouvernement de
le mettre dans le texte qu'il vous a
qu'il vous a transmis sur les différents
amendements il y a un propos général que
je veux faire avant de donner un avis
pour chacun en essayant d'être aussi
méthodique que la présidente de séance
le souhaite
le premier le point général concerne les
questions de coût puisque les
dispositifs de carrière longue au-delà
leur complexité de mise en oeuvre sont
des dispositifs qui sont coûteux si nous
retenons un principe qui consiste à dire
tout assuré qui a travaillé au moins un
trimestre avant l'année de ses 21 ans
était éligible au car au carrière longue
nous sommes sur un coup qui est
supérieur à 2 milliards d'euros si nous
disons c'est ce que Monsieur salvo Delhi
a proposé il y a un instant
qui consiste à dire la durée des 43 ans
non seulement supplante la question de
l'âge d'ouverture des droits mais en
plus doit intégrer non seulement les
trimestres cotisés mais aussi les
trimestres valides c'est ce qui a été
proposé par Monsieur le Sénateur
salvaudelli nous sommes sur un coup à 7
milliards d'euros et donc c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous n'avons pas
retenu si nous indiquons que tout assuré
qui a commencé à travailler avant des
bornes d'âge à hauteur de 5 trimestres
mais sans aucune
autre condition que d'atteindre 43 ans
nous sommes sur un coup qui est très
supérieur à un milliard et demi d'euros
et enfin si nous disons c'est ce que
disent les amendements qui arrivent à la
fin de l'allias pardonnez-moi j'en ai
oublié le numéro les trois moments 3103
et 3126 qui consiste à dire par rapport
à la situation existante où il y a trois
critères cumulatifs le fait d'avoir
tricotisé cinq trimestres avant une
borne d'âge le fait d'avoir atteint un
âge spécifique d'ouverture des droits et
le fait de se dispenser du troisième
critère qui est celui d'une durée de
cotisation nous sommes sur un coût qui
est supérieur à 300 millions d'euros
c'est l'état d'esprit de ce qui avait
été discuté le vendredi en fin
d'après-midi à l'Assemblée nationale et
donc pour ces raisons là j'appelle le
Sénat à faire preuve de beaucoup
d'attention parce que nous avons souvent
évoqué la nécessité de retrouver
l'équilibre budgétaire
une borne d'âge à 21 ans tel que nous le
proposons est tel que je le soutiendrai
dans un instant répondre à très
largement à votre préoccupation pas
entièrement mais assez largement sur les
amendements 45 1918 et 34 07 de Monsieur
Cabanel yakovelier de Madame ponce la
vie est favorable puisqu'il s'agit de
permettre la création d'une quatrième
borne d'âge et le gouvernement s'est
engagé la créer une borne d'âge à 21 ans
pour l'amendement 208 de Madame Müller
Brown il n'a pas été défendu merci
madame la Présidente pour l'amendement
il a été il est présenté il a été
indiqué
il n'est pas retiré il est parti et il
n'est pas tombé ça ne change
malheureusement pas la vie défavorable
pour les raisons budgétaires que j'ai
évoqué je ferai attention à écouter la
présidence des sciences plutôt que la
présidente de la commission désormais
pour
l'amendement 4336 présenté par Madame
assassy c'est une demande de retrait
madame la Présidente assassin
c'est une demande de retrait pour Madame
la présentatie sur le 43 36 parce qu'en
fait avec le 43 36 je pense que vous
n'atteignez pas l'objectif que vous
cherchez la disposition telle qu'elle
est dans le projet de loi permet
d'intégrer ce qui n'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui les trimestres cotisés soit
au titre de l'assurance vieillesse
parent foyer une partie des congés
parentaux soit au titre de la source de
l'assurance vieillesse pour les aidants
d'intégrer cette trimestre dans ce
retenu pour calculer le droit des
parents anticipé carrière longue et je
pense que c'est un progrès je propose
avec un amendement du Gouvernement
d'élargir ce progrès du régime général à
tous les régimes et votre amendement
supprimerait la possibilité de compter
ses trimestre d'aidant ou de parents au
foyer dans l'éligibilité au dispositif
carrière longue donc c'est retraits ou
défavorable l'amendement du Gouvernement
c'est évidemment un avis favorable
l'amendement 21-28 de Monsieur Savary
favorable le 35 80 de Madame ponce
défavorable pour des raisons budgétaires
le 21 29 de Monsieur Savary favorable
l'amendement de madame assassy et
pardonnez-moi madame la Présidente c'est
la même mécanique donc c'est la même
demande de retrait
l'amendement 21 30 de Monsieur Savary
c'est un avis favorable les amendements
31 03 et 37 26 des messieurs Cabanel et
chassassin sur les questions durée de
cotisation c'est le sens des discussions
que nous avons eu le vendredi à
l'Assemblée nationale avec cette
difficulté budgétaire du coup à 300
millions d'euros et la nécessité je
crois de trouver dans le cadre des
étapes suivantes du débat parlementaire
je pense notamment la commission mixte
paritaire l'équilibre financier donc à
ce stade ne souhaitons pas dégrader les
équilibres financiers du système à la
sortie de l'examen du texte au Sénat
c'est une demande de retrait même si le
débat doit se poursuivre pour
l'amendement de Madame Lubin le 3099 les
raisons budgétaires m'amènent à donner
un avis défavorable et enfin
sur le 33 92 et le 34 08 c'est une
demande de retrait pour les mêmes
raisons que celle que j'ai évoqué il y a
un instant
ce qu'il y a des explications de vote
sur Madame Lubin
tout d'abord monsieur le rapporteur
et Monsieur le Ministre d'ailleurs vous
parlez tout le temps de contraintes
budgétaires c'est bien la preuve on a
déjà dit mais je vais quand même le
répéter c'est bien la preuve que le
véhicule
législatif n'est pas le bon
non mais non parce que justement on ne
peut pas aborder toutes les questions de
des salariés qui arrivent en fin de
carrière
et qui ont du mal à terminer leur
carrière à ceux qui travaillent depuis
longtemps on ne peut l'aborder que sous
le prisme budgétaire puisqu'on est dans
une loi de finances de la sécurité
sociale or il faudrait aller bien
au-delà vous avez dit d'ailleurs j'ai
noté monsieur le rapporteur vous avez eu
l'expression il ne faut pas rater la
cible et oui nous y voilà parce que la
cible de ce projet de loi c'est bien les
travailleurs de longue durée si si c'est
bien là c'est bien ça le problème ce
projet de loi vous nous avez
suffisamment reproché la réforme
Touraine qui rajoute qui a amené à 43
ans de cotisations à partir de l'année
fallait-il vraiment puisque
effectivement tous ceux qui sont nés à
partir de l'année 73 devront travailler
43 ans fallait-il vraiment aller
chercher les autres qui sont ceux qui
travaillent forcément depuis le plus
longtemps donc vous parlez de rater la
cible on est justement en plein dans la
cible et ce projet de loi ne la rate pas
de cible c'est le moins que l'on puisse
dire ensuite un détail il faut dire la
vérité donc les 43 ans ça peut
effectivement en fonction du moment où
on est né ne plus être 43 mais 44 mais
dans le projet de loi aussi je citer un
exemple moi je suis né en 1963 je vais
avoir 62 ans donc en
je vais avoir 62 ans en 2025 donc il me
faudra après 62 ans et 9 mois sauf que
je suis né en juillet ah dommage donc 62
ans et 9 mois je peux pas les avoir
l'année 2025 je crois que j'attends de
l'année 2026 et donc en fait c'est un an
de plus pour moi c'est pas grave mais
pour mes copines de l'agroalimentaire
qui est viscères à des canards dans les
Landes je peux vous dire c'est pas
marrant du tout
[Applaudissements]
la présidente moi je rejoins
se rejoint la difficulté de monsieur le
rapporteur
a éclairé notre choix
je crois que ce que cela montre c'est la
difficulté effectivement d'atténuer la
brutalité de cette réforme quoi parce
qu'elle est évident que pour les départs
anticipés
qui ont quand même augmenté deux ans de
fait que ce soit pour pénibilité ou que
ce soit pour carrière longue
ça conduisait de telles aberration
travailler 44 45 ans de durée c'est à
dire bien au-delà du taux plein qu'il a
fallu que le gouvernement bricole
quelque chose de super compliqué et qui
d'ailleurs lui permettait de passer la
moitié de son temps d'explication de la
réforme a montré comment sur les
carrières super longues etc il avait
consenti des mesures sociales
et donc effectivement je veux dire toute
cette complexité vous avez dit c'est
illisible cette inégalitaire oui comme
la loi et là ça a tellement soulevé de
mécontentements et d'opposition qu'il a
fallu bricoler bon ben le bricolage si
tout le monde a suivi l'explication de
monsieur le rapporteur général
bravo alors les raisons budgétaires
effectivement les raisons budgétaires le
gouvernement n'accepte d'avoir veut 18
milliards de recettes et n'acceptent
d'avoir que des mesures d'atténuation de
la brutalité de la réforme qu'à hauteur
de 3 milliards et comme il dit que c'est
6 milliards parce qu'il s'est trompé et
il a pas il a cru que il avait avancé à
60 ans l'âge d'invalidité permanente et
donc il a chiffré à 3 milliards cette
mesure mais non comme c'était maintenu
ça avait rien à faire là et que le
tableau d'équilibre du coup qui arrive à
zéro en 2030
lui permet de dégager 3 milliards moi
j'ai 3 milliards voilà vous avez des
marges de manœuvre budgétaire et pour
accepter nos amendements vous avez 3
milliards
la parole est au président Retailleau
je voudrais expliquer le vote de notre
groupe sur cette série d'amendements
et je sais parfaitement les réticences
qu'à notre rapporteur qui sont à je
crois c'est partager par la commission
sur ces extensions sur les carrières
longues
nous votre en fait on va les calibrer
avec deux principes premier principe ne
pas faire perdre leur sens à la notion
de carrière longue deuxième principe
faire en sorte que la généralisation
quasi généralisation de la carrière
longue ne mettent pas à mal les
principes généraux de notre système par
répartition premier principe je disais
ne pas faire perdre aux carrières
longues leur sens pourquoi tout
simplement parce que une étude récente
l'a montré désormais il y a au moins la
même espérance vie pour ceux qui en
bénéficient par rapport à ceux qui n'en
bénéficient plus on est plus du tout
dans le système que François Fillon
avait inventé justement pour faire face
à un certain nombre de dispositifs en
2003 première chose la compensation de
la carrière longue pour une moindre
espérance vie ça n'existe plus voilà
donc ça c'est le premier point et
deuxième point on retrouve désormais
pour ceux qui bénéficient des carrières
longues des gens qui ont eu des métiers
peu pénibles avec des niveaux scolaires
conséquents ça n'est plus du tout ce qui
a été inventé le cadre et le dispositif
inventé à l'origine et vous voyez que en
étendant à l'infini des élèves de
Polytechnique qui sont rémunérés et qui
commencent à 20 21 ans pourraient partir
à 63 ans donc là là il y a un premier
problème ce qui veut dire que on
acceptera la borne de 21 et on votera
les articles les amendements là-dessus
en revanche pourquoi est-ce qu'on n'ira
pas jusqu'au 43 invités parce que là je
considère nous considérons que là du
coup la généralisation et l'écrasement
si j'ose dire des des bornes d'âge de la
mesure d'âge par rapport à la nuitée
fait perdre son sens à notre système
actuel le système actuel il repose sur
l'équilibre ou pardon un on a des durées
de cotisation et ensuite on a un filet
de sécurité avec l'âge c'est la raison
pour laquelle et pour être conséquent
pour ne pas trop dépenser financer la
mesure que nous avons voté tout à
l'heure pour les maires de famille on ne
votera pas les amendements à 43 ennemis
très bien est-ce qu'il y a d'autres
explications de vote monsieur va vendre
merci Madame ma présidente j'essaye de
comprendre président Retailleau vient
d'expliquer que on pouvait sortir de
Polytechnique et puis effectivement
bénéficier du système des carrières
longues je ne pense pas que tout le
monde ici est fait Polytechnique pour
comprendre le dispositif des carrières
longues que notre ami collègue René Paul
Savary s'était vertueux à nous
décortiquer mais à vous que c'est pas
simple j'ai bien compris compte tenu
effectivement qui a plusieurs paramètres
qui entrent en ligne de compte que c'est
le on renvoie au décret le soin de je
dirais réussir presque une mission
impossible c'est de maintenir une
certaine équité dans ce dispositif or ce
que nous avons demandé nous groupe santé
c'est qu'on lisse un peu le dispositif
alors je sais bien
ça peut avoir un coût mais la logique la
logique voudrait que quand on part à on
commence à 14 ans et avant
14 ans normalement
l'âge d'ouverture des droits et à 58 ans
ça conduit à travailler au moins 44
années
actuellement c'est 45 donc on peut dire
il y a un programme
vous vous commencez à 15 ans vous pouvez
partir à 58 aussi et là vous pouvez
effectivement avoir une durée de
cotisation qui n'est que de 43 ans
à 16 ans vous partez à 60 ans et vous
pouvez avoir une durée de cotisation de
44 ans donc vous voyez je peux continuer
comme ça jusqu'à 21 on a un dispositif
sinusoïdal
qui me paraît oui ou en marche vous
appelez ça comme vous voulez ça serpente
entre 14 et 21 ans avec des durées de
cotisations de 43 ou 44 avouez monsieur
le ministre que c'est pas simple à
comprendre si vous arrivez à convaincre
ici tant mieux en tous les cas je doute
qu'on arrive à convaincre la population
de que ce dispositif est équitable et
effectivement apporte un progrès social
évident merci Monsieur gay
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
heureusement qu'on a pas appliqué
l'article 38 sur l'explication monsieur
le rapporteur ce que même en 10 12
minutes on a été en incapacité de
comprendre en réalité le dispositif qui
nous était proposé et c'est vrai que
c'est dur et on vous a déjà posé la
question hier y compris à monsieur le
ministre c'est ce que vient de dire
notre collègue on ne comprend pas
pourquoi alors qu'il y en a qui vont
partir à 15 qui vont commencer à
travailler à 15 ou à 16 ans ils vont
pouvoir partir au même âge mais celui
qui ou celle qui a commencé à 15 ans va
devoir cotiser une année supplémentaire
par rapport à celui ou celle qui a
commencé à 16 ans et c'est la même chose
pour 17 18 etc et l'inverse il y a un
effet ciseaux qui ne fonctionne pas
parce que vous nous parlez d'équité
d'égalité bon ben celui ou celle qui a
commencé à 15 ans il faut qu'il le parte
avant celui ou celle qui a commencé à 16
ou à 17 ans ça nous semble une logique
implacable et puis pour répondre
aux présidents rotaïo là on parle des
carrières longues moi excusez-moi
peut-être qu'on rencontre pas les mêmes
mais celles et ceux qu'on connaît qui
ont commencé à 15 ou 16 ans c'est pas
tellement celle et ceux qui ont qui font
Polytechnique c'est en général c'est les
ceux qui font de l'apprentissage dans
les carrières sont dures avaient des
métiers difficiles évidemment ils
peuvent évoluer et heureusement mais
souvent ils se retrouvent aussi en fin
de carrière en incapacité et on revient
sur le débat de tout à l'heure ils
finissent une carrière mais pas en
activité et donc cette réforme elle va
doublement les pénaliser à la fin mais
aussi au début de leur carrière donc là
pour le coup si on peut avoir des
précisions et si le monsieur le ministre
peut nous expliquer l'effet de ciseaux
et pour dire surtout que cette mesure
c'est un statut quo et c'est déguisé en
progrès social mais ça ne l'est pas je
vous remercie
monsieur
merci madame la Présidente là j'avoue
très honnêtement
j'ai pas fait Polytechnique et du coup
je n'ai pas tout compris mais je
remercie le rapporteur qui a quand même
éclairé et détaillé un dispositif très
complexe puisqu'il y a des facteurs
multiples dans tous les sens des mesures
d'âge etc bon j'ai bien compris que si
on en restait au texte actuel on générer
quand même des inégalités et d'ailleurs
c'était souligné dans les débats est-ce
que certains doivent travailler plus
longtemps j'ai aussi compris une chose
c'est que au fond une ou deux reprises
le rapporteur nous a dit oui ce serait
plus juste mais ça coûte trop cher et
moi j'avoue que j'ai du mal bon d'abord
sans doute parce que je comptais cette
loi mais par ailleurs j'ai du mal à me
dire que nous voulons être juste mais à
condition que ça ne coûte pas trop cher
et là il y a j'avais d'ailleurs cru
comprendre que notre collègue Pradier à
l'Assemblée nationale essayer de dire il
faut faut pas être juste et puis mettre
la même durée pour tout le monde donc
moi je vous avoue n'ayant pas tout
compris je l'admets comprenant quand
même comme l'a dit mon collègue Fabien
gay que ceux qui commencent à travailler
à 15 ans ou à 16 ans c'est rarement ce
qu'on fait politique technique il y a
peut-être un surdoué qui a commencé
politique à 16 ans mais enfin ça doit
être assez rare par contre c'est plutôt
des gens qui rentrent des jeunes qui
sont rentrés dans l'apprentissage et
dans des métiers difficiles bah moi
j'avoue que je préfère la justice à
l'équilibre financier dans une loi juste
donc je voterai les amendements qui
défendent 43 ans pour tout le monde
monsieur le ministre
mais merci madame la Présidente
peut-être quelques éléments je l'espère
pour éclairer le débat d'abord de dire
en souriant à Madame Lubin mais vous
avez dit Madame Lubin c'est dommage nous
sommes dans un pays FFR donc ça donne
une connotation budgétaire je peux vous
assurer je veux manger je vous garantis
même que nous si nous étions que si nous
étions dans une un texte de loi
d'ordinaire j'aurais le même souci de
l'équilibre budgétaire en 2030 le même
parce que si on ne rééquilit pas le
système il ne tiendra pas et le fait
qu'on soit en PLF SS ou en PJL ordinaire
ne change pas l'approche qui est la
mienne ni celle du gouvernement sur
laquelle sur laquelle sur laquelle on
veut fonder l'équilibre ensuite pour à
la fois essayer de répondre
à Monsieur gay et à Monsieur Briet à
l'instant sur les carrières longues je
l'ai dit au tout début de notre séance
ce matin je crois lorsque nous avons
abordé cet article 8 aujourd'hui le
système c'est tel qu'il existe prévoit
de borne d'âge une borne à 16 ans une
borne à 20 ans mais il prévoit surtout
trois critères cumulatifs et un assuré
qui a cotisé cinq trimestres avant 20
ans peut partir à la retraite deux ans
avant l'âge légal donc aujourd'hui 60
ans mais à condition d'une part d'avoir
les cinq trimestres cotisées d'autre
part d'avoir atteint effectivement les
60 ans et en plus d'avoir atteint et
d'avoir réuni aujourd'hui 42 années 168
trimestres demain 172 trimestres et
uniquement des trimestres cotisés c'est
ce qui rend particulièrement juste la
remarque de monsieur le rapporteur
général de monsieur le rapporteur pardon
car monsieur le rapporteur dit que
finalement celles et ceux qui
bénéficient des carrières longues en
termes de départ anticipé porté à son
maximum d'anticipation sont celles et
ceux qui ont une carrière certes longue
mais particulièrement linéaire sans
exposition à des périodes de chômage
sans exposition des périodes d'arrêt
maladie qui excéderaient quatre
trimestres à l'échelle de leur carrière
et donc finalement ceux qui ont les
derrière les plus difficiles soit
marqués par la précarité soit marqué par
des problèmes de santé on sait que les
deux peuvent être liés sont écartés du
bénéfice effectif des carrières longues
puisque lorsqu'ils arrivent aujourd'hui
à 60 ans ils ne sont pas en capacité de
présenter si je peux dire de juste de
justifier les 158 trimestres pleinement
cotisés c'est pour ça que c'est pas un
effet ciseaux finalement c'est un effet
de perforateur et de mâchonnements parce
que il y a perforation dans la carrière
et il y a machanement de la borne de
départ tellement elle dépend des
situations individuelles et tellement
personne ne peut tracer un trait tout à
fait droit monsieur vanderenberg il a
évoqué aussi il y a un instant en disant
tout ça est un peu sinusoïdal en
fonction de l'âge auquel on commence dès
lors que les bornes d'âge se font deux
ans par 2 ans et pas un an par un an
votre votre raisonnement monsieur le
sénateur
tiendrait parfaitement dans la seule
hypothèse ou les assurer commencer à
travailler le jour de leur anniversaire
parce que s'il ne travaille pas le jour
de leur anniversaire mais s'il travaille
trois mois quatre mois cinq mois plus
tard au rythme d'une rentrée scolaire au
rythme de l'obtention d'un diplôme les
bornes explosent finalement en tout cas
tous les modalités de calcul explosent
et on arrive à des situations où oui des
assurés vont parfois travailler 44 ans
pour avoir droit à un départ alors que
d'autres seront piles à 43 ans mais la
plupart d'entre eux seront entre 43 ans
et trois mois quatre mois cinq mois en
fonction tout simplement de l'histoire
de leur vie il y a un point sur lequel
je vais inviter si vous me le permettez
le Sénat ne pas peut-être porter trop
d'attention en tout cas pas au delà de
ce qu'il en faut c'est la borne d'âge à
16 ans puisque monsieur le sénateur
avant le hunderg là aussi dit ceux qui
veulent ceux qui ont commencé à
travailler à 14 ans doivent pouvoir
partir beaucoup plus tôt et ne pas
nécessairement attendre 58 ans sauf que
ce cas de figure est devenu extrêmement
rare le départ avec mais j'ai au bout le
départ avec cinq trimestres valides
avant 16 ans concernent entre quelques
dizaines et un peu moins de 200
personnes par an aujourd'hui pour une
raison qui s'explique de manière
évidente c'est que l'obligation de
scolarité a été portée à 16 ans en 1959
ce qui signifie que ceux qui ont
commencé à travailler avant 16 ans
dérogeant à l'obligation scolarité soit
sont des assurés dans la liquidation
intervient alors qu'ils ont commencé
leur carrière avant 1959 c'est de plus
en plus rare d'une certaine manière
c'est assez statistique soit des assurés
qui l'ont fait avec un caractère très
dérogatoire et aujourd'hui ceux qui
commencent à travailler avant 16 ans le
fond dans des dispositifs généralement
de préparation à l'apprentissage qui ne
sont pas assujettis à cotisation et qui
n'entre pas dans ce cadre puisque
c'était c'est assimilé des périodes de
formation donc on est dans cette
équation là elle est évidemment
compliquée et surtout elle renvoie aux
carrières et à la construction de vie de
chacun avec un impact budgétaire
particulier c'est ce que je voulais
ajouter madame la présidente monsieur le
rapporteur
oui merci monsieur le ministre
vous avez compris la préoccupation juste
un point si on met 43 ans à tout le
monde ce ne sont plus des carrières
longues ce sont des carrières normales
donc il faut trouver un dispositif à ce
moment-là de carrière précoce de
carrière précoce ne l'oubliez pas plus
vous anticipez l'âge plus vous vous
accordez une durée longue de retraite à
ces personnes là donc il faut pas rater
la cible quand je dis la cible c'est ça
c'est celui qui veut quel métier pénible
moi à qui je pense qui a commencé de
bonheur et celui-là il est usé quand
même au bout d'un certain nombre
d'années c'est celui-là qu'il faut
essayer de cibler et ben c'est trop
compliqué
et ben le système qui est proposé
actuellement qui se base sur la même
philosophie comme certaines injustices
effectivement par rapport à mais ne les
gommes pas tous mais il engomme un petit
peu c'est pour ça que je demandais à
Monsieur le Ministre d'essayer de revoir
de créer un dispositif qui est en gomme
encore plus c'est inégalités et puis
vous dire simplement que si on part d'un
principe non pas que les 43 ans sont un
plancher mais que les 43 ans sont un
plafond pour équilibrer notre système de
retraite de par répartition déjà en
déséquilibre et qui conduit dans les
dizaines d'années qui viennent à ce que
les pensions des retraités relativement
par rapport au niveau moyen continue de
baisser
si on ne fait rien je vous le rappelle
et bien il faudrait il faudrait c'est
votre recette mais laissez-moi finir la
recette je suis en train de la mettre en
application
si on part de ce principe là pour
équilibrer le système et qui ne conduit
toujours pas à faire en sorte que les
retraités d'une pension meilleure c'est
45 ans qu'il faut comme durer de
cotisation pour tout le monde c'est 45
ans vous voyez c'est on peut faire un
raccourci mais dans le système qui est
bien complexe vous l'avez compris que le
système était complexe et bon on
n'arrive pas forcément à travers ses
propos à ce que l'on souhaite voilà
merci Monsieur Fichet
oui monsieur monsieur le ministre
monsieur le rapporteur c'est Monsieur le
Ministre moi je vous admire
tout à l'heure vous nous avez fait à peu
près 15 minutes exposé sur les départs
anticipés là là on a passé cinq six
minutes à comprendre la complexité des
carrières longues et je peux vous dire
c'est totalement incompréhensible pour
le citoyen lambda qui nous pose la
question en disant mais moi à quel
moment je pars en retraite pour ma part
je vois pas bien comment je pourrais lui
expliquer à quel moment il est dans les
cas hier longue à quel moment il a un
trimestre de plus un trimestre de moins
ou un chemise de push assez messe de moi
à quel moment il peut être considéré
dans les des parents typiques en tous
les cas ça devient extrêmement compliqué
extrêmement difficile je salue aussi le
travail du rapporteur qu'il est dessus
fait l'objet d'une démonstration assez
parfaite dans la compréhension des
mécanismes et je me dis que souvent on
parle de notre administration qui est
compliqué on dit mais je suis allé voir
l'administration d'abord c'est difficile
succéder aujourd'hui il faut prendre des
rendez-vous mais en plus il faut remplir
des dossiers et bien le dossier de
retraite des personnes qui sont
concernées par ce nouveau projet de
retraite là je leur souhaite vraiment
bien du plaisir mais je voudrais quand
même rappeler que pour tout ce qui
concerne globalement sur les départs
anticipés les personnes qui sont
frappées d'un handicap qui sont en
difficulté etc et invoquent quand même
travailler deux années de plus et c'est
ça qui m'inquiète et je crois que cette
réforme de retraite sera marquée par ce
dispositif là en plus de l'article 7 ça
veut dire que tout d'un coup les
personnes pour qui le travail est une
chose épanouissement mais parfois aussi
un exercice difficile sur le plan
physique ou sur le plan mental qui
mérite le retrait on va dire à 50-55 ans
parce que l'effort est double chez elle
et ben là maintenant non seulement il
est pas avancé mais il est reculé et
d'auront travaillé deux ans de plus et
ça c'est bien difficile à expliquer une
fois de plus je vous remercie
madame premier rôle
oui moi je voudrais m'adresser à
Monsieur du soft puisque vous venez
déclarer monsieur le ministre il y a
quelques instants que vous lui rassurer
madame Lubin en lui disant que ce soit
un PJL ou un pffss j'aurais eu le même
souci de l'équilibre et c'est bien là
que le bla blesse votre souci c'est
l'équilibre et en budget en matière de
budget un équilibre c'est un équilibre
entre les recettes et les dépenses et
vous vous ne privilégiez que la
diminution des dépenses vous ne voulez
pas entendre parler d'augmentation de
recettes
vous avez multiplié je ne vais pas y
revenir le dogme avec ce dogme de moins
d'impôts et d'exonération vous avez
multiplié les cadeaux fait au plus riche
vous ne voulez pas entendre parler de
recette vous nous avez tout refusé alors
oui moi aussi je préfère la justice à un
problème budgétaire donc tous ceux qui
ont eu 43 ans dans l'unité avant l'âge
de 64 ans doivent partir au bout de ces
43 ans nuités c'est une question de
justice
on touche merci on touche avec
cet article
à un sujet de clarté d'intelligibilité
de la loi pour nos concitoyens
il y a évidemment la question de la
justice et les exemples qui ont été
donnés par mes collègues montre à quel
point cette réforme dans l'ensemble de
ces aspects par son article 7 et sur
l'article dont on discute en ce moment
son vécus est vécu comme une réforme
injuste mais ce sujet quand même de
d'intelligibilité pour nos concitoyens
me paraît central j'ai reçu aujourd'hui
par mail comme vous tous sans doute
parce que nous sommes suivis par nos
concitoyens par les réseaux sur le
direct Public Sénat un cours mail d'une
habitante de sonner alors elle dit je
vis dans un mot près de Louhans et je
vous contacte concernant la réforme des
retraites et plus exactement sur le
début de son application pour les
personnes nées après le premier
septembre 1961 ce qui est mon cas et qui
auront trois mois de plus à faire je
trouve plus logique et en cohérence avec
l'ensemble de la démarche que le
démarrage se fasse sur une année pleine
pourriez-vous prendre en compte dans le
cadre d'une éventuelle négociation notre
première ministre madame borne est né
sur une période de 1961 qui n'est pas
concerné par la réforme peut-être
pourra-t-elle être sensible à cette
demande alors c'est une un exemple parmi
d'autres mais les gens n'y comprennent
rien la seule chose qu'ils ont compris
c'est que c'était injuste donc s'il vous
plaît est-ce qu'on peut quand même
essayer de faire en sorte que on se
prive de l'injustice de l'inutile
complexité et d'un sentiment
d'intelligibilité pour ceux qui auront à
vivre les effets de cette réforme
merci monsieur le Président renal
merci Madame le présidente moi je
à ce point des débats sincèrement et
malgré les efforts des uns et des autres
pour expliquer je salue tout à l'heure
l'explication de notre rapporteur
mais tout de même au final
j'ai l'impression qu'on vote tout un
aveugle
explique excusez-moi un aveugle sur le
coup des mesures l'équilibre des mesures
le bilan de ces mesures je ne sais rien
et ce qui m'a rassuré c'est que le
rapporteur d'une certaine façon
j'ai déjà dit je crois hier ou
avant-hier et honnête dans sa réflexion
c'est-à-dire quand il sait pas ou quand
il se dit qu'on pourrait faire mieux il
le dit et c'est une bonne chose on n'est
pas sur de la mathématique
identifiée claire on peut pas faire des
sommations mais quand même
départ anticipé
quelles sont qu'elles auraient pu être
les différents de propositions n'en sait
rien il y en a une sur la table on sait
pas exactement ce qu'elle coûte etc
carrière longue même combat on pourrait
faire mieux c'est pas très bon c'est pas
très bien c'est peut-être un peu moins
coûteux que si c'était mieux bon très
bien contraignant on nous dit 800
millions d'euros un milliard 200
millions on ne sait pas trop la tête
nous tourne
carrière progressive ça viendra plus
tard mais pareil on aura un coup mais
est-ce que c'est le bon etc bref moi ce
que j'aurais aimé monsieur le rapporteur
monsieur le ministre c'est qu'on est un
petit tableau
donc qu'est-ce qu'on fait là quoi
combien ça coûte les opérations et si on
faisait mieux combien ça coûterait et
qu'on ait un choix alors c'est le choix
sur les sucres on est bien d'accord
c'est pas le choix de la réforme la
réforme est contre mais c'est les petits
sucres pour faire passer pour faire
passer la réforme mais encore faut-il
qu'on ait un peu d'idées sur ces petits
sucres en fait ces petits sucres ils ont
été négociés ils ont été négociés dans
une salle noire et là ça apparaît mais
sans les chiffrages excusez-moi de vous
le dire
[Applaudissements]
monsieur Mérillou
depuis
6 jours j'écoute attentivement tout ce
qui se dit et ça me fait penser à ce que
disait Mitterrand il y a quelques années
quand je ne serai plus là il ne restera
plus que des comptables et des
financiers
monsieur le ministre vous êtes en
comptable et en financier vous êtes
chirurgical vous êtes sans état d'âme et
vous ne mesurez plus le coût humain de
vos arbitrages vous êtes perdu dans vos
arbitrages techniques dont
personnellement je ne comprends plus
grand chose mais le côté humain vous
l'avez totalement oublié en fait vous
êtes un Robin des bois moderne mais
inversé vous prenez au pauvres pour
donner aux riches et là je reconnais que
vous avez un certain talent dans ce
domaine vous êtes efficace constant et
c'est cela que je regrette
merci madame la Présidente bon encore
une fois on voit bien que ces
dispositifs sont faits pour finalement
combler des difficultés bon évidemment
moi je j'ai pas tout compris dans ce qui
nous est proposé ce que vous nous
proposez monsieur le rapporteur et
Monsieur le Ministre ce que je pense que
nos compatriotes ne concitoyens ne
comprendront pas non plus on vous a
trouvé toujours ce qui est important moi
ce que je retiens c'est que de toute
façon tout le monde va devoir travailler
jusqu'à 64 ans ou pas loin ou 63 ans
pour certains j'ai pas bien compris le
ce qui permettait de le faire mais on
vous a proposé quelque chose de bien
plus simple les sons la loi telle
qu'elle est actuellement et les gens
travaillaient jusqu'à 62 ans comme ils
le veulent comme ils le souhaitent et
puis ensuite s'ils veulent continuer à
travailler qu'il continue à travailler
et laissons les dispositifs de carrière
longue ou le départ anticipé tel qu'ils
sont je crois que c'est quand même le
plus simple et puis monsieur le ministre
je voulais vous dire vous nous avez dit
que cette réforme
elle n'est que même si jamais elle
n'avait pas été dans ce projet de loi de
finances rectificative vous auriez eu à
coeur l'équilibre de
financier pourquoi est-ce que vous ne
l'avez pas fait dans un autre dans une
autre projet de loi que celui-là ça nous
aurait permis d'avoir un peu plus de
temps mais on comprend bien pourquoi
vous l'avez fait au bout du compte
si monsieur le ministre
trois points madame la Présidente
d'abord pour dire au président rénal que
sur les différents scénarios proposés
par ses amendements j'ai donné les
chiffres et le coût la parole qui est la
mienne quand je suis devant vous pour
dire quels sont les coûts d'une mesure
proposée par les parlementaires ça puis
évidemment sur le travail de mes
services mais je n'ai pas la possibilité
et c'est plutôt heureux de modifier les
tableaux d'équilibre et l'étude d'impact
en même temps que j'annonce les coûts à
ce micro donc j'ai dit les coûts tout à
l'heure j'ai notamment dit le coup de
l'amendement des deux amendements dont
j'ai demandé le retrait à la fin de la
liasse que nous estimons autour de 300
millions d'euros mais j'essaye à chaque
fois que c'est possible et en fonction
des éléments dont je dispose de préciser
les coûts et j'essaye aussi d'avoir le
plus de clarté dans les explications que
j'essaye de donner au Sénat la deuxième
chose pour revenir sur le caractère
complexe et beaucoup d'entre vous ont à
l'instant dans les dernières
interventions dit je n'ai pas bien
compris j'ai peur de ne pas comprendre
ou finalement je ne comprends rien
oui c'est compliqué c'est extrêmement
compliqué et je tiens à dire puisque
beaucoup de sénateurs du groupe
socialiste nous ont presque fait ce
reproche de complexité que le système
des carrières longues a été créé en 2003
et que lorsque et je le répète je l'ai
voté comme vous cette loi lorsque la loi
Touraine a été votée personne ne nous a
proposé de modifier le système de
carrière longue à aucun moment ni de
créer la borne à 18 ni de créer la borne
à 21 ans ni de modifier ni modifier les
critères des éligibilité personne
personne ne nous l'a proposé et il y
avait une mesure de retour à 60 ans pour
les dispositifs de carrière longue mais
pas plus pas plus pas moins que ce qui
avait été prévu à partir de 2003 donc je
disais à un moment dans une explication
peut-être un peu emporté il y a quelques
jours que parfois j'ai le sentiment
qu'on nous reproche d'avoir le courage
de nous attaquer à ce que d'autres n'ont
jamais eu le courage d'ouvrir et c'est
le cas sur les carrières longues c'est
le cas sur les carrières longues et puis
enfin
et puis enfin
et enfin je termine je termine par
Monsieur Mériot je Mériot j'ai bien
écouté vos propos et vos mises en cause
personnelle je pense que c'est à peu
près du même niveau du même acabit que
les propos de votre collègue qui est
rouge qu'il a 48 heures ça me laisse
penser que comme beaucoup d'autres la
seule chose qui vous habite désormais
c'est la radicalité et une
mélenchonisation de l'esprit
madame Ferret
elle est sortie madame Cohen
Monsieur
Madame Cohen
alors nous au niveau du groupe
communiste dans ce débat là on est hyper
à l'aise parce qu'on n'a pas soutenu la
réforme Touraine on s'est battu bec et
on contre cette réforme extrêmement
mauvaise porte ouverte au suivant on
s'est battu avant contre les mesures
Fillon et on se bat aujourd'hui Monsieur
le Ministre contre votre effort alors là
je pense qu'on peut être salué applaudit
notre constance notre combativité et le
fait qu'on ne lâche rien voilà donc
c'est mauvais ça continue d'être mauvais
et tout ce que vous nous dit depuis le
début et bien conforte conforte nos
positions les gens majoritairement vont
perdre deux ans de plus et finalement
vous restez toujours fidèle à la même
logique c'est à dire que vous ne prenez
pas l'argent là où il se trouve vous
demandez les mêmes efforts au plus petit
au plus fragile et concernant les
carrières les carrières longues puisque
c'est le sujet pour ne trop m'éloigner
l'Institut des politiques publiques
montrent que le système dit des
carrières longues réservées aux
personnes ayant commencé à travailler
tôt ne profite pas principalement à
celles qui sont les moins qualifiées ou
les plus abîmés abîmés par leur emploi
donc si vous voulez on voit là qu'il y a
un vrai problème mais comme vous ne
prenez pas l'argent comment vous l'a
proposé avec des recettes nouvelles et
bien vous prenez le problème à l'envers
monsieur monsieur Durin pour un rappel
au règlement
oui madame la Présidente merci je suis
le ministre je
sais la charge de travail qui est la
vôtre c'est l'investissement que vous
avez eu ce texte quel que soit nos
options on peut que constater que vous
vous êtes dévoué pour la cause enfin
pour le coup je crois que la fatigue est
la lassitude
vous éloigne de la réalité de ce qu'a
dit notre collègue merylou à l'instant
dont on peut pas considérer que ce soit
le plus agressif des socialistes ici
présent quand on s'adresse à vous en
évoquant la politique que vous conduisez
je crois qu'il faut vraiment pas le
prendre pour vous à titre personnel
d'autant qu'il a interpellé le ministre
sur des choix politiques donc voilà il
va rester quelques jours de débat
jusqu'au dimanche soir notre esprit
n'est évidemment pas la mise en cause
personnelle de toutes les personnes qui
se trouvent dans cette hémicycle et en
tout cas notre collègue merylou a
développé des arguments politiques aux
quels notre groupe souscrit
merci Madame ma présidente
et notre rapporteur pour les
explications mais je rejoins ce qui a
dit mon collègue Fichet c'est
incompréhensible à expliquer à nos
concitoyens quand on est interrogé vous
avez inventé une espèce de fonction en
escalier sinusoïde et je vais faire un
parallèle en ce moment avec la
délégation aux entreprises et des
collègues on est en train de travailler
sur la simplification des normes moins
qu'on puisse dire c'est que la réforme
que vous nous proposez elle est loin de
simplifier les choses elle est complexe
et voilà pourquoi je pense que la
proposition de mamubain est une bonne
proposition pour simplifier les choses
merci Monsieur themal vous avez le choix
vous pouvez soit faire un rappel au
règlement soit intervenir dans la
discussion générale dans
l'indexplication de vote vous n'avez pas
fait encore
très bien
vous aviez les deux options merci madame
le Président pour ce choix-là je vais
prendre le premier choix c'est pour dire
à Monsieur le Ministre que nous
connaissons bien depuis des années donc
on peut se parler sincèrement et
honnêtement
nous fume camarades et c'est pas une
insulte même dans mes propos chacun
ensuite a droit de faire un parcours de
vie moi je ne juge pas je veux juste lui
dire que moi j'entends et je sais son
implication forte sa volonté de faire
avancer cette réforme et c'est son droit
le plus légitime mais monsieur Miss il
faut que accepter également et je libère
globalement que d'autres parlementaires
qui soient d'ailleurs quel que soit le
banc les bancs de cette hémicycle et
d'autres options d'autres opinions et
les portes tout simplement et c'est le
droit élémentaire monsieur miriou à
notre collègue Merion il a juste dit il
nous a pas cité il a évoqué la question
de François Mitterrand je crois que vous
et moi nous avons au moins ça en partage
en héritage ce qui était François
Mitterrand sont héritage il l'avait fait
part d'une vision potentiellement qui
arriverait après ne vous sentez pas
viser donc entendez bien monsieur le
ministre que nous avons pas la même
options que vous c'est vrai que quand
vous nous dites que c'est la seule
option nous considérons qu'à d'autres
options
par exemple le capitaine n'a pas été
inclus dans cette réforme là nous
conseillons notamment que là qu'on
évoque la question des fins de carrière
nous avons des visions différentes hier
notamment sur la question des étudiants
et leur possible de racheter leur
trimestre nous avons des visions
différentes d'un emportées par Monsieur
Cardon voilà donc à ce n'est pas en cela
une insulte épiquant vous dites quand
vous demandez à juste titre vous
demandez qu'on vous respecte
vous ne pouvez pas leur répondre que y
aurait pour les autres une
mélenchonisation des esprits parce que
ça marche un sens comme dans l'autre
d'abord nous sommes ici nous sommes ici
vous le savez bien pour mon colibri ou
moi-même socialiste et non pas et les
filles donc de rentrer pas dans ce jeu
là sinon ne vous n'avons pas y arriver
vous demandez le respect c'est légitime
entendez à être soyez respectueux de
l'opposition qui porte des arguments et
une vision différente de la vue de vous
pardon merci et la parole est à Monsieur
Julias
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur
ministre mais mes chers collègues je
partage totalement
ce que vient nous dire le président
rénal et je crois que il y a vraiment
une grosse défaillance dans dans votre
projet c'est qu'il n'y a pas
d'évaluation des conséquences de la
réforme sur la fonction publique et
notamment sur sur le déroulement des
carrières dans la fonction publique je
vais juste prendre un exemple il
concerne un domaine que je connais un
peu qui est l'enseignement supérieur et
là et la recherche il est évident
monsieur le ministre qu'avec
l'augmentation de l'âge moyen vous
augmentez aussi le gvt des
établissements de l'Enseignement
supérieur et de la Recherche et vous
savez le monsieur le ministre que le gvt
n'est pas compensé donc vous allez
rajouter une charge financière aux
établissements de recherche et aux
établissements d'enseignement je crains
sincèrement monsieur le mise j'ai pas
fait d'évaluation que ça remette en
question les engagements que vous avez
pris ici même dans l'hémicycle dans le
cadre de la loi de programmation de la
recherche là-dessus on aurait m'avoir
une analyse précise il va y avoir en
effet des grosses différences dans dans
la durée des carrières par ailleurs je
devrais pas le dire ça ici mais vous
donnez la possibilité à certains
fonctionnaires d'aller jusqu'à 70 ans
est-ce que vous avez mesuré exactement
quel pourrait être la charge pour l'État
merci madame la présidente madame Vogel
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre je voulais vous dire que si le
dispositif carrière langue est certes je
pense y compris dans cette hémistique
difficile à comprendre le plus
problématique c'est qu'il est surtout
très compliqué à expliquer aux
françaises aux Français qui nous
regardent et ça c'est un problème de
clarté de la loi et j'aimerais vous dire
que ce qui est important pour les
Françaises et les Français qui nous
écoutent c'est pas de savoir qui des
anciens socialistes des nouveaux
macronistes touché pas quoi ont voté ou
en papoter la loi Touraine mon père qui
a commencé à travailler à 15 ans il s'en
fiche complètement de savoir qui a voté
la loi Touraine et est-ce que ce sont
les mêmes qui aujourd'hui sont contre la
réforme etc ce qu'il aimerait savoir
c'est à quel moment il va pouvoir partir
à la retraite et ça je crois que c'est
c'est là où on a un problème et
j'aimerais vraiment vous dire que quand
on vous pose des questions simplement
pour vous donner l'occasion aussi
d'expliquer clairement pour que les gens
qui regardent à la télé les débats au
Sénat puissent comprendre tout
simplement à quel âge ils vont pouvoir
partir à la retraite en fonction à quel
âge ils ont commencé à travailler
il vous demande pas de nous dire si on
est devenu mélenchoniste ou pas je ne
comprends pas d'ailleurs comment ce
terme peut intervenir dans un débat où
on a simplement des gens qui je crois
très calmement demande des explications
factuelles sur un dispositif complexe si
c'est ça pour vous être mélenchoniste je
crois que ça dit plus de vous que de
nous
voilà
alors on va madame pansement je vous ai
pour un rappel au règlement d'accord
oui ben l'article 36 bis sur les propos
de Monsieur le Ministre quand même
monsieur le ministre hier Me reçu
retaillot a dit exactement la même chose
vous le dites aujourd'hui bon ça montre
une certaine collusion mais ce que je
pense c'est que vous regrettez vraiment
monsieur le ministre vous regrettez
vraiment que ce que vous avez
prétendument condamné l'Assemblée
nationale ne se passe pas au Sénat et
donc vous usez de la provocation
vous regrettez vraiment
que ça soit la droite qui monte qu'elle
ne voulait pas discuter de l'article 7
choses qui n'a pas pu être démontré à
l'Assemblée nationale vous regrettez
beaucoup que une à une on va vous
dégonfler vos fameuses mesures sociales
ces mesures qui ne sont que des
atténuations qui n'y arrivent même pas
d'ailleurs pour les carrières longues de
la brutalité de votre réforme et puis je
vous dirais monsieur le ministre c'est
un problème c'est un effet d'optique
comme dirait les médecins en fait vous
vous allez à droite monsieur Retailleau
il va à l'extrême droite alors c'est sûr
tout à fait on le verra pour
l'immigration ça le et sur les questions
sociales donc à partir de là quand on va
à droite et quand on va à l'extrême
droite il y a un effet d'optique y
compris les socialistes ils ont des
positions trop radicales et pour vous la
ridicalité s'est Mélenchon donc de
choses à intervé à terre c'est transitif
voilà mais c'est une preuve question et
cette provocation monsieur le ministre
ne l'attentez pas trop souvent bien nous
allons donc considérer que
attendez pardon monsieur Houlgate madame
d'abord
madame madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues Claude
Reynal a dit que nous avantion à
l'aveugle et ça ça me fait penser à une
maxime de sagesse qui dit que quand un
aveugle guide un autre aveugle il tombe
tous les deux dans le fossé je vous
envoie je vous envoie à l'admirable
tableau de BRUGEL l'ancien sur la
parabole des aveugles ça veut dire ça
veut dire d'une certaine façon aussi ça
veut dire d'une certaine façon aussi
qu'on ne peut pas être aveugle à l'heure
actuelle à l'inquiétude l'angoisse et la
colère qu'il y a dans la rue ça veut
dire aussi que nous avons un devoir de
clarification et de clarté dans dans les
différents textes et notamment
dispositifs que nous mettons en place
alors je comprends que le dispositif
carrière longue issu de la réforme de
2003 d'une certaine façon soit devenu
par décret une usine à gaz d'où la
nécessité de revenir à quelque chose moi
qui me semble simple justement c'est 43
années me semble simple alors on a cité
l'exemple des polytechniciens et c'est
vrai ils sont pas légion les
polytechniciens puisqu'ils sont salariés
de l'État dès leur première année
d'étude et bien il cotise et il pourrait
peut-être partir à la retraite plutôt
mais en général les polytechniciens ils
ont des fonctions qui sont des fonctions
responsabilités et il reste assez
longtemps dans dans leur poste par
contre on avait parlé et ça a été évoqué
à l'Assemblée nationale de du risque de
ce qu'on appelait le job d'été alors ce
job d'été des étudiants qui auraient
entre guillemets travaillés un mois par
ci un mois par là et qui leur donnerait
l'ouverture entre guillemets à des
trimestres et qui viendrait perturber
parce que c'est vrai que les étudiants
ensuite n'ont pas une carrière pénible
il faut se replacer peut-être dans le
contexte de l'époque chrono n'est pas
n'est pas n'est pas déclenché
le compteur mais n'en profiter pas donc
je vais pas profiter je termine
justement pour dire que la situation des
étudiants a complètement évolué et ceux
qui se penchent sur cette question
savent que désormais les jobs d'été
c'est une nécessité pour ses étudiants
et c'est aussi peut-être une des
conditions de la mixité sociale dans
dans l'enseignement dans l'enseignement
supérieur donc ne pénalisons pas ces
étudiants qui d'une certaine façon
auront fait des efforts et qui pourront
peut-être parce qu'ils auront cumulé des
trimestres partir un peu plus tôt
madame Ferret
merci
sur cette réforme et sur le sujet sur
lequel nous parlons depuis quelques
moments maintenant la question des
carrières longues le journal de mon
secteur Ouest-France à titré une réforme
dure à avaler oui elle est dure à avaler
cette réforme pour celles et ceux qui
tous on va dire même qui seront
concernés demain parce que pour tous ces
deux ans de plus votre réforme c'est de
reculer légal de départ à la retraite de
62 à 64 ans pour tout le monde y compris
pour les carrières longues et donc là où
aujourd'hui certains pouvaient partir à
60 ans et bien demain parce que vous
nous dites oui on a fait des efforts on
a tenté on a tenté oui on accompagne
celles et ceux qui sont en carrière
longue vous voyez bien il travailleront
moins que 64 ans mais il travaille en
plus qu'aujourd'hui il travailleront
plus deux ans demain puisque c'est deux
ans de plus pour tout le monde donc cet
article enfin en tout cas ce sujet
pardon qui est présenté donc comme
prévoyant des mesures d'accompagnement
pour prévenir les effets négatifs de la
réforme parce que véritablement cette
réforme est négative en fait c'est un
trompe l'oeil c'est un trompe là parce
que y compris lorsque la première
ministre a annoncé des mesures
d'assouplissement alors là on nous n'y
comprenions plus rien nous les
parlementaires qui sont dans le sujet
depuis de nombreuses semaines mais aussi
et surtout nos concitoyens qui ne savent
plus selon l'année à laquelle ils
doivent
envisager un départ selon l'année à
laquelle ils auraient commencé à cotiser
nous n'y comprenons rien ce que nous
comprenons ce que tout ce qu'on prenne
et vous disent c'est que pour demain ce
sera deux ans de plus pour tous et ça
c'est inacceptable
monsieur verzelen
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre on est à un moment qui me
paraît politiquement embêtant
et peut-être que on s'apprête à voir un
certain nombre de changements de vote
sur l'article 7 hier
pour ceux qui ont voté le décalage de 62
à 64 dans l'air il y avait quelque chose
sur l'aménagement des carrières longues
dans l'esprit de beaucoup il y avait si
tu as commencé vous avez commencé à
travailler avant 21 ans quand vous aurez
fait vos 3 ans de cotisation vous
pourrez partir on se rend compte que
c'est pas le cas et qu'on va se
retrouver dans ce tableau qu'on a vu
dans Le Parisien tous il y a quelques
semaines avec ce truc incompréhensible
de toi c'est toi toi c'est 44 selon la
date à laquelle tu vous avez démarré à
travailler
profondément à compréhensible on se
retrouve dans une situation on doit
voter ça et moi le premier je me
retrouvais demain dans une
circonscription enfin ou dans mon canton
on va me dire ben moi c'est quel âge
maintenant ça va être 44 pourquoi mais
j'ai pas compris je peux pas vous
expliquer donc un il y a la notion de la
commande de la justice de l'équité entre
les uns et les autres et deuxièmement il
y a la question de la lisibilité et
alors qu'il y a des notions financières
je l'entends mais on l'entends tous
parfaitement mais dans toute réforme un
il y a la compréhension et deux il y a
le degré d'acceptabilité il y en a qui
est cher de d'aller trop loin et de ne
pas trouver ce point d'acceptabilité ça
me semble un point extrêmement important
vous avez commencé à travailler avant 21
ans 43 ans de cotisation pour la ligne
c'est clair c'est simple et c'est juste
merci
[Applaudissements]
en 2010 un jeune député socialiste
s'opposait avec force au report de l'âge
légal de repart à la retraite à 62 ans
il écrivait sur les réseaux bien souvent
au sujet de la réforme verte
c'est un recul social pour qui commence
à travailler tard pour les plus
précaires les critères de pénibilité
sont flous de plus les contributions de
revenus du capital sont symboliques je
constate que la protestation se
radicalise dans la rue gagne tous les
terrains devant une réforme aussi
injuste soit elle ce député ministre du
Travail aujourd'hui il reporte la jeune
légale de départ de retraite à 65 ans
refuse de faire contribuer le capital et
la finance et ignore les messages de la
rue depuis plus d'un mois et demi
écoutez chez le ministre vous avez
balayé avec les 1200 euros pour tout le
monde ne savent pas marché vous n'êtes
pas crédible en fait moi ce qui me peine
beaucoup dans ce temps politique vous
parlez tout à l'heure de Monsieur
mélenchonisation de socialisme de si de
là moi ce qui me peine c'est que le
président Macron utilise avec cynisme un
fusible issu de la gauche pour faire
passer une réforme de droite dure pour
le plus grand plaisir de la droite
sénatoriale
monsieur le Président Retailleau pour un
rappel au règlement
article 38 vous poursuivez l'obstruction
nous avons pas voulu nous n'avons pas
voulu y recourir depuis plusieurs heures
je considérais que les carrières longues
c'est important nous nous sommes très
largement tous très très largement
exprimé et donc je demande l'application
de l'article 38
alors le président Retailleau a demandé
le présent à Taio a demandé
l'application de l'article 38 sur les
explications de vote sur l'amendement 43
34 selon la procédure je dois d'abord
donner la parole un représentant par
groupe
monsieur Chaumier
merci madame la Présidente moi je suis
pas étonné de l'invocation de l'article
38 on arrive à ce moment l'échange cher
président Retailleau amené à nos
collègues à faire remarquer justement
que il vote l'article 7 et il se réalise
après que sur la question des carrières
longues et ben en fait le compte n'est
pas du tout il faut pas il faut pas
chercher midi à 14h voilà pourquoi 8 de
nos collègues ont changé leur vote
depuis hier voilà pourquoi la majorité
en faveur de cette réforme et en train
de s'écrouler voilà pourquoi ça finira
par un 49-3 à l'Assemblée nationale et
nous avons ce débat surréaliste où il y
a quelques instants le ministre lui s'en
prend un de nos parlementaires lui qui
fait partie d'un gouvernement dont un
ministre fait des bras d'honneur à un
parlementaire à l'Assemblée nationale un
gouvernement dont la première ministre
est incapable de faire preuve d'autorité
de prendre une mesure comment
pouvez-vous accepter ça comment les
conditions du débat actuellement en
politique alors vous interrompez avec
l'article 38 parce que là vous êtes dans
cette difficulté de fond au fur et à
mesure que l'on débat des détails de
cette réforme et que vous entendez vous
entendez nos arguments mais vous
entendez dans vos départements nos
concitoyens qui parlent de leur
situation vous n'entendez pas les
polémiques techniciens vous entendez les
Français qui racontent chacun ce que
cette réforme va avoir comme conséquence
pour eux et en entendant ces Français
parce que je vous fais crédit d'être à
l'écoute de ce que raconte nos
concitoyens dans nos départements
respectifs et bien vous prenez acte vous
comprenez que cette réforme elle est
injuste le président Retailleau l'a dit
très justement tout à l'heure c'est une
réforme qui est particulièrement
dommageable pour les femmes et bien
voilà pourquoi vous interrompez le débat
avec l'article 38
merci Monsieur gay
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues monsieur le
Président rotaïo après
l'obstruction au silencieuse vous avez
fait un choix depuis deux jours le jour
de la mobilisation sociale énorme et
historique de faire de l'obstruction
réglementaire et maintenant vous passez
une nouvelle étape l'obstruction du
débat parlementaire parce que vous
activez l'article 38 au moment du débat
quand notre collègue armelen qui a voté
l'article 7 hier dit ou c'est abstenu
dit qu'il est en train de se poser des
questions et tout est en train de
s'effriter de votre côté alors que vous
avez la majorité écrasante ici au Sénat
vous êtes mis en minorité non pas par
que la gauche mais par le peuple
français qui s'est levé massivement et
vous utilisez le règlement qui est
normalement et je vous le redis le fait
d'organiser nos débats et notre vie
commune
régler une question politique par
l'autoritarisme pour retrouver une
autorité politique que vous êtes en
train de perdre chaque minute qui passe
dans ce débat démontre que l'injustice
est de plus en plus fragrante vous avez
déjà volé des deux plus belles années de
la vie au des millions de travailleurs
et travailleurs mais maintenant on en
vient sur la pénibilité et ce n'est pas
nous qui le disons c'est vos propres
camps que le compte n'y est pas et plus
nous allons nous enfoncer dans les
articles l'article 9 l'article 10
l'article 11 on va mettre au jour le
jour en réalité sur la place publique il
y aura pas 1200 euros pour tout le monde
ça sera une poignée que la pénibilité le
corps n'y sera pas et au fur et à mesure
pour museler le débat parlementaire
parce que vous voyez même que cette
grande majorité de droite qui est en
train de se réunir tout le monde et
certains de nos collègues ils voient
bien que c'est en train de s'effondrer
et donc au fur et à mesure soit ils vont
s'abstenir soit ils vont vous joindre le
camp de la gauche pour voter contre et
donc vous êtes en train par le règlement
politique et nous continuerons à assumer
jusqu'à l'échec de votre réforme
[Applaudissements]
si aucun autre groupe ne souhaite
monsieur le Président Gontard
merci merci Madame la madame la
Présidente
Bruno Retailleau n'était pas là hier
soir pour défendre son amendement
on a on a dû arrêter il a il a remis à
ce matin et puis ce matin on la redécalé
par contre il est bien présent il est
bien présent quand le débat devient
intéressant quand le débat ne va pas
dans son sens pour agiter le fameux
article 38 puisque c'est devenu c'est
devenu à la mode mais pourquoi encore
une fois pourquoi ça vient d'être ça
vient d'être dit dès que le débat tourne
pas dans votre orientation on voit bien
le doute ça ce qui s'installe on l'a vu
à travers le vote quand même d'hier soir
c'était le bleu n'était pas complet et
on voit bien que par-ci par là le doute
s'installe petit à petit que vous avez
du mal à assumer ce vote ce vote déjà de
l'article 7 qu'il va être difficile à
assumer chacun dans vos territoires que
là vous commencez à douter et donc dès
que ce débat là devient un petit peu
compliqué ben on agite l'article 38 et
puis on a des interventions nombreuses
des questionnements beaucoup de
questions et je m'adresse là à Monsieur
le monsieur le ministre c'est vrai que
sur ces questions chaque question la
réponse est Mélenchon je pense que c'est
peut-être un petit peu limité on demande
des réponses simples oui mais moi ce que
je constate c'est qu'à chaque fois
l'intervention de tout à l'heure
l'intervention de ma collègue Mélanie
Vogel tout à l'heure c'est qu'est-ce
qu'on répond aux gens qui nous demandent
qu'est-ce qui va se passer pour moi nous
n'avons pas de réponse et donc nous
sommes là en tant que parlementaire pour
avoir des réponses nous nous adressons
au ministre nous aimerions aussi avoir
vos réponses vos interventions qu'elles
modification c'est adressé aux
rapporteur nous n'avons pas non plus de
réponse moi j'aimerais effectivement
pouvoir retourner en Isère et les
nombreuses questions que je peux avoir
que ça soit par mail ou sur le terrain
pour voir avoir des réponses claires
nous n'avons nous n'avons pas vous voyez
bien que le doute s'installe et donc
vous a visité votre article 38 Merci
monsieur van derenberg
merci madame la Présidente bon je crois
que
on peut dire franchement que depuis
qu'on a commencé ce débat pas seulement
aujourd'hui tout le monde a eu
l'occasion de s'exprimer en long en
large et en travers sur tous les sujets
même à contretemps dire qu'on n'a pas le
débat c'est faux vous n'avez pas la
majorité ça vous aurait pile je peux le
comprendre mais c'est la réalité
parlementaire ça et donc il faut en
tenir compte
voilà c'est tout et je crois que il est
bon normal que on demande un moment on
dise stop avec l'article 38 que nous
offre effectivement le règlement du
Sénat alors sur le fond je sur le fond
nous suivrons effectivement les
rapporteurs c'est une question la vue
qui est compliquée qui vise à améliorer
la situation effectivement des carrières
longues donc le groupe centriste suivra
les rapporteurs et leur recommandations
avec l'engagement avec l'engagement de
Monsieur le Ministre de revoir en CMP
les modalités financières pour améliorer
effectivement le bilan financier de
cette opération merci
merci monsieur le sénateur je vais donc
métro voie conformément à la linea 3 de
l'article 38 la demande de clôture sur
les explications de vote sur
l'amendement 43 34 vote à malvet qui est
pour
c'est bon qui est qui est contre
qui
elle est adoptée je mets donc au voie
maintenant l'amendement monsieur le
ministre vous aviez demandé la parole
alors là vous n'en voulez plus
je mets donc aux voix la mandement 43 34
qui a reçu un double avis défavorable de
la commission et du gouvernement qui est
pour
43 34 qui est contre qui s'abstient il
n'est pas adopté nous passons maintenant
au 36 88 double la vie défavorable qui
est pour
qui est contre qui s'abstient il n'est
pas adopté le 26 35 qui est double vie
défavorable qui est pour
qui est contre qui abstiens il n'est pas
adopté nous avons maintenant trois
amendements identiques le 45 le 19 18 et
le 34 07 qui ont reçu un avis de sagesse
de la Commission et un avis favorable du
gouvernement qui est pour
qui est contre qui s'abstient ils sont
adoptés le 208 double avis défavorable
il est retiré le cas alors le 43 36 j'ai
un tout petit doute sur la vie leur
importe la vie de rapporteur c'est
défavorable
il y avait une ambiguïté je voulais que
ça précisé un avis défavorable du
gouvernement qui est pour qui est contre
qui abstiens il n'est pas adopté le 46
51 présenté par le gouvernement avec un
avis favorable de la commission qui est
pour
qui contre
qui s'abstient ils sont adoptés il est
adopté pardon le l'amendement de la
commission de 21 28 avis favorable du
gouvernement qui est pour
qui est contre qui s'abstient adopté le
35 80 tombe le 21 29 de la Commission a
reçu un avis favorable du gouvernement
qui est pour
quiconque qui s'abstient il est adopté
le 43-41 tombe également le 21 30 de la
commission rationalie favorable du
gouvernement qui pour qui contre qui
s'abstient adopter nous avons enfin deux
identiques 31 03 qui ont reçu un avis de
sagesse de la Commission et un avis
défavorable de la du gouvernement qui
est pour
banquer contre
qu'ils abstiens ils ne sont pas adoptés
et sur le 34 99 j'ai reçu une demande de
scrutin public
avec un double avis défavorable scrutin
est ouvert
dans votre personne ne demande à voter
le scrutin clos
vote en 344 exprimé 343 pour 93 contre
250 le Sénat n'a pas adopté je mets
maintenant au voie deux amendements
identiques le 33 92 et 34 08 qui ont
reçu un double avis défavorable qui est
pour
voilà qui est contre qui s'abstient ils
ne sont pas adoptés nous passons à trois
amendements identiques le premier c'est
le 113 qu'il défend madame mélo
je le retire
tirer d'accord le 1071 monsieur le
Président OK
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre sa collègue c'est tellement
bizarre corriger l'injustice le projet
de loi prévoit que les personnes qui
remplissent les conditions actuelles des
dispositifs carrière continueront de
partir à 62 ans les personnes qui ont
des carrières très longues c'est-à-dire
celles qui ont commencé à travailler
avant 20 ans pour en partir plus tôt
sourire d'avoir cotisé la durée
d'assurance requise majorée d'une année
144 ans aussi c'est avant devant lui là
ce que la durée de cotisation
n'est-quiète pas 43 ans c'est à dire
sans sans doute trimestres pour les
personnes qui justifient de travailler à
très longue ce qui ne mesure d'équité
pour ceux qui ont commencé à travailler
très tôt que c'est que nous voulons de
proposer d'adopter
le 46 47 qui est identique à celui de
présenter le président Rocket je pense
que je pense que vous avez un problème
de tableau moi je vois pas mais c'est
bon
Monsieur ferick Vous AVEZ LA PAROLE oui
effectivement merci Madame présidente
oui un amendement identique aux deux
précédents en tout cas celui qui a
présenté le président Ruquier c'est
l'union des entreprises de proximité du
Bas-Rhin qui a insisté je l'aurais fait
mais pour que cet amendement soit
présenté donc elle demande de prévoir
que pour toutes les personnes
justifiantes une carrière très longue la
durée de cotisation n'excède pas 43 ans
soit 172 trimestres merci quelle est la
vie de du rapporteur sur cet amendement
bah écoutez nous avons eu déjà le débat
largement là-dessus il se trouve que les
amendements par la séance sont mis
effectivement différemment mais ça c'est
comme ça c'est le processus législatif
je pense qu'on a tout le monde a compris
que dans le cadre actuel 43 ans n'a été
pas à la solution retenue il
appartiendra bien sûr au gouvernement de
bien préciser les choses en attendant je
ne développerai pas plus mais à vie bien
sûr défavorable monsieur le ministre
merci madame la Présidente c'est le même
avis pour monsieur le Président requin
en particulier puisque on essaye sur un
débat à 43 ans vous êtes sur un
amendement à 172 trimestres qui est
divisé par 4 doit faire quelque chose
comme 43 ans donc pour les mêmes raisons
que tout de suite très précédemment
c'est un avis des favoris
donc mettre aux voix
amandes de la Commission et du
gouvernement qui est pour
qui est contre
qui s'abstient ils ne sont pas adoptés
quatre amendements identiques on
commence avec le 30 rectifié qu'il le
défend
madame guidez
oui madame la Présidente cet amendement
vise à maintenir la possibilité de
prendre en compte des trimestres validés
assimilés l'article 8 du projet de loi
propose de ne plus retenir que
l'obligation d'avoir un certain nombre
de trimestres cotisés pour pouvoir
bénéficier de la retraite anticipée pour
les travailleurs handicapés certes la
réduit la durée totale d'assurance pour
bénéficier du dispositif mais cela
risque de rendre encore plus compliqué
l'accès aux dispositif car les
trimestres assimilés mais non cotisés
notamment au titre du chômage d'un arrêt
maladie d'un stage ne sont plus pris en
compte si la réduction de la durée
d'assurance totale exigée et bienvenue
cet amendement s'oppose à la suppression
de la prise en compte des trimestres
validés c'est inacceptable pour des
personnes qui sont largement touchées
par un chômage de longue durée et ont un
niveau élevé de fatiguabilité de
fatigabilité cet amendement prévoit donc
de continuer à prendre en compte des
trimestres valides validez assimilé mais
cette proposition doit aller de pair
avec un engagement du gouvernement à
diminuer la durée totale d'assurance et
la durée incompréhensible de cotisations
cet amendement a été travaillé avec le
collectif handicap je vous remercie
merci Monsieur Cabanel merci madame la
présidente depuis 2003 une possibilité
de départ un retraite anticipé dès 55
ans est ouverte sur handicapés qui ont
accompli alors qu'ils étaient atteints
d'une incapacité permanente d'au moins
50 % une durée minimale d'assurance dont
une partie cotisée les âges de départ en
retraite anticipé pour les travailleurs
handicapés fixés par décret ne devrait
pas changer ce que nous nous félicitons
par ailleurs la condition de durée de
d'assurance validée serait supprimé pour
ne laisser que la condition de durée
d'assurance cotisée grâce à ses
aménagements le nombre de bénéficiaires
du dispositif devrait passer de 2800 à
3300 personnes pour autant nous
craignons que cela ne rende l'accès aux
dispositif encore plus compliqué en
effet les trimestres assimilés mais non
cotisés notamment au titre du chômage
d'un arrêt maladie d'un stage ne seront
plus pris en compte ce qui risque au
final de pénaliser les travailleurs
handicapés plus largement touchés par du
chômage de longue durée aussi nous
proposons de continuer à prendre en
compte des trimestres validés assim ilés
amendement identique maintenant madame
Lubin c'est vous qui le défendez il est
défendu et le 32 90 madame ponce
oui il est il est défendu mais c'est
vrai que là c'était une mesure qui au
départ se voulait positif c'est vrai
mais qui a qui a qui provoque aussi un
autre problème et effectivement enfin je
voudrais vraiment préciser que ce n'est
pas acceptable si vous voulez de ne pas
de ne pas compter les trimestres
validés pour notamment on l'avait
signalé les personnes qui ont été
largement touchées par un chômage de
longue durée et qui ont un niveau élevé
de fatigue habilité donc effectivement
une mesure qui se voulait positive et
puis qui qui a une contrepartie très
négative qu'il faut à laquelle il faut
remédier merci et la vie du rapporteur
merci par le biais de ces amendements
effectivement on parle d'invalidité
c'est toujours très complexe et la
réponse automatiquement n'est n'est pas
simple et ni simpliste d'ailleurs je
pense quand même par rapport à des
dispositifs particulièrement complexes
de retraite anticipée on vient de s'en
apercevoir quand même pour la prise en
compte du handicap c'est tout à fait
identique vous pouvez pas trouver un
dispositif qui s'adapte à toutes les
personnes parce que le handicap quand il
vient de bonheur et il est consécutif
parfois d'un certain nombre de facteurs
accidentels et bien sûr il reste tout au
long du carrière mais c'est pas tout à
fait pareil que la quand vous tombez
handicapé arriver un certain âge en
moyenne en moyenne le handicap est à 46
ans donc vous voyez que si on met le
facteur de prise en compte des
trimestres validés on ne répondra pas on
ne répondra pas à ceux qui partent tard
c'est la raison pour laquelle j'ai pensé
enfin nous l'avons analysé j'ai bien vu
tous les amendements proposés par le
comité handicap il y a Philippe mouillé
qui m'a parlé de ça Jocelyne guidez elle
connaît bien le dispositif parce que
nous avons fait véritablement un travail
en commun Elisabeth Doisneau et moi-même
pour vous faire en sorte des
propositions qui sont les plus
cohérentes possibles en conséquence on
voit qu'il y a plus de personnes qui
seront concernées en prenant cette
disposition et puis compte tenu de la
complexité faut pas en rajouter là pour
une fois on trouve elle simplifié un peu
voilà on a simplifié donc c'est mieux
c'est la raison pour laquelle je donne
un avis défavorable à l'ensemble de ces
amendements au nom de la commission
après une large réflexion monsieur le
ministre
c'est le même avis j'ai développé un
exemple ce matin en réponse à Madame
assassy ou madame Cohen pardonnez-moi si
je confonds mais pour quelqu'un n'est en
1972 si nous ne changeons pas la loi il
faut pour prendre sa retraite à 55 ans
qu'il est validé 132 trimestre et que
sur ces 120 trimestres 112 soit cotisés
avec ce que nous proposons c'est de
garder uniquement les 112 trimestres
cotisés sans que la personne est à
justifier que 20 trimestres
supplémentaires auraient été validés
quand bien même il ne serait pas cotisé
et donc c'est une simplification qui va
permettre à plus de personnes en
situation de handicap d'accéder à ce
départ anticipé puisqu'on passe de deux
conditions cumulatives et
obligatoirement cumulative à une seule
condition qui est par ailleurs la plus
basse en termes de curseur donc
défavorable
bien pas d'explication de vote on je
suis aisé une demande de scrutin public
sur ses amendements il en reste trois
après leur retraite guidée la vie de la
commission est défavorable la vie du
gouvernement et défavorable le scrutin
est ouvert
plus personne ne demande à voter le
scrutin est clos
en 344 exprimé 343 pour 105 contre 238
le Sénat n'a pas adopté trois
amendements mission commune on commence
avec le 43 37 qui est un amendement
présenté par Madame assassy et son
groupe et donc c'est monsieur le
Président Laurent qu'il défend
bien dans la dans la merci madame la
Présidente dans la foulée de ce que nous
discutons depuis le début sur l'article
38 l'article 8 pardon l'article 8
où vous nous présentez systématiquement
des reculs sociaux comme des comme des
avancées sur les départs anticipés pour
carrière long on a eu le débat sur les
retraites progressives et maintenant
nous sommes sur la question de l'âge de
départ anticipé pour un validité
inaptitude notre amendement vise à
supprimer la limitation de l'âge de
départ anticipé pour invalidité et
inaptitude parce que dans les faits ce
que vous présentez monsieur le ministre
comme une avancée n'en est absolument
pas une aujourd'hui l'âge de départ à
taux plein pour invalidité est
inaptitude fixé à 62 ans alors vous le
maintenez à 62 ans et vous dites puisque
nous reculons l'âge de départ de tous
les salariés à 64 c'est maintenant une
avancée mais il n'y a aucune avancée
c'est le statu quo et la situation
actuelle et or sur cette situation nous
devrions au contraire réfléchir à faire
de nouveaux progrès puisque cette
catégorie de la population vit en
moyenne ce qui sont dans cette situation
vivre en moyenne presque 5 années de
moins que les autres traités et qui
touchent une pension en moyenne
inférieure à 30%. donc oui il y aurait
des choses à modifier oui il y aurait
des choses à améliorer sur cette
question mais ce que vous présentez
comme une avancée n'en est pas une elle
est le maintien de la situation actuelle
pour ses salariés voilà pourquoi nous
nous proposons de limiter l'âge de
départ anticipé pour invalidité
inaptitude ce qui pourrait ouvrir à
condition que ce soit complétée par des
nouvelles mesures que nous vous avons
déjà proposé que nous continuerons à
proposer qui soit calculée
différemment pour améliorer la pension
de ces retraités et les conditions de
leur départ en retraite merci
le 35 69 madame Poncet Monge
oui merci à ma présidente alors c'est un
moment visa associé le Conseil d'État ou
de décret qui fit fixeront les
conditions d'abaissement de l'âge pour
les assurer reconnus inapte au travail
ainsi que le taux pour les assurer
justifiant d'une incapacité permanente
mais je vous souhaite revenir sur les
inaptitudes rappelons que selon le
rapport de 2019 de la Haute Autorité de
Santé sur la désinsertion
professionnelle 95% des salariés
déclarés nets sont licenciés et ce
malgré l'obligation de reclassement à la
charge de l'employeur il s'ensuit alors
pour le salarié une perte durable
d'emploi qui est d'autant plus grande
pour les seigneurs d'après l'enquête
Emploi 2012 en 5 ans le taux de
licenciement pour inaptitude a fortement
augmenté et passer de 4 à 6
licenciements pour 1000 emplois en CDI
en outre selon l'adresse les départs
anticipés à la retraite bénéficient
davantage aux personnes sans incapacité
42% de ces dernières sont déjà retraités
dans l'année qui précède légal donc
elles sont parties effectivement
de façon anticipée contre seulement 19%
des personnes handicapées par ailleurs
aujourd'hui les départs anticipés au
titre du handicap restent très marginaux
est-ce que je comptais ajouter pour
l'inaptitude c'est que vous avez lors de
l'article 7 moqué et permis aussi qu'on
puisse pas en discuter les amendements
qui comptaient exclure certains métiers
de l'application de la loi du reportage
de d'ouverture des droits de 62 à 64 ans
ces âge-là enfin ces métiers là aide à
domicile ouvrier du bâtiment Auxiliaire
puériculture caissière que vous avez
fait tomber vous aurez pourtant permis
d'entendre que dans ces métiers on parle
plus en inaptitude quand on retraite
normale et donc on vous aurait donné les
taux d'inaptitude de ces métiers et leur
évolution notamment dans les métiers que
je connais de l'aide du soin et de
l'aide du soin donc c'est bien dommage
que vous les ayez fait tomber compte
tenu de ces implications merci
quelle est la vie du même pensé manger
ce que vous pouvez nous dire un mot
aussi du 35 68
merci même la présidente alors nous nous
pensons le groupe écologiste pense
urgent de renforcer le dialogue social
dans les entreprises dans les branches
professionnelles
que vous avez d'une certaine façon
monsieur le ministre rompu avec cette
réforme injuste en restant sourd
notamment à une inter syndicale au
complet et uni il s'agit donc ici de
réinvestir en quelque sorte les corps
intermédiaires rentrer dans ce corps
que vous n'avez d'ailleurs pas écouté
lors du quinquennat précédent le
président Macron parlait alors d'une
forme de dialogue social nouvelle pour
le deuxième voici une proposition visant
ainsi associé les partenaires sociaux et
passer des paroles aux actes afin de
répondre véritablement aux enjeux au
plus proche du terrain les organisations
syndicales doivent jouer un rôle
primordial premier dans la gestion des
départs anticipés en matière
d'incapacité toutes les organisations
syndicales par ailleurs je le rappelle
vous demande de retirer votre effort il
est ils ont lors de la sixième journée
d'action contre la réforme des retraites
du 7 mars réunis je vous le rappelle 3
millions et demi de personnes dans la
rue qui en fait la mobilisation parmi
les plus importantes depuis 1995
elle s'appelle par ailleurs à la
mobilisation le 11 mars vous avez encore
du temps pour retirer votre réforme je
vous remercie quelle est la vie du
gouvernement
de la Commission
le rapporteur
sera un avis défavorable effectivement
l'inaptitude
nous avons après consultation justement
de toute les études et documents qui
existent par rapport à cela concernant
tous les métiers Madame raymond-ponce
nous avons pensé maintenir à 62 ans le
deuxième amendement le 35 69 ça renvoie
un décret en Conseil d'État avis négatif
quand tu as une concertation préalable à
publication du décret n'importe où
gouvernement de l'organiser donc là
aussi avis défavorable merci monsieur le
ministre mais ma vie sur l'amendement 43
37 je suis saisie d'une demande de
scrutin public par le groupe CRCE je
vous rappelle que sur cet amendement la
vie de la Commission et du gouvernement
sont défavorables des avis
le scrutin est ouvert
plus personne ne demande à voter le
scrutin est clos
vote en 344 exprime mes 343 pour 92
contre 251 le Sénat n'a pas adopté
nous passons maintenant à trois
amendements identiques oh pardon faut
que je fasse voter les deux toutes mes
deux autres toutes mes excuses sur le 35
69 qui est pour
qui contre qui s'abstient une n'est pas
à adopté les deux reçoit un W
défavorables sur 35 68 même vote même
vote trois amendements identiques on
commence par Madame guidez pour le 29
oui madame la Présidente
l'alinéa 19 de l'article 8 du PDF RSS
vise à supprimer la possibilité que les
assurances situation de handicap
puissent bénéficier d'une retraite à
taux plein quelle que soit leur durée de
cotisation à 65 ans c'est un moment
demande de maintien de cette possibilité
en effet selon le premier article de
l'article L 351-8 du code de la sécurité
sociale les assurés justifiant d'une
incapacité permanente au moins égal à un
taux fixé par décret qui atteignent
mentionné à l'article
l161-17-2 bénéficie du taux plein même
si le justifie pas de la durée requise
d'assurance ou de période équivalentes
dans le régime général et un ou
plusieurs autres régimes obligatoires
l'alinéa 19 de l'article 8 vise à
abroger le premier TER de l'article et
du code de la sécurité sociale le
président amendement à l'objectif de
maintenir ses droits existants pour les
personnes en situation de handicap quel
que soit leur durée de cotisation
puisqu'elles ont souvent des carrières
hachées cet amendement vise donc à
supprimer la Nina 19 de l'article 8 du
plafet SS merci la parole est maintenant
madame Lubin
et maintenant
qui le défend chez vous madame waranas
si madame la Présidente
personne si fiente d'une incapacité
permanente peuvent à partir de 62 ans
partir à la retraite avec un taux plein
quel que soit la durée de cotisation or
vous supprimez monsieur le ministre vous
proposez la suppression de l'alinéa 19
de l'article
l3508 du code de la sécurité sociale et
j'avoue que s'achète le trouble je
rappelle que le rapport souligne que
cette garantie ne changera pas et
l'étude d'impact à bond d'ailleurs dans
ce sens si les assuré atteint d'une
incapacité de travail n'ont pas la
possibilité de bénéficier actuellement
d'un des parents dissipés il bénéficie
en revanche d'une retraite autoplin des
62 ans et ce quel que soit la durée de
cotisation validée cette dernière
possibilité est maintenue pourquoi
supprimer cette alinéa même si nous
comprenons que renvoyait un article ou
la limite d'âge est augmentée de deux
ans placerait les personnes en
incapacité permanente dans une attente
inutile nous souhaitons nous souhaitons
que cet âge soit mentionné à l'article
l351,8 du code de la sécurité sociale
parce que ça va mieux en l'écrivant
monsieur le ministre
merci
qu'elle me sera porteur allez-y oui
merci on voit bien la difficulté du
débat parce que ces amendements sont
identiques mais madame guidès n'est pas
hors sujet elle perdue handicap quoi que
quoi et vous parlez d'incapacité
permanente il y en a un qui est lié au
travail et pas l'autre alors si vous
modifiez si vous supprimez le 19 le
premier terme et qu'il a brogit c'est
parce qu'on le retrouve dans l'article
la linéa20 voilà donc il y a pas de
confusion il me semble-t-il mais
monsieur le ministre sera plus précis
que moi donc il y a pas du tout de
remise en cause ce qui concerne ces âges
anticipés soit du côté de l'incapacité
permanente soit du côté de l'inaptitude
donc je pense que vous pouvez retirer
tout à fait l'amendement
monsieur le ministre
merci
je vais donc mettre au vois avec
ils sont
vous le maintenez
retrait pour vous Madame Lubin du côté
du président canner
est-ce que vous maintenez l'amendement
je peux pas vous souffler là
on dirait et
nous passons maintenant à un amendement
et un sous-amende en faisant l'objet
d'une discussion commune
je vais commencer par l'amendement
monsieur lévrier
si madame la Présidente c'est simplement
un amendement de coordination qui vise à
permettre aux assurés nés entre en 62 et
en 63 de pouvoir toujours partir en
retraite anticipée pour carrière longue
selon les conditions actuelles avec
pension à taux plein
merci le sous amendement
du rapporteur à cet amendement tu es une
correction d'erreurs matérielles madame
merci pouvez donner votre avis sur
l'amendement
de précision pourquoi pas donc à vivre
favorable monsieur le ministre
favorable également
je vais donc mettre au voie d'abord le
sous amendement de rapporteur sur cet
amendement qui est pour
qui le défend madame Cohen merci madame
la Présidente nous proposons par cette
amendement d'inscrire dans le texte que
les conditions de départ pour carrière
longue et les conditions de départ
anticipées en retraite soit l'objet
d'une négociation préalable avec les
organisations syndicales et patronales
quoi de plus normal me direz-vous mes
chers collègues le texte propose à ce
stade que la condition d'âge prévue au
premier alinéa soit abaissée d'au moins
deux ans ce que nous approuvons mais
dans des conditions fixées par décret
nous pensons nous qu'il faut associer
les organisations syndicales d'autant
que le gouvernement ne cesse de mettre
en avant qu'il y a eu effectivement
qu'il y aurait eu trois mois de
concertations et le résultat on le voit
dans la rue avec un front syndical qui
n'a jamais été aussi uni donc on voit
bien que votre réforme est rejetée en
bloc par l'ensemble des salariés que la
contestation continue à juste
mais peut-être que nous pouvons en tout
cas tenter ensemble de remettre un peu
de concertation au moins sous forme de
cet amendement et donc j'en profite
d'ailleurs pour pour dire que en tout
cas au niveau de notre groupe nous
souhaitons que la demande de
l'intersyndical d'être reçu par le
Président de la République soit entendu
positivement mais en attendant un
premier pas serait de reconnaître le
rôle des corps intermédiaires et je
pense que ça ferait du bien à notre
démocratie sociale et c'est l'objet de
cet amendement
bien alors à cet amendement que vient de
défendre madame Cohen il y a des sous
amendements
d'abord celui de Monsieur Gontard
oui merci merci madame la Présidente cet
amendement de madame assessi qui vise à
consolider les dispositions qui seront
prises par décret à l'aide d'un avis
éclairé préalable qui intervient de
manière complémentaire avec les
négociations avec les organisations
syndicales et patronales quant aux
conditions de départ pour carré long il
y a aux conditions de départ anticipées
en retraite dans le texte
chacun de ces amendements qu'on a listé
ajoute une institution parce que nous
pensons que c'est important que ça soit
la consultation de la Chambre de
commerce de la paix de l'AFPA de Cap
Emploi du Conseil d'État du comité de
suivi des retraites il nous semble
important de venir justement préciser
dans ce texte l'ensemble des
institutions qui seront qui seront
consultés on sait que ces choses seront
ensuite par décret et on a quelque chose
qui nous dit qu'on a plutôt intérêt à le
mettre dans la loi pour faire en sorte
que le gouvernement consulte directement
ces institutions on a eu le cas
mon collègue Daniel Breuillet là la
signification plusieurs reprises sur le
Conseil d'État donc je pense que c'est
important en tout cas qu'on signifie
qu'il soit qu'il soit consulté et donc
c'est un complément à l'amendement de
Madame de Madame présenté pas Madame
assassin pour ajouter l'ensemble de ces
institutions merci monsieur le Président
comptin on est d'accord que vous nous
avez présenté les sous amendements de
5228 à 5240 ou parce qu'ils ont été
regroupés
nous sommes nous sommes d'accord madame
la Présidente voilà comme ils sont
regroupés par auteur merci maintenant
madame poncer Monge pour les sous
amendements 5241 à 5253
défendu sur l'ensemble des sous
amendements ensuite madame le Président
idem
pareil défendu monsieur salmon défendu
ah non monsieur salmon je vous donne la
parole
5267 à 5279
oui merci madame la Présidente je vais
défendre l'ensemble de ma Dias de
sous-amendement je vais pas les faire un
par un mais je vais quand même apporter
un certain éclairage puisque c'est sous
abondement vise à associer largement
pour éclairer les dispositions prises
par le décret et je profite donc cette
de cette défense pour également éclairer
sur certains propos que j'ai entendu
venant des bancs de la droite vous
invoquez très souvent le bon sens pour
l'invoquer même à tout moment mais je me
pose la question le bon sens en ce
moment est-ce qu'il est vraiment sur vos
bancs à droite ou est-ce qu'il est dans
la rue il y a vraiment une interrogation
à ce sujet là peut-être qu'on aura des
réponses bientôt et quelques autres
éléments la démographie vous expliquez
tout à travers le prisme de la
démographie et ce prisme est très
réducteur prenons quelques chiffres en
1950 il y avait cinq actifs pour un
retraité en 2020 1,7 actif pour un
retraité
des chiffres qui sont souvent avancés
mais il faut les croiser avec la
productivité
en prenant une base 100 en 1950
productivité pour un travailleur sans
en 2015 productivité pour un travailleur
ça permet de relativiser ce paramètre
démographique ce productivisme il est le
fruit du machinisme de la robotique du
progrès technologique dont vous êtes
très friand à quoi bon ces progrès si ce
n'est pour réforme après réforme que le
temps passé à la retraite se réduisent
comme peau de chagrin
le progrès technologique ne serait donc
pas au service de l'homme mais un
facteur d'asservissement d'hommage ne
serait-ce pas parce que la richesse
produite est captée par une minorité
encore une question peut-être aura-t-on
les réponses tout à l'heure
la démocratie est un paramètre comme
l'âge de départ ce nombre est le nombre
d'années de cotisations vous restez
comme le disait ma collègue Raymonde
qu'on sait manche sous votre lampadaire
sans rechercher d'autres caractères
d'autres paramètres à activer merci
merci
monsieur l'abbé maintenant
défendu merci Monsieur Fernique
la présidente si vous m'y autorisez je
me propose de regrouper mais sous
amendements successifs pour lesquels je
n'ai forcé de pas dépasser le temps qui
met un parti donc ce bouquet de
sous-amendement vise à consolider les
dispositions qui sont prises par décret
à l'aide d'un avis éclairé préalable qui
intervient de manière complémentaire
avec les négociations avec les
organisations syndicales et patronales
quand on conditionne le départ pour
carrière longue et aux conditions de
départ anticipées en retraites dans ce
texte donc chacun de ces amendements
propose la prise en compte de la vie
d'une institution ou d'un corps
intermédiaire je crois que il nous faut
aider le gouvernement à trouver le
chemin de l'écoute de l'écoute des
partenaires sociaux des institutions
prises directes des corps intermédiaires
et cela en amont de la publication du
décret merci de votre attention si
monsieur défendu monsieur brouiller
monsieur benaroche
ok donc si j'ai bien vu on en a fini
avec les sous amendements
je vais donc demander
ok
la vie de la Commission sur ces sous
amendements
alors la vie de la commission sous les
sous amendements puisque il y a une
différente liste de
d'organismes à consulter
nous pensons qu'il est déjà un peu tard
si vous voulez de les consulter et que
ce soit sur le plan des organisations
syndicales sur le plan des parlons des
organisations syndicales ou patronales
représentatif tantôt niveau national
qu'au niveau
interprofessionnel nous pensons que pour
discuter
négocier même
[Musique]
travailler sur le thème des agent
anticipés il appartient qu'il y a une
large concertation quand on établit de
décret il importe au gouvernement c'est
de responsabilité de tenir compte de
tout cela donc sur le plan de cette
concertation nous sommes d'accord mais
pas forcément au niveau du Crès c'est
avant qu'il faut le faire parce qu'il
faut prendre en même temps que les
mesures d'agent anticipées qui sont des
mesures de réparation faut bien sûr
négocier des mesures de prévention vous
êtes attachés à la prévention voilà
c'est pour ça que je donne un avis
défavorable mais
mais vous vous changez vous parlez du
décret en changeant un mot sur l'alinéa
24 mais l'alinéa 24 est rattachée au 23
qui fixe celui par décret bien entendu
les
âges de départ anticipé des
professionnels libéraux
voyez-vous il n'y a pas de raison de
faire des mesures différentes pour les
professionnels libéraux ou pour les
autres donc il y a une erreur il y a une
erreur au départ moi je vous je me
permets de dire où la vie défavorable
sur retirer l'amendement parce que ça
correspond pas à ce que vous souhaitiez
merci
quelle est la vie du gouvernement
merci madame la Présidente j'ai le même
avis que monsieur le rapporteur la
rédaction des amendements et des sous
amendements tout ça fait que ce que vous
proposez ne concernerez que les sujets
concernant les professions libérales je
ne suis pas sûr que soit l'objectif que
vous poursuivez une fois que je dis cela
je d'une part que le gouvernement a mené
une concertation n'a pas permis de lever
tous les désaccords d'autre part c'est
l'occasion pour moi de dire devant le
Sénat que la totalité des organismes
dans la consultation est obligatoire
telle que prévu par les textes a
évidemment été consulté et que dans le
cadre des concertations à venir au titre
de l'article de la partie L1 du Code du
travail bien évidemment nous mènerons
toutes les concertations un
professionnel nécessaire
merci s'il y a-t-il des explications de
vote
non mais merci
monsieur le ministre pour les pour les
pour les réponses et les explications
effectivement mais c'est vrai que c'est
important que que l'ensemble des
organismes soient consultés mais du coup
nous nous retirons nos amendements merci
monsieur le Président donc nous voilà
maintenant monsieur le Président Laurent
oui merci mon explication de votre porte
sur l'amendement le
une fois de plus cet amendement
à travers cet abonnement nous portons
une question qui est un
problème majeur de tout ce que nous
discutons
nous demandons dans cet amendement
que les dispositions soient prises après
négociation pas consultation après
négociation avec les organisations
syndicales et patronales représentatives
au niveau national et interprofessionnel
alors tout ce que nous discutons là
porte un problème global c'est que cette
négociation n'a pas eu lieu en aucun cas
abouti sur l'ensemble de ces
dispositions donc nous ça nous sommes
non seulement face à un problème majeur
pour faire la loi mais si nous
continuons à avancer comme ça avec la
situation qui est en train de se créer
dans le pays un moment où les
organisations syndicales représentatives
je ne sais pas si on mesure la gravité
de ce que ça veut dire sont obligés de
dire que le seul la seule personne avec
laquelle elle veut le discuter
maintenant c'est le président de la
République
c'est dire quand même que nous sommes
face à une crise quand même majeure de
discussions de négociation avec les
organisations syndicales
et on nous dit que c'est parce que notre
amendement est peut-être mal placé mal
rédigé si c'est le seul problème vous
pouvez assez aisément nous aider à le
sous amender probablement monsieur le
rapporteur je pense que comme chacun
sait qu'il y a un défaut
de construction majeure dans ce projet
de loi on ne veut pas évidemment au
stade où on est le corrigé mais à force
de ne pas le corriger et de ne pas
écouter tous les amendements que nous
avons fait dans le même esprit depuis le
début vous êtes en train de provoquer
une crise majeure qui n'est pas prête
s'étendre dans le pays si vous continuez
comme ça donc peut-être qu'il y a un
petit défaut de rédaction dans notre
amendement mais ce qui est certain c'est
que nous mettons le doigt sur un
problème qui lui est assez fondamental
et qui va dépasser qui va conduire un
blocage qui n'est pas près de s'éteindre
qui n'est pas près de se lever si vous
ne corrigez pas le tir
j'ai été saisie sur cet amendement 43 31
d'une demande de scrutin public par le
groupe CRCE les deux avis sont
défavorables et le scrutin est ouvert
personne ne demande à voter le scrutin
est donc clos
votant 344 exprimé 3032 pour 92 contre
240 le Sénat n'a pas adopté madame ponce
c'est à vous pour le 35 73 merci Madame
ma présidente alors nous souhaitons
quand même alerter si le projet de
réforme maintient le dispositif de
retraite anticipée pour les travailleurs
handicapés il
renvoie un nouveau décret pour fixer
l'âge de départ anticipé le collectif
handicap demande à ce que ce soit fixé
enfin que ce soit fixé à 55 ans l'âge de
départ en retraite anticipée pour les
travailleurs handicapés directement dans
le code de la sécurité sociale
de plus afin d'accéder à la retraite
anticipée pour handicap à 55 ans il faut
remplir deux conditions cumulatives nous
en avons parlé validé une certaine durée
d'assurance trimestre cotisée trimestre
assimilé le gouvernement propose de ne
plus retenir que la condition de durée
cotisée et c'est bien c'est un progrès
mais seul mais cela réduit la durée
il ne réduit pas la durée totale
d'assurance pour bénéficier du
dispositif dès lors la durée de
cotisation restant la même elle est nous
comptons le dire trop longue enfin le
report de l'âge légal de départ à la
retraite à 64 ans va pénaliser les
personnes en situation de handicap
qui ne peuvent pas bénéficier des
dispositifs des radiatoires c'est quand
même les collectifs qui le disent quand
j'entends que tout va bien parce que
c'est maintenu à 55 ans parce que celle
qui ne bénéficient pas des dispositions
dérogatoires
qui n'enblissent pas les conditions
administratives et qui rencontrent de
grandes difficultés pour se maintenir en
emploi jusqu'à l'âge de départ elle
elles auront une augmentation d'après
l'INSEE en 2018 les personnes
considérées comme handicapées car
fortement limité dans les activités de
la vie quotidienne liquide leur retraite
à 62,4 ans en moyenne donc et plus tard
que les personnes sans incapacité
étant par ailleurs moins souvent un
emploi elle pince écoutez bien en
moyenne 8,5 années sans emploi ni
retraite après 50 ans contre un an 8
pour les personnes sans incapacité et
cet écart c'est accru depuis 2013 sous
l'effet de la réforme des retraites de
2010 alors défendre les personnes
handicapées c'est aussi cela et pas
simplement le passé ne profitez ne
profitez pas d'un de mes moments
d'absence s'il vous plaît c'est pas bien
quelle est la vie de la Commission sur
cet amendement
applicable professionnelle libéraux donc
c'est un avis défavorable un simple
décret suffira
défavorable également
des feuilles vertes sont quelque chose à
voir avec ce qu'on fait maintenant ou
pas
je vais donc s'il n'y a pas
d'explication de vote je vais donc
mettre au voie cet amendement 35 73 qui
a reçu un double avis défavorable qui
est pour
qui contre qui s'abstient il n'est pas
adopté le 35 75 madame pensez Monge
merci madame la Présidente alors c'est
amendement comme tous ceux qui visent
les écritures réglementaires de la borne
d'âge pour les inaptitudes et
l'invalidité par décret est un
amendement d'appel qui cherche à
s'assurer que ces bornes d'âge seront à
l'avenir bien conservés et qu'elle ne
bougeront pas car en effet il nous
semble que tout est possible monsieur le
ministre je crois que vous avez failli
les modifier car dans le rapport sur les
objectifs de la réforme vous affichez le
non report de l'âge comme une mesure
sociale donc je pense qu'un moment donné
vous avez dû penser effectivement
augmenter de deux ans comme un effort de
votre part je vous rappelle que vous
comptabilisez d'ailleurs 3,1 milliard en
2030 donc de façon tout à fait étonnante
sauf si vous comptiez leur mettre deux
ans de plus c'est que vous y avez
renoncé mais dans ce cas là faut enlever
les trois milliards
déjà concernant l'âge d'ouverture des
droits en 2019 monsieur le Président
Emmanuel Macron déclarait qu'il était
hypocrite de décaler l'âge et voilà que
quatre ans plus tard nous discutons d'un
projet qui fait exactement l'inverse
alors comment croire la parole de ce
gouvernement comment être assuré
il faut plutôt être rassuré que les
dispositions réglementaires qui sont
prises seront tenues maintenus non
modifiées lorsque vous voudrez à nouveau
augmenter
les gains d'une nouvelle réforme donc
les associations ne veulent pas que les
dispositions de maintien de l'âge pour
les invalider une apt passe par décret
précisément parce que la confiance
envers ce compte ce gouvernement a été
un peu atterré merci
nous pensons effectivement qu'un simple
décret suffit qu'il n'y a pas besoin
d'un décret en Conseil d'État
non mais c'est surtout que ça crée une
espèce de confusion sur la séparation
des pouvoirs
milles excuses mais je crois que la
fatigue peut être commence à gérer
donc avec ce Wii défavorable je suis
saisi une demande de scrutin public sur
cet amendement 35 75 par le groupe
écologiste solidarité de territoire le
scrutin est annoncé dans le palais et
ouvert
tout le monde a voté plus personne n'en
a voté le scrutin est donc clos
votant 344 exprimer 344 pour 91 contre
253 le Sénat n'a pas adopté et nous
passons à deux amendements faisons
l'objet d'une discussion commune 28 64
madame Pomerol
oui merci madame la Présidente nous
connaissons le faible niveau je dirais
même le très faible niveau des retraites
agricoles a-t-elle ancienne que
d'ailleurs nous avons légiférer
récemment concernant ces retraites
agricoles suite un petit peu à l'appel
Chassaigne à l'Assemblée nationale
le travail agricole est particulièrement
pénible il est responsable de nombreux
de nombreuses pathologies en particulier
dans les troubles musculo-squelettiques
et a fortiori si on a eu une carrière
longue qu'on a commencé tous qui souvent
le cas dans les métiers agricoles c'est
amendement vise donc à supprimer le
décalage à 62 ans de l'âge de départ
anticipé à la retraite pour ces
travailleurs agricoles qui ont eu une
carrière longue merci Madame
penser mon
merci madame la Présidente alors c'est
amendement vise à s'assurer que
l'intention du législateur sera
respectée sur ce projet après avoir
refusé d'écouter les organisations
syndicales enfin vous les avez écouté
mais vous ne les avez pas entendu pour
être plus précis après avoir décidé
d'utiliser la procédure d'examen
contraint dans le temps qui implique
l'article 47 1 de la Constitution
le gouvernement procède à de multiples
recours à des décrets en raison
notamment de l'importance du décret
mentionné ici et des difficultés de
prise en compte des points de vue des
acteurs concernés et nous semble il
semble indispensable au groupe
écologiste
que le Conseil d'État soit associé à
l'écriture de ce décret par cet
amendement le Conseil d'État sera ainsi
saisi du projet préparé par le
gouvernement et son avis devra être
recueilli après une consultation des
organismes dont la vie est souhaitée je
vous remercie merci quelle est la vie de
la Commission sur ces deux amendements
rapporteur est-ce que Monsieur
rapporteur c'est pour un avis merci oui
sur les deux amendements voilà le
premier concert effectivement les agent
anticipés les départs anticipés pour les
professions
agricoles et salariés agricoles et les
dispositions relatives que vous
souhaitez supprimer n'irez pas me
semble-t-il dans le bon sens c'est pour
ça que je donne un avis défavorable ce
second là aussi c'est une histoire de
décret en Conseil d'État nous pensons
qu'il vaut mieux rester sur le décret
tel qu'il est actuellement mis sur le
texte merci donc la vie monsieur le
ministre mais ma vie
[Musique]
de s'il n'y a pas d'explication de vote
on va passer au vote par scrutin public
que de 2864
avis doublement défavorable c'est le
groupe SR qui demande le scrutin public
le scrutin est ouvert
personne ne demande à voter le scrutin
clos
votre en 344 exprimé 343 pour 95 contre
248 demande de scrutin public également
sur le 35 84 cette fois-ci initiative du
groupe écologie c'est territoire les
avis sont toujours
défavorables et de scrutin est ouvert
plus personne ne demande à voter le
scrutin est clos
votre 343 exprimé 343 pour 90 comptes
253 le Sénat n'a pas adopté nous avons
maintenant un amendement 35 et 79 de
Madame poncer Monge
merci ma présidente se présente un
moment vise sur un autre sujet associé
le Conseil d'État au décret qui fixera
le taux minimum d'un capacité permanente
permettant de justifier d'un départ
anticipé à la retraite ainsi que les
conditions d'abaissement de l'âge pour
les personnes reconnues inapte au
travail selon le ministère du Travail
je cite l'inaptitude est déclarée
lorsque aucune mesure d'aménagement ou
d'adaptation de votre poste de travail
actuel est possible qu'en est-il dans
les faits de cette inaptitude déclarée
lorsqu'une mesure d'aménagement ou
d'adaptation de du poste de travail
n'est possible ce qui n'est pas
mentionné effectivement c'est que selon
le rapport de 2019 de la Haute Autorité
de Santé sur la désinsertion
professionnelle
95% des salariés déclarés inapte sont
licenciés et ce
malgré l'obligation de reclassement à la
charge de l'employeur ils s'ensuit pour
le salarié une perte durable d'emploi et
bien sûr beaucoup plus grande pour les
seniors
si le chiffre de 100 000 salariés
déclaré inapte à leur poste et
régulièrement avancé de façon parcelle
il n'existe d'ailleurs aucun chiffre au
niveau national qui consolide ce
phénomène donc il faudrait inciter les
entreprises s'engager sur des politiques
opérantes de prévention en amont de la
déclaration de licenciement pour
inaptitude mais également s'assurer que
la recherche de reclassement a bien été
menée et pour cela il ne faut pas
réduire alors il faut arrêter de réduire
il faut augmenter désormais les moyens
de la médecine du travail et de
l'inspection du travail
merci
quelle est la vie de la Commission sur
cet amendement
de créer en Conseil d'État au lieu d'un
décret simples donc la vie défavorable
monsieur le ministre même avis je vais
donc mettre amendement qui a reçu un
double avis défavorable qui est pour
quiconque qui s'abstient il n'est pas
adopté nous passons maintenant au 35 87
madame ponts et Monge
merci madame la Présidente alors cet
amendement d'appel
ne vise évidemment pas contester la
situation des anciens prisonniers de
guerre où il valait de guerre c'est vite
c'est victime fut celle passer ou
récente ont le droit à notre entière
considération au disposition les plus
favorables afin de tenir compte de leur
situation là bien sûr n'est pas le sujet
le sujet de cet amendement ce sont les
dispositions réglementaires que le
gouvernement peut décider de prendre et
c'est la défiance désormais qu'on a le
droit d'avoir envers un gouvernement
pour décider de tout ce qui a trait à
l'âge après ce qui s'est produit sur
l'article 7 et alors même que lors du
précédent dans quelques NAS a été dit
mais il faut
utile de le rappeler le président de la
République s'était engagé à ne pas
dégager là décaler l'âge pardon le
décalage de l'âge peut être moduler à
tout moment et l'on voit qu'il suffit
par exemple que
la Commission européenne demande de
nouvelles économies qui que nous nous
continuons nos impôts pour que nous en
arrivions à faire de nouvelles réformes
structurelles sur les dépenses publiques
et celles de notre sécurité sociale et
face à cela nous ne pourrons même pas
nous protéger derrière le Parlement
puisque le 47 ans pourra de nouveau nous
contraindre comme nous le vivons
actuellement
la défiance la méfiance qui s'est créée
qui est partagée par les associations ne
pourra être qu'alimentées par la façon
dont les débats peuvent tourner et donc
nous proposons que le Conseil d'État
prennent ces décrets merci
et monsieur le rapporteur votre avis est
même peine à vider favorable monsieur le
ministre
je mets aux vois ce 35 87 double la vie
défavorable qui pour
pardon qui est contre qui s'abstient il
n'est pas adopté nous passons 35 91
madame ponce c'est vous
je suis désolé
personne ne dépose pas ses amendements
donc du coup
voilà merci madame la Présidente
consultez pour avis à propos du peller
SS pour 2023 je rappelle que le Conseil
de la Caisse nationale de solidarité
pour l'autonomie a émis un avis
défavorable
parmi les causes avancées les mesures
qui concernent les personnes en
situation de handicap voilà un extrait
de la vie de la CNSA
j'ouvre les guillemets il leur apparaît
en effet contestable de présenter
certaines mesures de statu quo ou de
faible avancées telles que le maintien
de la retraite anticipée pour inaptitude
à 62 ans et pour handicap à 55 ans ou la
réduction de la durée d'assurance
nécessaire pour accéder à la retraite
anticipée comme des progrès sociaux je
crois que sur ces bancs nous vous
l'avons longuement dit et c'est partagé
par la caisse
avec des taux de chômage et de pauvreté
la gèrement largement supérieur à la
moyenne nationale une fatigabilité
importante et des carrières en dent de
scie les personnes en situation de
handicap sont fortement pénalisées par
le report de l'âge de la retraite et je
ne parle pas de ceux qui peuvent
bénéficier de l'âge dérogatoire à 55 ans
la réforme proposée n'apporte donc pour
la majorité des membres du Conseil
aucune réponse à la hauteur des enjeux
puisque c'est quand même le sujet et va
même renforcer la précarisation de ces
personnes en effet les personnes en
situation de handicap en emploi sont
nettement plus âgés que la moyenne elles
occupent plus souvent des professions
peu qualifiées et travaillent davantage
à temps partiel on retrouve un petit peu
de caractéristiques de gens pour les
femmes selon l'INSEE en 2020 parmi les
personnes reconnues handicapées
61% sont employés ouvriers et 32 sont un
temps partiel le taux de chômage de ces
personnes atteint 14% . en 2022 il y
avait
460131 demandeurs d'emploi en situation
de handicap j'ai fini voilà merci madame
la Présidente
monsieur le rapporteur vidé favorable
monsieur le ministre alors je suis Suzy
je crois d'une demande de secrétaire
public sur cet amendement 35 91 par le
groupe écologie solidarité de territoire
le scrutin est ouvert
personne ne demande à voter le scrutin
est clos
votant 344 exprimé 344 pour 91 contre
253 le Sénat n'a pas adopté nous avons
ensuite un amendement de coordination
présenté par la commission c'est le
Ministre n'y voit pas d'inconvénient
à la maman de coordination vous n'êtes
pas contre même presque pour
plutôt favorable voilà et si l'assemblée
non plus ne va pas d'inconvénient on
pourrait considérer qu'il est adopté
et nous allons maintenant passer à
l'article 8 alors je vous rappelle que
il y a eu sur cet article une demande de
clôture et qu'il y aura une explication
de vote par groupe
j'ai déjà madame Lubin
nous votre rencontre
cet article parce que nous considérons
que les salariés les les plus ceux qui
travaillent depuis longtemps vous
connaissez mon argumentation seront les
premiers pénalisés par cet article et
même si le bénéficieront toujours de
reports anticipé par rapport à la
nouvelle borne d'âge qui sera mise en
place par ce projet de loi il n'empêche
qu'ils verront leur durée de travail
prolongée jusqu'à deux ans maximum et
puis je vais vous donner une autre
raison pour laquelle nous allons voter
contre et je vais vous lire
je rappellerai juste je rappellerai
juste que c'est un décret du président
Hollande prit le 3 juillet 2012 qui a
remis en place la retraite partielle à
60 ans pour un grand nombre de Français
qui ont pu depuis bénéficier de carrière
longue il faut rendre à César ce qui est
à César
merci Madame Cohen
merci madame la Présidente ce n'est pas
un scoop notre groupe le groupe
communiste républicain citoyen
écologiste votre a contre cet article 8
vous avez refusé tous nos amendements de
suppression donc vous n'êtes pas étonné
en fait ce qui est présenté ici dans cet
article comme une avancée sociale à
savoir des départs anticipés pour
certaines et certains travailleurs mais
souvent que le simple maintien du statu
quo j'ai beaucoup déjà parlé dans cette
hémicycle des femmes et l'amendement
présenté par Bruno retaillod n'a pas
amélioré la situation il a amorti un peu
les conséquences pour quelques-unes de
ces femmes dans un rapport de ligase
d'octobre 2022 il est souligné que les
femmes et les hommes déclaraient en
situation d'inaptitude ou de handicap
c'est-à-dire donc des situations où il
est incompatible de rester dans le
maintien un poste de travail vive 4 ans
7 mois de moins que les autres pour les
hommes
les quatre ans un mois de moins pour les
femmes sans compter que leur niveau de
pension sont plus faibles du fait de
parcours particulièrement chaotique elle
est ils sont touchés en moyenne elles
ils touchent pardon en moyenne 30% de
moins que les autres de plus le
gouvernement maintient à 58 ans l'âge de
départ pour celles et ceux ayant
commencé à travailler avancés
par la réforme on voit bien là que cet
article 8 et dans le prolongement des
articles que nous avons étudié depuis le
début et notamment de l'article 7 c'est
à dire qui aggrave les conditions de vie
qui aggravent en fait ce que vivent les
Françaises et les Français donc pour
toutes ces raisons nous voterons contre
cet article
merci
y a-t-il d'autres explications de vote
madame ponce
et bien imaginez-vous que je crois que
je vous en ai quand même beaucoup dit et
je reviendrai pas il suffit de reprendre
un petit peu l'ensemble de nos
amendements pour voir nous ce qu'on
pense de de ces mesures d'atténuation de
la brutalité de la réforme alors
ça a été calculé quand même pour les
départs anticipés dans les carrières
longues
les scientifiques disent enfin ceux qui
ont travaillé les statistiques les
départs anticipés pour carrière longue
vont régime général augmenté de deux ans
sauf pour les carrières super longues et
toutes les mesures d'atténuation de la
brutalité que vous avez donc vous avez
les parler et dont vous parlez
massivement sur les médias et que du
coup une fine et
selon les catégories je parle des
carrières longues là ça va correspondre
à un allongement de six mois minimum à
un an et demi pour les carrières longues
donc y compris les mesures d'atténuation
de la brutalité de la réforme et je
rappelle que pour les départs pour
pénibilité là ces deux ans ferme
merci chers collègues la parole est à
Philippe mouillée
merci monsieur le Président je ferai une
intervention rapide simplement pour vous
dire très naturellement que nous allons
voter le groupe la républicain et la
majorité statale va voter l'article 8
alors je n'aurais pas dans le détail de
ces articles qui est compliqué parce
qu'on a vu que pendant le débat on a eu
à la fois des précisions sur les
carrières longues on voit bien que c'est
une grande complexité et je tiens à
celui d'ailleurs le travail de ne
rapporter parce que aujourd'hui on voit
bien qu'il y a une maîtrise parfaite de
la situation et nous avions besoin de ce
regard de professionnels pour pouvoir
faire une une idée précise de notre
positionnement politique sur ce texte je
reverrai pas sur tous les éléments nous
avons essayé à travers cet article
d'apporter une plus-value une
plus-valotique initiale portée par le
gouvernement avec des mesures pour
provenir je dirais faire en sorte
d'apporter quelques mesures de justice
sociale alors certains diront elles sont
pas suffisantes pour nous c'est quand
même une vraie plus-value je pense très
naturellement la surcote de 5% pour les
femmes je pense également à toutes les
carrières anticipées personnelles donc
on voit bien que nous avons essayé de
balayer au maximum les situations les
plus complexes pour faire en sorte que
nous puissions par la touche du Sénat et
par le travail de nos rapporteur et de
la commission apporter gérer des mesures
qui sont juste et qui doivent améliorer
en tout cas l'acceptabilité de ce texte
merci chers collègues la parole est à
Monsieur Hainaut
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Ministre dans la même veine nous
allons voter cette cet article je crois
que depuis
tout celles et tous ceux qui se penchent
sur le texte de réforme de retraite sont
à la recherche d'une volonté de trouver
des mesures qui viennent introduire de
la justice alors c'est vrai pour les
seniors c'est vrai pour les femmes et
c'est vrai pour les carrières longues
nous voterons cette article parce que ça
a été dit par le sénateur Jean
laurenberg ça a été dit par un certain
nombre de d'entre nous la question des
carrières longues et de la pénibilité
est une réalité même si comme ça a été
aussi exprimé ça a beaucoup évolué ça va
continuer d'évoluer et je pense que
l'intérêt de ce dispositif parce que
bien évidemment comme dans tous les
domaines il y aura d'autres après nous
d'autres personnes d'autres
parlementaires qui se pencheront sur les
systèmes de de retraite les Sochaux sont
jamais figées et il me semble que ce
qu'on fait là concerne à la fois ici et
maintenant mais aussi pour demain parce
que on a une vision et on a une capacité
de de s'adapter à ces changements dans
le dans la réalité de la vie
professionnelle et des carrières donc
c'est tout l'intérêt de cette article 8
et du travail qui a été fait par les
rapporteurs merci
Monsieur Chassin
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président
nous sommes d'accord aussi pour bien sûr
adopter favorablement cet article 8 qui
met à disposition si vous voulez des
articles concernant les départs
anticipés pour carrière longue la
retraite progressive pour état de santé
du concernant l'état de santé des
personnes handicapées
prises en compte aussi des trimestres au
titre de l'assurance vieillesse des
parents au foyer ou des aidants
assouplissements des conditions d'accès
des travailleurs handicapés en abaissant
à 50% et aussi favorable bien sûr à la
proposition de la du rapporteur pour
permettre aux maires de famille de
partir plus tôt donc nous sommes très
favorables à cet amendement
j'ai été saisi d'une demande de scrutin
public sur le vote de cet article 8 par
le groupe CRCE et ser
le scrutin est ouvert
le scrutin est clos
nombre de votants 344 exprimé 339 pour
245 contre de 94 le Sénat a adopté
passons aux articles additionnels après
l'article 8 l'amendement 2223 monsieur
iacovelli
oui monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
actuellement vous le vous le savez les
trimestres acquis pour l'éducation des
enfants peuvent être partagés entre les
parents si la demande en effet avant le
quatrième anniversaire de l'enfant
on est tous attachés à l'égalité et à
favoriser l'égalité femme homme et on
voit aussi une réalité c'est que le
deuxième parent s'implique de plus en
plus dans l'éducation de l'enfant et
donc c'est amendement vise à élargir les
effets enfin là je de la demande pouvant
ainsi aller